CALLING THIS HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
ORDER OF THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. DONALD HERE THE DONALD
HERE KILEY. KILEY HERE BENNETT
AND HERE DALLY. LEE HERE LEAVE
HERE MCCARTY RICK SILVA. AKORN
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED TO I'D
LIKE TO WELCOME THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO TODAY'S HEARING WE
HAVE SEVENTEEN BILLS ON FILE
AND FIVE ARE ON CONSENT THE
MEASURES ON CONSENT ARE AS
FOLLOWS EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS AB NINE
FOUR FIVE AB ELEVEN TWELVE WITH
AMENDMENTS AB FIFTEEN SIXTY. F.
FIFTEEN SIXTY A. C. R. FIVE
THREE PLEASE NOTE THAT WILL BE
THAT WE WILL BE HEARING THE
BILLS AND FILE ORDER WITH
COMMAND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PRESENTING LAST IF A MEMBER IS
NOT PRESENT WHEN THEIR BILLS TO
BE TAKEN UP THE OVERSIGHT AT
THE END OF THE HEARING THEY
WILL GO BACK TO THE END SO
STAFF OF YOUR LISTENING. FOR
YOUR- FOR YOUR MEMBERS PLEASE
STAY ON TOP OF THIS BECAUSE WE
ARE MOVING TODAY- IN ORDER TO
MOVE THROUGH OUR AGENDA TODAY
EFFICIENTLY WE WILL AIM TO
SPEND NO MORE THAN TWENTY
MINUTES ON EACH BILL. WE WILL
HEAR UP TO TEN MINUTES OF PHONE
TESTIMONY ON EACH BILL. IF YOU
ARE AN AND UNABLE TO GET
THROUGH ON THE PHONE. PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY THROUGH THE PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THIS
WILL BECOME PART OF THE
OFFICIAL RECORD OF THE BILL.
BEFORE WE BEGIN OUR AGENDA I
HAVE A STATEMENT TO READ
REGARDING OUR PROCESS TODAY
WHICH YOU KNOW WAS ALTERED. WE
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE ARE ALSO
REQUIREMENT MASKEY WORN AND
PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TESTIFYING. IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE AMASSED WE WILL
PROVIDE ONE FOR YOU. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL YOU MAY APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. WHEN WE INVITE
COMMENT FROM PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM. WE WILL ALSO BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR
TESTIMONY. THE CALL IN NUMBER
FOR THIS HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN ALSO FIND
THIS NUMBER ON THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR SCREEN. AND I
WOULD ASK THAT THE MODERATOR-
AS YOU CLICK THROUGH. THE
DIFFERENT COLORS OF SOMEONE
DOES NOT COME ON. DO NOT. DO
NOT DO NOT WE'RE NOT GONNA WAIT
TWO MINUTES FOR PEOPLE TO GET
IT TOGETHER- FOR THOSE WHO ARE
LISTENING TODAY. BE READY TO
SPEAK WHEN THE MODERATOR CALLS
UPON YOU. THEY WILL BASICALLY
TYPICALLY SAY THE LOWER YOUR
LINE IS OPEN AND THAT IS YOUR
CUE TO SPEAK. BUT IF SOMEONE
DOES NOT START SPEAKING
MODERATOR PLEASE MOVE ON. SO WE
CAN BE EFFICIENT TODAY. YEAH IF
YOU ARE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN
TO DO SO AS THE OFF AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR PRESENTATION. SO ISABELLE
YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON THE
OTHER PRESENTS THAT'S WHEN YOU
CALL AND YOU WILL BE IN THE
QUEUE. PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE WHEN YOU CALL
AND THIS AND THIS INCLUDES A
MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMARTPHONE'S. M. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE OFFICE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE TWO
ZERO EIGHT SEVEN. WE'RE ALSO
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. FINALLY I WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS THE DISRUPTIONS- TO
OUR HEARING PROCESS THE
ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO
COMMITTEE AND FOR PROCEEDINGS
AND THE LAST. YOUR CONDUCT THAT
CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS
OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING IS
PROHIBITED AND WILL BE
ADDRESSED. SUCH CONTACT MAY
INCLUDE REMOVING A MASK AND
REFUSING TO PULL PUT IT BACK ON.
TALKING ARE MAKING LOUD NOISES
FROM THE AUDIENCE UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE
LANGUAGE. SPEAKING LONGER THAN
THE TIME ALLOTTED. EXTENDED
DISCUSSION OF MATTERS NOT
RELATED TO THE SUBJECT OF THE
HEARING OR BILL. AND OTHER
DESTRUCTIVE ACTS TO ADDRESS ANY
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT I WILL TAKE
THE FOLLOWING STEPS. IF AN
INDIVIDUAL'S STRAPS ARE HEARING
PROCESS I WILL DIRECT THEM TO
STOP AND WARNED THEM THAT THE
CONTINUED DISRUPTIONS MAY
RESULT IN REMOVAL FROM THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. I WILL ALSO
DOCUMENT ON THE RECORD THE
INDIVIDUAL INVOLVED AND THE
NATURE OF THIS DISRUPTIVE
CONDUCT. I'M A TEMPORARILY
RECESSED THE HEARING AS WELL.
IF THE CONDUCT IS NOT STOP BY I
WILL REQUEST YOU SYSTEMS OF THE
SERGEANTS AND SERGEANTS AND
ESCORTING THAT INDIVIDUAL FROM
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COOPERATION TODAY
WE'RE GOING TO START
MOMENTARILY AND AGAIN IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN. IF YOU'RE A WITNESS
YOU ARE GIVEN TEN TO MINUTES
WITNESSES SAID TWO MINUTES EACH
YEAH BUT IF YOU'RE A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC I JUST GIVING A
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO A
BILL- JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY. ANY OTHER FURTHER
CONVERSATION WILL BE CUT OFF
AND ENCOURAGE THE MONITOR THE A
MODERATOR TO CUT OFF ANYONE WHO
CONTINUES ON BEYOND- THEIR-
THEIR SUPPORTER OPPOSITION OF
THE BILL. IN A VERY RAPID
MANNER SO EVERYBODY FROM THE
PUBLIC GETS A CHANCE THAT
DESIRES TO HAVE EMPLOYED IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON OUR PROCESS THAT
WE DO THIS SO THAT OTHERS CAN
HAVE A CHANCE TO HAVE THEIR
OPINION HER TO. WITH THAT LET'S
GO TO OUR FIRST AUTHOR WHO'S
WAITING OUT THERE EAGERLY THAT
IS- MISTER FRAZIER. AND WHO IS
FILE ITEM. NUMBER THREE AB NINE
SIX SEVEN I WANT TO WELCOME
BACK BECAUSE I DIDN'T SEE HER
WHEN I WALKED IN JHANSI. OUR
COMMITTEE SECRETARY AS HERE
WELCOME BACK. WE'RE GLAD YOU'RE
HERE- WILL DIFFERENT ISN'T IT-
AND WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO- MR FRAZIER- THE ORDER- OKAY
SO WE ARE ON- FILE ITEM NUMBER.
THREE EIGHTY NINE SIX SEVEN YOU
MAY PROCEED WHEN READY AGAIN
I'LL REITERATE THAT WHEN THIS
IS HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH-
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT WISH
TO CALL AN- HOUR OR HERE. YOU
JUST COME UP AND STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY MISTER FRAZIER
YOU MAY PROCEED ALREADY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR COLLEAGUES.
FIRST ACCEPTED MEMBERS FROM THE
COMEDIAN APPRECIATE
COOPERATION. EXTREME HOPE OF
YOUR CHIEF CONSULTANT ON THIS
BILL. AS YOU KNOW STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES HAVE BEEN
ESPECIALLY IMPACTED BY THE
COVERT NINETEEN. PANDEMIC AN
EXPECTED INFLUX OF DUE PROCESS
CASES RELATED TO THE COVERT
NINETEEN SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR
DISRUPTIONS. WILL OVERLOOK
OVERWHELM THE SYSTEM. CREATING
ADDITIONAL DELAYS TO SERVICES.
ALSO MORE NEGATIVE IT EDUCATE
SKEWS ME MORE EDUCATIONAL
IMPACTS AND PROVIDE LITTLE
RECORDS FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
OR THOSE FACING LANGUAGE
BARRIERS. AB NINE SIXTY SEVEN
WILL DELIVER HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS INVOLUNTARY DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PROCESSES WITH A
PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF
PREVENTING AND RESOLVING
DISPUTES IN AN EQUITABLE AND
COST EFFECTIVE MANNER. AB NINE
SIX SEVEN REQUIRES LEDS TO
CONFRONT INEQUITY BY CONDUCTING
OUTREACH TO FAMILIES WHO ARE
TYPICALLY LEFT OUT OF THE
PROCESS AND UNABLE TO ACCESS TO
DUE PROCESS RIGHTS. AB NINE SIX
SEVEN ALSO CREATES
ACCOUNTABILITY AND ENHANCES
FAMILY SUPPORT BY INCLUDING
CELLPHONES CDE AND FAMILY
EMPOWERMENT CENTERS THROUGHOUT
THE PROCESS. MORE THAN A
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS FROM ALL
SIDES OF THIS ISSUE HAVE COME
TOGETHER IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR RIVAL IN SUPPORT OF AB
NINE SIX SEVEN THIS
UNPRECEDENTED UNPRECEDENTED
COALITION OF STAKEHOLDERS AND
ARE AFFECT EFFORTS TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. I HAVE TO EXPERT
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
THE FIRST IS VERONICA COATS. ON
BEHALF OF THE SELF
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION AND
THEN KRISTEN POWERS ON BEHALF
OF THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
MISTER FRAZIER TO YOUR
WITNESSES. GOOD MORNING CAROL
JOHN COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
VERONICA AND I AM THE ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE PAYMENT
COUNTY SELBACH I AM TESTIFYING
ON BEHALF OF THE TOP
ADMINISTRATORS OF CALIFORNIA AS
A CO SPONSOR EIGHTY NINE SIX
SEVEN. I THOUGHT THIRTY MINUTES
LATER WE ARE OBLIGATED TO
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS WHO
RECEIVE SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES ARE GIVEN THAT IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THEIR
INDIVIDUALIZED EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. YOU TO THE COMING
NINETEEN PANDEMIC CALLED
WORKFORCE TO CLOSE THEIR
PHYSICAL SECURITY COMPLY WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS. CONTRA
MANTA INSTRUCTION IN THE LINE
OF MOST OF OUR STUDENTS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES IN MANY CASES I'M
NOT BEEN ABLE TO PROVIDE THE
REQUIRED SERVICE CENTRE
DISTANCE LEARNING DESPITE THE
INNOVATION AND CREATIVITY OF
EDUCATORS BUT THE BLOOD
INCREASE. BETWEEN BIRTH AND
FAMILY SCHOOL FIND SOMETHING TO
FIND WORK CURRENT FUNDING
CANNOT ADEQUATELY ADDRESS THAT
NEED. MORE STUDENTS GO BACK IN
PERSON LEARNING WE WANT TO BE A
PART OF THE SOLUTION TO ENSURE
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES GET
THE SERVICES THEY NEED WE WANT
TO UPLIFT PROACTIVE MEASURES
WHICH PRESERVATION CHEN AND
PROMOTE EQUITABLE SOLUTION WELL
NOT INFRINGING ON THE ABILITY
FOR FAMILY TO PROCEED TO THE
CATHEDRAL RIGHT AND SAFEGUARDS.
AB NINE SIX SEVEN PROVIDE
PROVIDES AN INCENTIVE TO USE
ALTERNATIVE DISPUTE RESOLUTION
TO QUICKLY PROVIDE SERVICES TO
ALL EIGHTY NINE SIX SEVEN ALSO
PRIORITIZE THE MARGINALIZED
UNDERSERVED AND UNDER REPORT
THE ONLY TRUE TYPICALLY HAVEN'T
BEEN ABLE TO EFFECTIVELY
NAVIGATE THE PROPERTIES RELATED
TO THEIR PROCEDURAL SAFEGUARDS.
THE BILL WOULD BE WHAT THE CROP
CALIFORNIA BEEN DOING FOR YEARS
WORKING WITH FAMILIES TO ENSURE
THEIR RIGHT TO REALIZE
ADDRESSING THE IMPACT IT DIDN'T
WELLNESS AND LEARNING SHOULD BE
THOUGHTFULLY DONE THROUGH AN
EMPATHETIC ONE WITH AN
INCENTIVE TO PRESERVE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN FAMILIES
AND ALII. WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA HAD MORE TIMES THE
NATIONAL RATE SPECIAL EDUCATION
LEGAL FILINGS WHICH ARE COSTLY
IN DOLLARS AND EVEN MORE SO THE
TAX IN THE RELATIONSHIP THE
BILL AND GROUNDBREAKING AT THAT
INSPIRES US TO RETHINK THAT
SYSTEM OUR INTENT IS THAT THE
MAXIMUM AND OF DOLLARS GO TO
SERVICE THREE. AND LAST TO
ADDRESS THE CALL. AFTER THEM.
50% OF CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE
HAVE LEARNING DISABILITIES ARE
LESS LIKELY TO ACCESS QUALITY
SPECIAL EDUCATION DUE TO THEIR
INSTABILITY. ASSEMBLY STATED
THE GOAL OF EIGHTY NINE SIX
SEVEN IT TO PROVIDE RESOURCES
TO CALL TO OFFICIALLY AND
EFFECTIVELY ENGAGE WITH
FAMILIES. TO RESOLVE DEFEAT
BEATING THE AVAILABILITY OF
EDUCATION A THREE COURSE ISN'T
SERVICES FOR STUDENTS WITH
SPECIAL NEEDS. I CAN'T HAVE YOU
ALTHOUGH IN MARCH TWENTY TWENTY
THE WORLDWIDE CODE NINETEEN
CANNOT EXPORT CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOL TO MAKE AN ABRUPT AN
UNPRECEDENTED SHIFT TO VIRTUAL
THIS CONCERNING. STUDENTS
FAMILIES AND TEACHERS WENT FROM
DALY PERSONAL CONTACT THE
IMPERSONAL SCREEN IN THE SAME
CLASSROOM. THE CHALLENGES OF
THE PANDEMIC HAVE WIDENED THE
EDUCATIONAL GAP BETWEEN THE
MOST VULNERABLE STUDENTS.
PARTICULARLY THOSE WITH SPECIAL
EDUCATION NEEDS. IN THE
PANDEMIC. IS LIMITED TO EIGHT
SERVICES AND REESE SUCH. BY
OCCUPATION PHYSICAL THERAPY.
SPEECH AND LANGUAGE THERAPY ONE
TO ONE BEHAVIOURAL AS AN
ESPECIALLY THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
INSTRUCTION MOST STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ACCESS THEIR EDUCATION. MANY
SERVICES ACTIVITIES CRITICAL
FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENTS ARE DIFFICULT IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE TO DELIVER ON
MINE. FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF OUR
CLIENTS WITH AUTISM HAS BEEN
TOTALLY UNABLE TO ACCESS THE
ONLINE EDUCATION FOR THE PAST
YEAR. WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF
HIS ONE TO ONE AIDE WHICH IS
REQUIRED BY HIS INDIVIDUALIZED
EDUCATION PROGRAM. ANOTHER
CLIENT LOOKS TERRIBLE PAUL
BECAUSE BEEN UNABLE TO MAKE
GAMES WITH HER WALKING AND HAND
WRITING SKILLS. WITHOUT ACCESS
TO HER IN PERSON OCCUPATIONAL
AND PHYSICAL THERAPY.
ADJOURNMENTS ASSOCIATION PLAY
DEFICITS HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY ISOLATED AND
ANXIOUS ABOUT IN PERSON PEER
INTERACTION. AT SCHOOLS REOPEN
WE ANTICIPATE A FLOOD OF
REQUEST FOR ASSESSMENT OF
TWELVE FIFTY THREE FAMILIES IN
COLD EVER SERVICE OF THE
RESOURCES THAT WERE REQUIRED BY
THE CHILD'S I EP. BUT WE'RE NOT
DELIVER TO THE CHILD FOR THE
PAST YEAR. THIS SURGE THREATENS
TO OVERWHELM FAMILIES AND
SCHOOLS FURTHER DELAYING ACCESS
TO CRITICAL SERVICES AND
RESOURCES PER STUDENT. WE'RE
PLEASED THAT THE FORTY SEVEN
MEMBER FRAZIER THAT BIRTH EIGHT
FAMILIES AND SCHOOLS AND
ACHIEVING RESOLUTION THE SPEED
ACCESS THE EP SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS FOR STUDENTS. AS
DISTRICT MOVE FROM DIFFERENT
FINING TO IN PERSON
INSTRUCTION. IT'S A SMALL BUT
VERY CRITICAL FAMILY SUMMARIZE
CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL NEEDS. WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU. ARE THERE-
WE'RE GOING TO OPPOSITION
WITNESSES RECORD YEAH ARE THERE
ARE THERE ANY IS IN A- ASCENA
MUST HERE. NOW- WHY DON'T WE GO
TO THE- THE COMMITTEE BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE SENA
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE DO
WE HAVE A MOTION. IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED. ARBEN MOVED
AND SECONDED SO NOW WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION A MAXIMUM OF TEN
MINUTES. THANK YOU FOR IN
SUPPORT OF OPPOSITION MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL
GO ONLINE OF FIFTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE FACT THAT
IT'S GREAT DIRECT DONATE
POINTING. WHAT PART ANTI BY
COLD NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR AGAIN WHEN YOU INPUT.
PLEASE GO THEM UP WE IN SOME
GETS ON THE WE NEED TO DO IS
THERE. THEIR THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION I'M AN AUNT AND THE
POSITION. ON THE BILL ONLY THAT
WE DON'T THIS IS NOT A TIME FOR
FURTHER TESTIMONY IS JUST
WHETHER OR NOT YOU OPPOSE OR
SUPPORT THE BILL WITH YOUR
NAME. AFFILIATION IF YOU'RE
WITH A GROUP EVEN IF YOU'RE-
NOT. THAT IT'S NOT ANYTHING
THAT'S BUT IF YOU'RE A CITIZEN
THAT MATTERS TO JUST SAY THAT.
YOU'RE CONCERNED CITIZENS
THAT'S OKAY AND STATE YOUR
POSITION. THANK YOU OF A LINE
OF EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GEN RING I'M WE ARE DAVIS
REPRESENTING RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE FULLY
SUPPORT THE BEST THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AN EXTRA LINE OF
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS INTERNET
PELLETIER AND THE CHAIR OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION AND CO
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL AND WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OCTOBER LINE OF
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ELIZABETH INGLE CAN AND I NEED
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT TENANT FOR
YELLOW COUNTY REPRESENTING A
SIX DISTRICTS AND THE YELLOW
COUNTY FELL BUT IN FULL SUPPORT
OF NINE SIXTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
NEXT ON THE LINE OVER NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING DANIELLE WHITE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LINE CHILD FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF SIXTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING ALEX
KEPPLER REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NEXT WITH A LINE OF AND
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS ASSEMBLY KARACHI
WITH THE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK AND MEXICO LINE OF
SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SAMANTHA TRAN
WHICH OVER NOW IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITH A LINE OF
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE WILL MOVE ON TO LINE AT
NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS AMBER
GALLAGHER REPRESENTING SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY SOUTH IN FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ANNEX OF THE
LINE- FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU WHY NOT FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MICHELLE UNDERWOOD ON BEHALF OF
THE TORRANCE AND CLOVIS SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LINE EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GOOD MORNING ANDREA BALL
ON BEHALF OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
EDUCATION COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MY NINETY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MARTHA ALVAREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT INSTRUCT THE COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
MONICA HER TADO WITH THE SOLANO
COUNTY HELP THE COMMUNITY
ADVISOR COMMITTEE AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
EXTRA LINE OF TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS ADAM
STEIN FROM THE CINEMA COUNTY
CELLPHONE CINEMA COUNTY CHARTER
SILVA IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NEXT ON THE LINE OF ONE OH
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS STEVE WARD
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL FUNDING COALITION AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ON
THE LINE OF EIGHTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS KATIE BABCOCK WITH THE
NORTH REGION CELTA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINE SIX SEVEN.
THANK YOU. NEXT TO A LINE OF
ONE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING ELIZABETH ASK
ABOUT WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL BUSINESS
OFFICIALS OF TRANSPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU X. ARE GONNA ONE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YOU LINE ITEM. ALRIGHT
MEXICO LINE OF ONE SEVENTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM NOT
SURE WHAT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION FOR.
THANK YOU EXURBAN LINE OF ONE
SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
DISABILITY SECRETARY ON BEHALF
OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
LINE OF FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NINE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I'M SORRY NINE
THIRTY IN THE COUNTY DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU AN EXTRA LINE OF ONE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY ONE
TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS MANDATORY AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
HUMBOLDT ON ART PUBLIC.
ACCORDING THIRTY TWO FOR THE
SECOND PART OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT- OPPOSITION AND
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED- THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR PASSION
COMPASSION FOR THE SPECIAL
NEEDS POPULATION CAN. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER ABOUT.
THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER EVEN
ALLOWED VOICE FOR THAT
COMMUNITY AS WELL SO THANK YOU
WITH THAT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS FOR
DONALD BY DONALD FIVE KILEY.
KILEY AYE BENNETT. BENNETT I
VALLEY. LEE LEE I MCCARTY.
QUICK SILVA QUICKSILVER I THANK
THUS FIVE ALSO IT IS A MISTER
FRAZIER THANK YOU THE GOVERNOR
THANK YOU- LET US PROCEED FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOR AB FIVE TWENTY
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR. AND THIS
IS BY MISTER GIBSON. YOU MAY
PERCEIVE ALREADY. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL OF FIVE TWENTY
WHICH- WOOD ECSTATIC THE
CALIFORNIA DIVERSIFYING THE
TEACHER WORKFORCE GRANT PROGRAM.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO SUPPORT
LOCAL PROGRAMS AIMED TO BUILT
TO BUILDING A MORE DIVERSE
TEACHER WORKFORCE THAT'S MORE
REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TODAY MEN OF COLOR PRISON
REPRESENTS LESS THAN 10% OF
CALIFORNIANS TEACHING WORKFORCE.
OF THAT 10% BLACK AND LATINO
MEN MAKES UP JUST 122% OF THE
WORKFORCE. STUDENTS OF COLOR
MAKES UP ABOUT 75% OF
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENT
POPULATIONS. THESE ARE STARK
DIFFERENCES. THAT RESEARCH
IDENTIFY THE DEMOGRAPHIC
MISMATCH WHICH LOW ACHIEVEMENT
OF FROM STUDENTS OF COLOR
EDUCATIONAL RESEARCH HAVE FOUND
EVIDENCE THAT THIS DEMOGRAPHIC
MIX MAC CAN DRIVE INEQUALITY IN
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES. ARE STUDIES
FOUND BLACKS AND WHITES
CHILDREN ALIKE ARE SET TO
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER CHEEVER
HIGHER CHEAPER- WHEN ASSIGNED
TO TEACHING. OF THEIR OWN RACE.
BUT BECAUSE WHITE STUDENTS ARM
FAR MORE LIKELY TO HAVE THE
SAME RACE TEACHERS
DISPROPORTIONATE BENEFITS MANY
RESEARCHERS HAVE FOUND THAT
TEACHERS OF COLOR PRODUCE MORE
FAVORABLE ACADEMIC OUTCOMES IN
THE SHORT RUN FOR STUDENTS OF
COLOR IN TERMS OF STANDARDIZED
TEST SCORES ATTENDANCE COURSE
PERFORMANCE AND SUSPENSION IN
BI DISTRICT COPYRIGHT VICE
GOODNESS BECAUSE CURRENTLY
INVOLVED IN A PILOT PROGRAM TO
IMPROVE RETENTION RATES. OF
MALE TEACHERS OF COLOR WHO HAVE
SOME OF THE LOWER RETENTION
RATES THE GOAL WITH THIS BILL
IS TO PROVIDE MORE TOOLS FROM
THE STATE LEVEL TO BUILD AN
INNOVATIVE IDEAL ALIKE. IT'S
ABOUT STUDENTS WHEN STUDENTS
CAN IDENTIFY. THEIR TEACHER CAN
IDENTIFY WITH THEIR TEACHER AND
SEE THEM AS ROLE MODELS THERE
ARE USUALLY THERE ARE
ULTIMATELY MORE SUCCESSFUL IN
SCHOOL. THEY SHOWED GREAT
CONFIDENCE AND PROPEL THEM TO
PURSUE AND ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS
AND ASPIRATIONS. IT'S TRULY.
IT'S TRULY ABOUT THE STUDENTS
WE REGULARLY TALK ABOUT EQUITY.
BUT IT IS CRITICAL TO STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE NATIONAL BUREAU OF
RESEARCH OF ECONOMIC RESEARCH
REPORTS THAT A BLACK OF TEACHER
FOR ONE YEAR IN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL REYES WILL RAISE LONG%
TERM EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT FOR
BLACK MALE STUDENTS EXPRESSLY
BUT THOSE FROM LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS FOR THE MOST DIVERSE
A DISADVANTAGE- BLACK MALES THE
REPORT ESTIMATES THAT EXPOSED
TO A BLACK TEACHER IN
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL REDUCE- HIGH
SCHOOL DROP OUT RATE BY 39% AND
REYES. COLLEGE ONGOING
ASPIRATIONS AB FIVE TWENTY
WOULD PROVIDE SCHOOLS WITH
TOOLS TO HELP THEM BUILD A MORE
DIVERSE TEACH TEACHER
POPULATION AND TO RETAIN THOSE
WHO ARE HAPPY TO BE IN THIS
PROFESSION AND CONTINUE TO BE
ROLE MODELS FOR OUR STUDENTS AB
FIVE TWENTY. PUT EQUITY FRONT
AND CENTER AS A PRIORITY TO
IMPROVE STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
JOINING ME TO PROVIDE
SUPPORTING TESTIMONY IS OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE SUPERINTENDENT
PUBLIC INSTRUCTIONS TO TONY
THURMOND WHO SELL PRODUCE AND
WILL BE ABLE TO ANSWER ANY.
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS- HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AB FIVE
TWENTY. THANK YOU MR GIVES A
BEFORE WE GO TO SUPERINTENDENT
THURMAN I JUST WANNA CONFIRM
YOU DO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS I
DO ACCEPT THE MEMBERS I THINK
THE COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE
STAFF WORK WITH MY COMMITTEE-
MY TEAM IN ORDER TO MAKE THIS
BILL BETTER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. TO SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN.
THANK YOU EIGHT ZERO DONALD AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I
LIKE TO ALSO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GISON. OUT FOR HIS
AUTHORSHIP OF THIS BILL. IN
YOUR SHIP TONY THURMOND- STATE
SUPERINTENDENT ON BEHALF OF- AB
FIVE TWENTY. PLEASED TO SAY
THAT WE AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. OUR
SPONSOR A TO THIS BILL AND URGE
THE SUPPORT OF THE MEMBERS. OF
THIS COMMITTEE. YOU KNOW
THEY'RE GREAT TEACHERS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS THERE'S CERTAINLY
NO QUESTION OF THAT. BUT AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON POINTS
OUT IN HIS OPENING REMARKS-
DIVERSIFYING THE TEACHER
WORKFORCE PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS. FOR MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS. WHO EXPERIENCED THE
TREATMENT GAP YEAH AND- AND SO
IN THAT RESPECT WE'RE EXCITED
TO ASK YOUR SUPPORT. OF THIS
BILL. AS YOU'VE HEARD THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE A GRANT PROGRAM.
THAT WOULD EXPAND THE PROGRAMS
THAT DIVERSIFY THE TEACH WORK
FORCE WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
PROGRAMS LIKE MALE EDUCATORS.
OF COLOR PIPELINE PROGRAMS.
THESE PIPELINE PROGRAMS HAVE.
REALLY GROWN ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY INCLUDING- IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE PROGRAMS AT
CAL STATE NORTHRIDGE. WE HAVE A
PROGRAM TO CAL STATE
BAKERSFIELD- IN IN THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS DISTRICT ACCOUNT AND
UNIFIED AT BERKELEY UNIFIED- IN
MANY DISTRICTS- THE RESEARCH
HAS SHOWN. THAT DIVERSIFYING
THE TEACHER PIPELINE IN HAVING.
EDUCATORS OF COLOR- PROVIDES
BENEFITS TO STUDENTS OF COLOR
AND TO ALL STUDENTS OF FROM ALL
BACKGROUNDS. I'D LOVE TO CALL
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE RESEARCH.
OF DR TRAVIS BRISTOL- FROM THE
DIVERSITY CALIFORNIA BERKELEY-
I CANNOT BE HERE TODAY HAS BEEN
AN INCREDIBLE PARTNER FOR US IN
SHARING HIS RESEARCH ON HOW THE
BAIL. EDUCATOR PIPELINE
PROGRAMS CAN ADD TO THE MIX OF
GREAT RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE.
FOR CLOSING LEARNING GAPS FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND FOR. ALL
STUDENTS WE'VE HEARD. FROM OUR
PARTNERS AT THE C. ISSUE. HIS
MILITARY OF COLOR TYPE PRO. ARE
ABLE TO OFFER ADDITIONAL SO.
THAT WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE
WHETHER BE A RATHER PROGRAM OR
COACHING- FOR OTHER TYPES
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT. THAT
WILL ALLOW OUR- EDUCATOR TO
STAY IN THE WORKFORCE- RESEARCH
IS SHOWING THAT MANY EDUCATORS
EXPERIENCE ALL KINDS OF
CHALLENGES AND IT'S OFTEN
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO STAY IN
THE WORKFORCE. BUT IN
PARTICULAR- THAT MALE EDUCATORS
OF COLOR- SHOULD HAVE SHORTER
TIMES IN THE WORK FORCE BECAUSE
OF MANY EXPERIENCES LIKE MICRO
AGGRESSIONS AND LACK OF
SUPPORT. THAT THEY EXPERIENCED
SO FOR ALL THE BENEFITS THAT
WE'VE HEARD TODAY WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT THE
CREATION OF THIS GRANT PROGRAM
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES TO OUR
DISTRICT- TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO EXPAND STRENGTHEN.
EFFORTS TO DIVERSIFY THE
TEACHER WORKFORCE WITH THE
NIGHT AND AN EMPHASIS ON
SUPPORTING MALE EDUCATOR COLOR
PIPELINE PROGRAMS- WE KNOW THAT
NOW MORE THAN EVER THE CHEATING
GAP HAS BEEN EXACERBATED.
DURING THE PANDEMIC AND THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE GREAT
RESOURCES AS WE CAN A CONTINUE
TO ACCELERATE LEARNING NOW BUT
ALSO TO CONTINUE OUR EYE
TOWARDS THE FUTURE ON HELPING
TO CLOSE OPPORTUNITY GAPS AND
SUPPORT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
STUDENTS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB AT FIVE
TWENTY AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU.
ARE THANK YOU MR THURMAN. OF
NORTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT DO
WE HAVE ANY- THERE ARE NO.
OPPOSITION WITNESSES I BELIEVE.
A WILL GO TO THE- MEMBER TO
HAVE A MOTION. TO ME INSECT
MOVED IN SECONDED- AND
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS. I WANTED
TO CRONENBERG SILVA. THIS IS AN
EXCELLENT BILL OF LET YOU KNOW
I'VE BEEN IN EDUCATION FOR WELL
OVER THIRTY YEARS AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT FOR DECADES AND YET
PUTTING IN PLACE AN ACTUAL
PROGRAM THAT CAN REALLY- BE
FOCUSED ON THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT
WE NEED JUST LAST WEEK I WAS.
AT UC DAVIS AND FRESNO WHERE
THEY ARE WORKING ON PROGRAMS
TO- NOT ONLY EDUCATE BUT TO
RETAIN- DOCTORS AS WE KNOW WE
WANT THEM SERVING IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES SO THIS WOULD BE
SIMILAR- BUT IT'S VERY MUCH
NEEDED AND- I JUST COMMEND YOU
FOR BRING IT FORWARD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU- MISTER
BENNETT I APPRECIATE THE MISTER
GIBSON RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF TEACHING AND THE
TEACHER AND THE EDUCATIONAL
QUESTION AND CERTAINLY
INCREASING THE DIVERSITY OF OUR
TEACHING WORKFORCE AND TRYING
TO GET REAL PROFESSIONAL-
EDUCATION IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN
UNLESS YOU HAVE- TEACHERS ARE
REALLY WELL TRAINED AND
APPROPRIATE TEACHERS FOR
COMMUNITY SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER COMMITTEE COMMENT. SEEN
A FURTHER COMMENT FROM THE
COMMITTEES MANY MEMBERS WE WILL
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FOR TEN
MINUTES. AGAIN IF YOU ARE ON
THE PHONE LINE. I'LL BE READY
TO GO WHEN YOU'RE QUEUED UP- IN
YOUR- NAME AFFILIATION IF
YOU'RE WITH A GROUP AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
PLEASE TO THE TO THE PHONES A
MODERATOR PLEASE. YOU IF YOU
AREN'T SUPPORTER OPPOSITION OF
AB FIVE TWENTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
KAREN MEMBERS ALEX GRAVES THE
ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES WHICH INCLUDES
FORTY THREE TOLD THEM PROGRAMS
OF EDUCATION- WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO- EXPAND
THE ALLOWABLE COLLABORATIONS
WITH- OUR UNIVERSITIES AS WELL
AS CSU WE WILL BE MOVING TO A
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
EXTRATO LINE OF ONE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HI MY
NAME IS RUTH GRAY I AM NOT
AFFILIATED WITH ANYBODY I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT IS THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
OPPORTUNITY COLOR PLEASE NEXT
CALLER. THANK YOU WE'LL GO TO
LINE OF ONE ELEVEN. YOUR LINE
SO I'VE BEEN. HI THIS DR CRAP
AND PROPOSED A PROFESSOR AT UC
BERKELEY FOLK REPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU DOCTOR THANK
YOU. MEXICO LINE OF ONE UP
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE ONE THREE SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR NEXT CALLER THE
NEXT BOOK BOOK YEP WE'LL GO TO
LINE. ONE THIRTY. ONE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI BRIAN
STAFF ON BEHALF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION AND FULL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NUMBER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU- THE AUTHOR MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
MEMBERS THIS RESPECT LAST BUT I
VOTE THIS ABOUT DIVERSIFYING
THE TEACHER WORKFORCE WE
BELIEVE WE'RE MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION- AND WE LOOK
FORWARD FOR AN AYE VOTE AND
RECOMMENDATION FROM THIS
COMMITTEE. MOVING FORWARD THANK
YOU. I THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON-
WE WILL CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL HI THE
DONALD HI KILEY. KILEY AYE
BENNETT. BENNETT I DALY PLEASE.
LEAI MCCARTY MCCARTY I QUICK
SILVA. QUICKSILVER I. THE BILL
HAS SIX VOTES IT IS OUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF ITS GIPSON
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO EIGHTY
EIGHT AB NINETY NINE A FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE. THIS IRWIN. GOOD
MORNING HAVE A ZERO DONALD AND
KATIE MEMBERS AND I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE STAFF FOR
THEIR ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AS POLICYMAKERS
WE CANNOT MANAGE WHAT WE CANNOT
MEASURE OUR CURRENT EDUCATIONAL
DATA SYSTEMS EXIST IN SILOS
THEY DON'T TALK TO EACH OTHER
THEY HAVE INCONSISTENT
DEFINITIONS THIS MEANS THAT
POLICY MAKERS AND RESEARCHERS
ARE UNABLE TO ANSWER BASIC
QUESTIONS ABOUT STUDENT
PROGRESS AND OUTCOMES SUCH AS-
AS HAVE RECENT REFORMS SUCH AS-
I'LL SEE IF I HAVE SUCCEEDED IN
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR
DISADVANTAGED GROUPS. AND WHAT
EQUITY GAPS EXIST THAT KEY
TRANSITION POINTS WITHIN THE
EDUCATIONAL PIPELINE FOR
STUDENTS OF COLOR AND THOSE
FROM DISADVANTAGED SOCIAL
ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS MY
PREVIOUS WORK ON REMEDIAL
EDUCATION AND THAT WAS SEVEN OH
FIVE TO- CHANGE OUTCOMES AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WAS BASED ON
EXACTLY THIS TYPE OF DATA DATA.
OUR CURRENT DATA INFRASTRUCTURE
IS MAINLY USED FOR COMPLIANCE
WITH STATE AND FEDERAL
REPORTING THIS BILL MARKS A
MEANINGFUL SHIFT IN HOW WE USE
THIS DATA IT WILL EMPOWER US
MAKE BETTER AND MORE IMPACTFUL
INVESTMENTS IN OUR FUTURE BASED
ON MORE COMPLETE EVIDENCE. AB
NINETY NINE WILL ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA CRADLE TO CAREER
DATA SYSTEM WHICH WILL SECURELY
CONNECT THE DATA THAT SCHOOLS
COLLEGES FINANCIAL AID
PROVIDERS AND EMPLOYEES ALREADY
COLLECTED NEIGHBORING
POLICYMAKERS AND THE PUBLIC. TO
HAVE A COMPLETE PICTURE OF A
STUDENT'S JOURNEY. OVER THE
LAST YEAR AND A HALF WEST THAT
HAS FACILITATED A ROBUST AND
CROSS CUTTING STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESS. RESULTING
IN A MEANINGFUL BLUEPRINT OF
HOW TO CONNECT OUR MAYES OF
EXISTING SYSTEMS INTO ONE
COHESIVE SYSTEM. AB NINETY NINE
ENSURES THAT THIS SYSTEM WILL
BE DESIGNED WITH PRIVACY. AND
SECURITY OF THE STATE AS THE
TOP PRIORITY AND PROVIDES THE
LEGISLATURE WITH A VALUABLE
OPPORTUNITY. TO DIG INTO POLICY
DECISIONS THAT AFFECT SO MANY
STAKEHOLDERS. I WANT TO THANK
THE FACILITATORS OF THE WORKING
GROUP ONE OF WHOM IS HERE TO
TESTIFY ABOUT THE PLANNING
PROCESS. AS PART OF THE WEST
AND SEX A POST SECONDARY
PATHWAYS AND CAREER MOBILITY
TEAM CATHY BOOTH. AND ALSO
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY IS
SOO JIN JESS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA COMPETES AN
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS BEEN
DEEPLY ENGAGED ON THIS ISSUE
WITH A FOCUS ON HELPING. TO
MEET WORKFORCE AND EQUITY GOALS.
THANK THANK YOU MISTER INTO
YOUR FIRST WITNESS. ON THE
PHONE. AT THE CAPITOL FROM WEST
THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE PLANNING
PROCESS BOB WHAT WE STARTED OUT
WE WERE ASKED TO ADDRESS
SEVERAL DIFFERENT TOPICS HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT PRIVACY WOULD BE
KEPT- PRIVATE HOW WE WOULD PUT
TOGETHER INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
DID NOT REQUIRE NEW INVESTMENTS
RATHER LEVERAGE THINGS THAT
ALREADY EXISTED HOW TO MOVE
BEYOND EDUCATION DATA TO A
COULD WORK FORCE OF HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES INFORMATION. I
WOULD MAKE SURE THAT THE DATA
THAT WAS THERE WOULD HELP
ADDRESS EQUITY GAPS AND HOW WE
CAN ADVANCE POLICY RESEARCH
OVER THE LAST SIXTEEN MONTHS
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE
HELPED DESIGN SYSTEM INCLUDING
BOTH PEOPLE FROM THE VARIOUS
STATE AGENCIES HAVE BOTH THE
AUDIENCES AND ALMOST ALL THE
DECISIONS THAT WERE.
RECOMMENDED ARE UNANIMOUS. THE
DIDN'T APPOINTMENT SEVERAL COME.
ONE IS THAT IT WILL KICKED THE
HIGH. IN TO CREATE ANALYTIC
DATA FACT THAT THE PUBLIC CAN
ACCESS THE DASHBOARD A QUERY
BUILDER AND REQUEST PROCESS.
THEY WILL ALSO BE TOLD THAT ARE
SPECIFICALLY FOR FAMILIES AND
EDUCATORS INCLUDING THE ABILITY
TO FIND OUT MORE ABOUT.
POSSIBLE COLLEGES AND CAREERS
FIGURE OUT IF YOU'RE TAKING THE
RIGHT COURSES IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO BE ELIGIBLE TO GO TO UC
OR CSU. AND MAKING IT EASIER TO
APPLY FOR BOTH COLLEGE AND
FINANCIAL AID AND THAT'S BY
SCALING EXISTING STATE PROGRAM
CALL CALIFORNIA COLLEGES DOT
EDU. IT ALSO WOULD REVAMPING
EXISTING. ELECTRONIC
TRANSCRIPTS PROGRAM CALLED THE
TRANSCRIPT CALIFORNIA. TO MAKE
IT POSSIBLE TO SHARE
INFORMATION LIKE BADGES FOR
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION AS
WELL AS FIFTEEN TO CHECK THEIR
ELIGIBILITY FOR SOCIAL
SERVICES. FINALLY THE SYSTEM
WILL INCLUDE COMMUNITY OUTREACH
TO ENSURE THAT MANY DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS KNOW ABOUT THE
INCIDENT AND CAN'T EFFECTIVELY
USE AT. LEAST SOME OF THE
THINGS SEPARATE BUT THEY'RE
ACTUALLY INTERRELATED THERE ARE
WAYS THAT THE TOOLS TO HELP
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WILL
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF DATA.
THAT ARE HELD BY THE STATE
AGENCIES THAT'LL MAKE THE
ANALYTICAL RESEARCH MARCH
SECOND. THE PANDEMIC IS MADE
CLEAR THAT IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE THE DATA SYSTEM.
ON IT IS GROUNDED IN EFFECTIVE
PRACTICES THE GENERAL EXPLAIN
MORE ABOUT WHY IT'S GOING TO BE
SEVEN USEFUL. BUT THIS IS A
HIGHLY INCLUSIVE SYSTEM IT WILL
BE ONE OF THE MOST INCLUSIVE
FOR PUBLIC PERSPECTIVES IN THE
GOVERNANCE PROCESS. HAS ALREADY
BEEN- BY THE APPROVED. BY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OF I
BELIEVE IN ALL. WITNESSES
SEEING OFFICES WHEN THIS WILL
BRING BACK TO THE- THERE'S ONE
MORE SPEAKER OTHERS OF HAVE
YOUR RIGHT I APOLOGIZE TO OTHER
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. HI GOOD
MORNING CARADON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HAVING ME AND DR STUDENT
JAZZ EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA COMPETE. WHERE
POLICY RESEARCH AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION FOCUSED ON THE
INTERSECTION OF HIGHER
EDUCATION EQUITY IN THE
ECONOMY. I'M HERE TO WIN
SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL NINETY
NINE INTRODUCED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN WITH A
FABLESS THE LONG OVERDUE CREDIT
A CREATE A SYSTEM. CALIFORNIA
IS JUST ONE OF TWO STATES
WITHOUT SUCH A SYSTEM WHICH
MEANS CALIFORNIA'S LEADERS LACK
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
FASTER STUDENTS WORKERS AND THE
ECONOMY. CURRENTLY OUR STATE
VARIOUS DATASETS WORKING
PILOTS. K. TWELVE SEPARATE FROM
HIGHER EDUCATION SEPARATE FROM
WORKFORCE AND TELEVISED.
HOWEVER THE CHALLENGE OF
CALIFORNIANS SPACE ARE NOT
VALID FROM EACH OTHER NOT ONLY
ARE THESE CHALLENGES CONNECTED
BUT THEY ALSO COMPOUND EACH
OTHER. CALIFORNIANS WERE
UNDERSERVED IN K. TWELVE WILL
BENEFIT FAIRS AND ACCESSING
COLLEGE AND THE WILL BE WORSE
OFF AND FINDING A GOOD JOB. THE
INDIVIDUAL SUFFERED AFTER THE
STATE AS A WHOLE. WE SUPPORT AB
NINETY NINE BECAUSE IT WAS A
LITTLE BY THE RECOMMENDATIONS
OF THE CRADLE TO CAREER WORK
GROUP. WHICH ENGAGE ALONG
PARTICIPATORY PROCESS AND
DEVELOPINGITS PLAN. MAKING THE
ALREADY EXISTING DATASETS.
ALLOWED TO MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO HAVE OPEN OPEN ACCESS
TO USER FRIENDLY DASHBOARD. AND
ALLOWS FOR TEACHERS COUNSELORS
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
THE THREAT OF OPERATIONAL TOOLS
THAT SUPPORT THINGS LIKE
COLLEGE AND CAREER PLANNING.
LIST ALL THE POTENTIAL BECAUSE
THE LACK OF COMPREHENSIVE
LONGITUDINAL DATA PREVENT
POLICYMAKERS FROM PINPOINTING
WHERE CALIFORNIANS FATHER THE
CRUX OF THE EDUCATION TO
EMPLOYMENT PIPELINE. HOW THAT
VARIES BY RACE GENDER REGION IN
INCOME WHY IT HAPPENED AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WHAT WE CAN DO
ABOUT IT. LEADERSHIP IS THE
BEDROCK OF ALL SUBSTANTIVE
EVIDENCE BASED CHANGE FOR
POLICY MAKERS THE PUBLIC AND
STUDENTS. IT IS LONG OVERDUE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION TO THIS
CRITICAL. ISSUE AND I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. GREAT
THANK YOU. I KNOW KNOW I'VE
THEY'RE NOT. WITNESSES WITH
THAT WILL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. I COMMENTS RENDON
THE CAN MEMBERS- MISTER. I JUST
QUIT COM I WANT TO THANK YOU
FRIENDLY IN THE BILL THIS IS
ONE OF MANY AREAS WERE
CALIFORNIA HAS LAGGED BEHIND-
VIRTUALLY EVERY OTHER STATE IN
THE COUNTRY WHEN IT COMES TO
EDUCATION AS YOU WITNESS THAT
IT'S REALLY SOMETHING THAT'S
LONG OVERDUE. THANK YOU HAVE A
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISS CLARK
SILVA. YEAH CAN YOU JUST
EXPLAIN. WHAT THIS WOULD LOOK
LIKE- WHETHER IT'S PARENT
TEACHER. OR EVEN
ADMINISTRATION. YEAH I KNOW YOU
SAID A- COMPUTER DATA SYSTEM
DASHBOARD BUT- WOULD IT BE.
INDIVIDUALIZED FOR EACH STUDENT
AND FROM SAY KINDERGARTEN TO.
COLLEGE THEIR DATA IS BEING-
ACCRUED INTO A SYSTEM SO THAT.
THROUGHOUT THEIR EDUCATION
YEARS THINKING GO ON AND-
OTHERS CAN. I MEAN. RELATED TO
PRIVACY. JUST KIND OF HOW IT
IS. WITH THIS LOOK YOU KNOW I
MEAN I HAVE- ONE OF THE-
SPEAKERS ANSWER THAT QUESTION
NOT. BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
WORKING AS A COMMITTEE ON WHAT
THE MOST. APPROPRIATE WAY. TO
IMPLEMENT THIS IT AND IT IS.
VERY MUCH. CONCERNED WITH- BUT
DE IDENTIFIED INFORMATION. AND
SO. DO WE HAVE ONE OF THE
SPEAKERS THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THAT SPECIFICALLY ABOUT.
WHETHER INDIVIDUALS CAN. HOW
THEY WOULD BE TRACKING THEIR
PROGRESS. ACTUALLY THIS IS
KATHY WITH FROM SAID SO FOR THE
TOOL BUT THE DASH. WHERE THEY
POLICYMAKERS GO ON TO
UNDERSTAND DIFFERENTIAL
OUTCOMES AFTER THAT PANDEMIC HE
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO SEE AN
INDIVIDUAL INFORMATION YOU'D
ONLY BE ABLE TO SEE GROUPS OF
STUDENTS. BUT IF YOU'RE IN ONE
OF THE TOOLS LIKE LET'S SAY YOU
ARE A COUNSELOR AT A HIGH
SCHOOL AND YOU'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT A STUDENT HAS
TAKEN THE RIGHT COURSES THAT
THEY CAN APPLY. TO THE CSU OF
THEIR CHOICE THEY WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO INDIVIDUAL LEVEL DATA
JUST FOR THAT STUDENTS WHICH
SAID LOOK AT ME THAT STUDENTS
TO SAY OH THIS IS A CLASSIC
NEED TO TAKE. IN ORDER TO BE
ABLE TO APPLY SO THERE'S A LOT
OF VERY CAREFUL SAFEGUARDS THE
ONLY BE APPROPRIATE PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING AT INDIVIDUAL LEVEL
DATA. AND ONLY IN THE CONTEXT
OF COUNSELING. OKAY AND THIS
ONE FOLLOW UP SO THINGS THEIR
TEN SCORES. ON A- BIG AS- THAT
TYPE OF INFORMATION WOULD BE.
PUT IN THEIR THROUGHOUT THEIR
SCHOOLING IS. YEAH BUT IT BUT
IT WOULD BE AS NOTED THAT I'LL
GO AHEAD. YEAH SO FAR ON IT FOR
THE PUBLIC DATASETS THERE WILL
BE INFORMATION ABOUT BROAD
THINGS LIKE TEST SCORES HOWEVER
HE WOULD NEVER BE ABLE TO SEE
THAT FOR INDIVIDUAL STUDENTS-
THE TOOLS THAT ARE FOR COLLEGE
AND CAREER PLANNING DON'T I
BELIEVE INCLUDE TEST SCORES
THEY'RE MUCH MUCH MORE FOCUSED
ON MAKING SURE YOU'RE TAKING
THE RIGHT COURSES AND YOU'VE-
FINISHED EDITING THINGS LIKE
YOUR FINANCIAL AID APPLICATION.
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU SEE
YOU KNOW FOR THE CALMEST
BENNETT. JUST WANNA COMPLEMENT
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THIS IS
A WELL THOUGHT OUT TO
IMPROVEMENT IN THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM AFTER SPENDING A- NUMBER
OF YEARS AS A HIGH SCHOOL
COUNSELOR. THANK YOU. GREAT
THANK YOU. I'LL JUST SHARE MY
COMMENTS YOU KNOW MY OPINION
ABOUT THIS. ISSUE IF YOU'RE THE
MANY TIMES- MY CONCERN IS THAT.
THIS PROJECT IS A BUREAUCRAT'S
DREAM- IT'S GONNA TAKE TONS OF
MONEY AND I'M JUST NOT SURE.
HOW PRACTICAL THE FINAL PRODUCT
WILL BE BUT YOU RICHARD ME. MR
ON THE- WATCHING THIS CLOSELY.
AND THAT THIS IS GOING TO BE A
PRODUCT IS GOING TO BE USER
FRIENDLY- AND REALLY OUT. AT AT
THE SCHOOL SITE LEVEL. THAT THE
COUNCIL LEVEL THE TEACHER LEVEL
DEMONSTRATE OF LEVEL WHATEVER.
TO MOVE CALIFORNIA KIDS FORD
SO. I'M I'M TAKING YOUR WORD
FOR TODAY BUT I'M VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THIS JUST BEING
ONE OF THOSE. YOU KNOW I HEAR
VACUUM INSTEAD IS IT SOME KIND
OF MONEY RIGHT NOW. BECAUSE
WE'VE SEEN THAT IN THE STATE
THE PASTEXPERIENCE. THAT THAT
THAT WE SEEN ACROSS OUR STATE
ARE PASSAGE VERY SHOW THAT YOU
KNOW WE HAVEN'T ALWAYS BEEN
THAT GREAT AT DEVELOPING
TECHNOLOGY. I THINK WE ALL HAVE
TO AGREE THAT'S SOMEWHAT TRUE.
MAYBE NOT ALWAYS BUT SOMETIMES
AND I'M JUST WORRIED ABOUT THIS
PRODUCT. BECAUSE REMEMBER
THERE'S TEN THOUSAND SCHOOLS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT.
AND A LOT OF STUDENTS SIX POINT
TWO MILLION STUDENTS ISHE. AND
I'M JUST VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW THIS FINAL PRODUCT. WHAT IT
WILL ACTUALLY PRODUCE FOR US SO
YOU HEARD ME I WILL GO OFF ON
ANY FURTHER- BUT- WHAT WE NOW
GO. TO THE- THE PHONES- OVER
THE PHONE LINE FOR SOME. AND
ALL. TEN MINUTES THANK THANK
YOU OF YOUR IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE OF SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER WITH THE TALK
ABOUT A LEADERSHIP GROUP AND WE
ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
OVER LINE OF ONE FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
JEFF AMONG THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROGRAMS THE
STATION. AB NINE NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EXTRALITE A ONE SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M NOT OF
WHAT I HAVE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ESCALATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO A
LINE OF ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MANY
OF YOU HAVE A TRUST WEST IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE LINE OF FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
REFRIGERANT THING WITH THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN STRONG SUPPORTER
OF AB NINETY NINE. THANK YOU.
NEXT ON THE LINE OF EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS MICHELLE AND SALAS
CANOE FOR LYING TO PROTECT
CHILDREN. AND I AM IN
OPPOSITION AND I WOULD BIG FOR
THAT HERE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION. TO OUR NEXT CALL
THANK YOU NEXT TO THE LINE ON
ONE TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
ACOLYTE OF ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS PROPERTY
WHICH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS SHERI
LEWIS SIMILAR TO ANGELES I'M AN
ATTORNEY AND A FORMER COLLEGE
PROFESSOR I AM VERY OPPOSED TO
THE SALE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AMY
BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD
YEAH CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO MORE SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. GREAT
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE BILL MOTION IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED MOVED AND
SECONDED- THE OTHER MAKE
CLOTHES. YEAH BUT I APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS OF THE COMMITTEE
AND I APPRECIATE- THE CHAIR'S
COMMENTS TO SELL A COUPLE OF
THINGS THIS IS GOING TO BE AS
AS WE DISCUSS THIS IS GOING TO
BE IN THE BUDGET SO I THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT THERE
IS A BILL MOVING FORWARD SO
THAT WE CAN. MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE ABLE TO INTERACT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND- MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE PART OF THE-
PLANNING PROCESS OF AND I ALSO
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA ON
TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS. I CAN TELL
YOU OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
THEY HAVE- DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY HAS DONE A REALLY
GOOD JOB WITH AMY- AMY TONG
THERE- THEY HAVE GONE TO AGILE
PROGRAMMING WHICH MAKES IT MUCH
MORE LIKELY THAT A- SOFTWARE
PROJECT IS GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. AND AN ADDITIONAL
LAYER ON TOP OF THAT IS-
THEY'RE GONNA BE USING THE
TECHNOLOGY PROJECT APPROVAL
LIFECYCLE WHICH WILL ALSO MAKE
SURE THAT. WE ARE VERY CAREFUL
WITH THE PLANNING AND THE
FUNDING AND IT MAKES MUCH IT
MUCH MORE LIKELY THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS GOING TO BE A
SUCCESSFUL BUTTE WHERE THAT WE
ARE THE HOME OF SILICON VALLEY
AND WE HAVE TO GET THIS RIGHT
SO- I WILL BE FOLLOWING IT I
WILL GIVE YOU MY WORD ON THAT
AND- APPRECIATE. EVERYBODY'S
SUPPORT RIGHT HOPEFULLY THAT.
THANK YOU MR ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO HIGHER EDUCATION
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS THE PAST-
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION
O'DONNELL I DON'T KNOW I KILEY.
KILEY I'D BENNETT BENNETT I
DALY. LEE LEE I HAVE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I QUICK. SILVA HI RICK
SILVA I. THE BILL SIX BOTH IT
IS OUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WORK NEXT ITEM AGO DOES EIGHTY.
NINE NINE EIGHT FIVE NINE ITEM
NUMBER SO. MISTER JONES SOIL.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX MADE
RECEIVING READY. THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING IN A CHAIR IN
MEMBERS. ARE I WOULD LIKE TO
START OFF BY ACCEPTING TO
COMMITTEE COMMITMENT I THANK
THE CHAIR AND HIS STAFF. FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT THEY HAVE
DONE ON THIS BILL. WITH MY
OFFICE I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
FIVE NINE NINE WHICH ALIGNS THE
WAY SCHOOLS ARE. ARE IDENTIFIED
FOR INSPECTION BY COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION. WITH
THOSE IDENTIFIED UNDER CURRENT
L. C. FF. ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES AS WE START TO RETURN
TO IN PERSON LEARNING. ENSURING
OUR SCHOOLS ARE WELL EQUIPPED
WITH ADEQUATE FACILITIES
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS AND
MOST IMPORTANT. UP FULLY
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS NEED TO
BE ONE OF OUR HIGHEST
PRIORITIES. FURTHER WE CAN
SETTLEMENT THE CUT CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTITUTIONALLY OBLIGATED TO
ENSURE YOU THE RECEIVING THE
BASIC TOOLS. THEY NEED TO
RECEIVE A QUALITY EDUCATION.
THE WILLIAMS CASE CREATES AN
ANNUAL LIST OF POOR PERFORMING
SCHOOLS REQUIRES THAT COUNTY
OFFICES EVALUATE THEM FACILITY
ADEQUATELY. MISALIGNED
EDUCATORS AND QUALIFIED
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS.
OUTDATED. HAVE BEEN FROZEN IN
PLACE SINCE TWENTY THIRTEEN.
WHEN THE ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
INDEX WAS LAST PRODUCED THIS
HAS MISPLACED A FOCUS AND
RESOURCES ON TO SCHOOLS THAT
MAY HAVE VASTLY IMPROVED. THEIR
PERFORMANCE OVER THE LAST EIGHT
YEARS SIMILARLY SCHOOLS THAT
WOULD THAT WE OUGHT TO BE
EVALUATED MAY NOT BE. ON THE
OUTDATED LISTS AB FIVE NINE
NINE WILL USE EXISTING CSI AND
ATS I LESS COMPLY COMPILED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION. AS WELL AS SCHOOLS
WITH 50% OR MORE TEACHERS WHO
DO NOT HOLD A FULL CREDENTIALS.
TO IDENTIFY WHICH SCHOOLS NEED
TO BE REGULARLY INSPECTED AND
RECEIVED SUPPORT. BY SHIFTING
THESE MEASURES WE WILL BETTER
ENSURE CALIFORNIA FOR FILLED
THIS PROMISE TO ITS STUDENTS.
AND REDUCE THE GAPS IN ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE THAT HAVE BEEN
APPLE PIE DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. HIS
ERRANT ACTI ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
ADVOCATES. AND BE NOT WILSON ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OF EDUCATION. MODE
MEMBERS I. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THEY YOU MISTER
JOHNSON JONES T. OF IS ON THE
PHONE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ERIN APTIOM LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE WE ARE
PLEASED TO COSPONSOR EIGHTY
FIVE NINETY NINE ALONG WITH THE
VALUE THE FACT THAT NOT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. PUBLIC ADVOCATE FOR
THE STEEL YOU WERE LEAD COUNSEL
AND NOBODY IMPACTS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CLASS ACTION LAWSUIT
WHICH CLAIMED AT THE STATE AND
ITS EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES
TONIGHT OVER A MILLION
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN. THE
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO AN
EDUCATION BY FAILING TO GIVE
THEM BASIC EDUCATION ON THE
FACT THAT THE COMMISSION
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS. THAT
THE SAUDIS IN GOOD REPAIR AND
TEACHERS APPROPRIATELY
QUALIFIED AND ASSIGNED TO TEACH
THEIR SUBJECTS AND OUR
STUDENTS. THE TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR BILLION SETTLEMENT
LEGISLATION REQUIRES ALL
SCHOOLS TO MEET THE BASIC
STANDARDS. REQUIRES THE COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION TO CONDUCT
INSPECTIONS AND THE LOWEST
PERFORMING SCHOOLS AND SCHOOLS
LIKELY TO EXPERIENCE
EDUCATIONAL NECESSITY ISSUES IN
ORDER TO PREVENT THE ATTACK AND
CORRECT PROBLEMS. AT THE TIME
OF THE SETTLEMENT THE ACADEMIC
PERFORMANCE INDEX WAS USED AS A
PROXY FOR WHERE THESE ISSUES
ARE MOST LIKELY TO OCCUR. AND
IDENTIFIED SCHOOLS EVERY THREE
YEARS TO BE INSPECTED ANNUALLY.
AB FIVE NINETY NINE REPLACES
THE EIGHTY K. I. BASED METHOD
FOR SELECTING SCHOOLS TO BE
INSPECTED LET'S GO AHEAD AND
UPDATE FOR SUPPORT UNDER
FEDERAL LAW SPECIFICALLY CSI
SCHOOL. WHICH IDENTIFIED BASED
ON THE GRADUATION RATE AND
LOWEST PERFORMING 5% OF SCHOOLS
AND HSI'S WHICH IDENTIFIED
SCHOOLS WHERE STUDENT GROUPS
MEET ANY OF THE C. S. SECRETARY
AFTER LOWEST PERFORMING 5% OF
SCHOOLS. BASED ON BACHELOR
PERFORMANCE FOR THREE YEARS IN
A ROW IT WOULD ALSO ITS
CORPORATE 15% OR MORE TEACHER
TOLD US IN A FULL CREDENTIAL.
TEACHER PREPAREDNESS IS THE
SINGLE MOST IMPORTANT SCHOOL
INDICATOR OF STUDENT ACADEMIC
OUTCOMES. SCHOOLS WITH HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF UNDER
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS ARE ALSO
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE ISSUES WITH
THEIR FACILITIES OR
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS
EFFICIENCY AS FOR WORKING
CONDITIONS LEAD TO HIGHER RATES
OF TURNOVER. AND INABILITY TO
ATTRACT PREPARED AND
EXPERIENCED EDUCATORS. IN LIGHT
OF TEACHER EDUCATION AND
EDUCATIONAL CHALLENGES DURING
COLD IT IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER TO ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS. TO FULLY
CREDENTIALED IMPROPERLY THANK
TEACHERS. DEFICIENT SECTIONAL
MATERIALS AND FACILITIES GOOD
REPAIR. WE NOW HAVE BETTER DATA
AND MULTIPLE. TO WILLIAM CAN.
THAT WE SUMMARIZE. YES NEW. DID
QUITE A BIT INCREASE TRAIL
BETTER IN A WILLIAMS. WHETHER
STATE WITH THE OF SUPPORT TO
MORE TARGETED ARE. WE WERE ASK
FOR YOUR ON EIGHTY FIVE AND
THANK. TO OUR NEXT WITH. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
MIGHT IS DANA WILSON I'M THE TO
OF THE- OF THE TO AMONG. TO THE
AT THE TEN COUNTY OF THAT. AT
LATIMES NEARLY EIGHT YEARS
SUPPORTING SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
IMPLEMENTING BEST PRACTICES AND
ENSURING ADHERENCE TO STATE AND
LOCAL REGULATIONS. PRIOR TO MY
TENURE AT THE COUNTY OFFICE
I'VE SPENT OVER THIRTEEN YEARS
AT THE SITE AND DISTRICT
ADMINISTRATOR. WOULD DIRECTLY
BENEFIT FROM LIKE- SUPPORT.
FROM THE OFFICES OF EDUCATION
ARE UNIQUELY POSITIONED AS
LIAISONS BETWEEN LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES AND THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND BOARD OF
EDUCATION. AS A KEY PLAYER IN
THE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT WILL NOT
ONLY ENSURE THAT OUR DISTRICTS
AND SCHOOLS ARE AWARE OF THE
MANY CHANGES AND REQUIREMENTS
WITHIN THE LAW INCLUDING THE
WILLIAM SETTLEMENT LEGISLATION.
WE ALSO PROVIDE TRAINING
RESOURCES AND GUIDANCE TO
ENABLE OUR ELEAZAR TO MEET
THESE EXPECTATIONS. PACIFIC TO
WILLIAMS WE ARE COMMITTED TO
HELPING OUR SCHOOLS ENSURE THAT
ALL STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO THE
NECESSARY INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIALS. QUALIFIED TEACHER
AND SAFE LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS.
I WILLIAMS OVERSIGHT IS NOT
DESIGNED AS A GOTCHA FOR OUR
SCHOOLS WE UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES SCHOOL STATE. AND
SEE OURSELVES AS KEY IN
SUPPORTING TO HELP MEETING THE
NEEDS OF ALL STUDENTS. SHOULD
VISIT UNDERWRITTEN
INSUFFICIENCY WE WORK WITH THE
SCHOOL AND DISTRICT AND FINDING
RESOLUTION. REVISITING WHEN
ASKED AND WORKING WITH STAFF ON
CREDENTIALING NEEDS. OUR WORK
ALSO INCLUDES ENSURING THAT THE
PUBLIC. REPORTS ARE MADE. OKAY
BENEFIBER THE ACCOUNT SAYS FOR.
OR AT THE TARGETED GOING TO.
HAVE SHOWN THROUGH DASHBOARD
RESULTS THE NEEDS ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT AND MEETING THE STATE'S
PRIORITIES FOR ALL STUDENT
GROUPS. ALWAYS KEY IN PROVIDING
THIS ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO OUR
WILLIAM SETTLEMENT MONITORING
WE ARE ABLE TO ASSIST L. YANG
UNDERSTATE PARTY ONE MEETING
THE BASIC NEEDS. OF ALL
STUDENTS THAT THEY SERVE FOR
THESE REASONS I SUPPORT I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR AB FIVE NINETY
NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT TODAY
AND I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE THERE ARE
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WILL
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE AND
A COMMA SERENITY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SAYING NO COMMENTS
REALLY. COMMEND HIM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
BEEN MOVED AND BY MR- WILL- NO
NO QUESTIONS FOR THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL NOT OVER THE PHONE
LINES FOR TEN MAXIMUM OF TEN
MINUTES. FOR SUPPORT AND OR
OPPOSITION ONLY ONLY JUST TATE
YOUR NAME. AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY
PLEASE. TO THE- TO THE LINES
OUR MODERATOR PLEASE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE SIXTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO HAVE A
SUMMIT. PLEASE MOVE ON WITH A
LINE OF. ONE NINETY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THEY JUST DROP
THE LOCAL LINE OF TWO HUNDRED
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES LISTEN
SHALL INTEND FROM SANTA CLARA
SANTA CLARA CALIFORNIA I AM A
THE OWNER OF THE CALIFORNIANS
FOR EQUAL RIGHTS FOUNDATION AND
I STRONGLY AGAINST THAT AB ONE
A LOT. THANK THANK YOU OUR GOAL
TO LINE OF TWO OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DURING THE TRIAL
CHILDREN NOW WORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VOCAL LINE OF TWO OH
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MARTHA IS THERE ARE
BOTH THE DíAS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S TOGETHER AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND WE ARE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU WILL GO
LINE OF ONE EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS DEREK LEMON ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES ASSOCIATION A CO
SPONSOR THE MEASURE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LOCAL LINE
OF TWO OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY TWO OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AND WE WILL GO TO THE NEXT LINE
OF BUT TO TWELVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE TO TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. OKAY WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF ONE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY TWENTY
FOUR. BUT THE DEBRA JACKSON I'M
A CONCERNED PARENT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. THANK
YOU. ONE ONE SEVENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
LISA PAPUA FROM REAL IMPACT AND
WE OPPOSE AB ONE OH ONE. THANK
YOU THE NEXT FOOTBALL LINE UP
OF ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I IS BEING FLOWN FROM
SUNNYVALE- I'M NOT AFFILIATED
WITH ANY ORGANIZATION BUT I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE NO ONE.
THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE OF ONE
SIXTY TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
KNOW. HE AND I EIGHTY ONE AT
ONE. THANK YOU. THE NEXT DOUBLE
LINE OF ONE THIRTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS VERY
DEMAND FROM EL DORADO HILLS
CALIFORNIA ALLEGES SCHOOL
TEACHER AT TEMPLE ARE WE SHOWN
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE ZERO
ONE. THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE OF
TWO NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD MORNING ARIZONA ARE
ONLY HALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT OF AB
ONE OH ONE. THE PROPOSAL AND-
THANK YOU. WE ARE. NAZARIAN
MINDO REAR ON AB FIVE NINE NINE
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YOU
MAY GO OUT TO ALL THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. TWELVE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. EXTROVERT
ALIGNED ONE SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHAT OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
CHERYL KAPLAN OF THE HOME
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THOSE- EIGHTY ONE OH
ONE. THANK YOU MODERATE ABOUT
COULD JUST FOR CLARIFICATION IF
YOU'RE ON THE PHONE OUR LISTING
WE ARE ON AB FIVE NINE NINE WE
ARE NOT ON AB ONE OH ONE RIGHT
NOW. SO WE ARE TAKING SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION ONLY I'M AB FIVE
NINE NINE BY MR JONES SAWYER IT
IS NOT TIME TO HEAR ABOUT AB
ONE OH ONE YET. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ABOUT NEXT OF ONE ONE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIND ONE
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
THAT THAT WE ARE ON AB ONE OH
ONE NEVER MIND THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
ONE SIXTY THREE. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO LINE. TWO EIGHTEEN.
YOUR LINES OPEN. I WITH THE
WAITING TO CLOSE THAT ONE- ONE
POSSIBLY THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO THE LINE OF. BUT THE. ONE
EIGHTY FIVE. AND AS A REMINDER
WE ARE ON A. B. FIVE NINE NINE.
FOR OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
OR SUPPORT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU WE ARE
COMING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ON
AB FIVE NINE NINE WE'RE NOW IN
AB FIVE NINE NINE- THE AUTHOR
MAY CLOSE. REFER RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON H. B.
FIVE NINE NINE THE WILLIAMS ACT
AUTHORED BY JONES SAWYER. GREAT
THANK YOU THE MOTION IS TO
PASS. AS AMENDED YOU DO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS YES I DO YEAH DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS THE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB FIVE
NINETY NINE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL I.
DON'T HI KILEY KILEY I'D
BENNETT. BENNETT I DALY. LEE
HIGH FLEET I MCCARTY. MCCARTY
AYE CORK SILVA QUICK SILVA I.
THE BILL HAS EXPOSED IT IS OUT
MISTER JONES SAWYER. THEY WERE
NOW GOING TO PROCEED AB ONE OH
ONE AB ONE OH ONE WILL BE OUR
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT. FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT.
AB ONE OH ONE- AUTHORS MR
MEDINA WHO IS HERE AND- READY
2% MAY PROCEED WHEN READY MR
MEDINA. GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS. TODAY I
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL ONE OH
ONE. AB ONE OH ONE WILL REQUIRE
HIGH SCHOOLS TO PROVIDE ETHNIC
STUDIES STARTING IN THE
ACADEMIC YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY SIX. AND STUDENTS
TO TAKE AT LEAST ONE SEMESTER
OF AN EIGHT THROUGH G. APPROVED
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE TO
GRADUATE STARTING. IN. TWENTY
TWENTY NINE THIRTY. I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON
THIS BILL. I WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED IN THE
ANALYSIS. THAT WILL CLARIFY
THAT THIS AND THE OTHER
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS. APPLY
TO CHARTER SCHOOLS. CALIFORNIA
HAS ONE OF THE LARGEST AND MOST
DIVERSE STUDENT POPULATIONS IN
THE NATION. ETHNIC MINORITIES
ACCOUNT FOR OVER 71% OF THE
STUDENT POPULATION. WITH MORE
THAN NINETY LANGUAGES SPOKEN IN
DISTRICT SCHOOLS. IT HAS BEEN
MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS SINCE
ETHNIC STUDIES WAS ESTABLISHED
AS AN ACADEMIC DISCIPLINE. YET
DESPITE DECADES OF SCHOLARSHIP
AND ACTIVISM. ETHNIC STUDIES
HAS NOT BEEN UNIFORMLY
INTEGRATED INTO THE K. TWELVE
CLASSROOMS. THE ETHNIC STUDIES
AWAIT STATEWIDE ADOPTION DOZENS
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS INCLUDING
SOME OF THE STATE'S LARGEST
HAVE TAKEN IT UPON THEMSELVES
TO OFFER THESE IMPORTANT
CLASSES ON THEIR CAMPUSES.
STUDENTS TEACHERS AND PARENTS
HAVE COME TOGETHER TO SUPPORT
CATHOLIC STUDIES PROGRAMS AND
IT IS TIME THAT OUR STATE JOIN
THEM AS WELL. WE ARE HEADED IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION. THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION RECENTLY
APPROVING THE MODEL CURRICULA
FOR ETHNIC STUDIES ANOTHER TOOL
IN THE TOOLBOX FOR TEACHERS TO
USE. AS WE'VE SEEN CIVIL UNREST
AND RACIAL TENSION RISE ACROSS
THIS NATION CALIFORNIA HAS
PRIDED ITSELF AS BEING A
PROGRESSIVE BEACON WORKING TO
CHART A MORE EQUITABLE FUTURE.
IN ORDER TO BUILD RACIAL
JUSTICE IN THIS STATE AND
COUNTRY OUR STUDENTS NEED TO
LEARN A MORE INCLUSIVE HISTORY
OF THE UNITED STATES. AND THAT
HISTORY INCLUDES THE DIVERSE
EXPERIENCES AND PERSPECTIVES OF
PEOPLE OF COLOR. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. HERE
WITH ME TODAY ON BEHALF OF AB
ONE OR ONE. R. DR ALBERT
CARILLO. LEON'S LOS MEMORIAL
PROFESSOR AND PROFESSOR. AND
ALVIN LEE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
GENERATION UP- THANK YOU-
MISTER MEDINA TO THE WITNESSES
ON THE PHONE IN SUPPORT. YEAH
THIS IS A TOPIC COVERING
PROTESTS AMERICAN HISTORY AT
STANFORD UNIVERSITY. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRIEFLY
SHARE A FEW COMMENTS WITH YOU
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE ON ONE.
FIVE FOLLOW THE PATH OF THIS
PROPOSED LEGISLATION FOR MANY
YEARS AND MOST RECENTLY WAS
INVITED BY SUPERINTENDENT TONY%
THURMOND AND STAFF REVIEW PARTS
OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES MODEL
CURRICULUM RECENTLY ADOPTED BY
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
NOT FOR ME THERE ARE MANY
COMPELLING REASONS TO ENDORSE
AB ONE ON ONE I. MENTIONED
THREE HERE BRIEFLY. FOR THE
REASON CONDUCTED OVER THE PAST
DECADES ON THE EFFICACY OF WHAT
IS MORE BROADLY TERMED
CULTURALLY RELEVANT PEDAGOGY.
CONCLUDE THAT SUCH CURRICULUM
CONSISTENTLY HAVE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR
AND STUDENTS IN GENERAL. THE
MOST OF THIS RESEARCH IS
QUALITATIVE IN MEMPHIS MORE
RECENT QUANTITATIVE FINDINGS
BASED ON RESEARCH CONDUCTED IN
SAN FRANCISCO SCHOOLS THAT
PILOTED ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES
FONG SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN
DAILY ATTENDANCE GRADE POINT
AVERAGE AND COMPLETION OF
COURSE CREDITS. ESPECIALLY FOR
AT RISK STUDENTS ENROLLED THESE
PARTS. I CAN SUPPORT THESE
FINDINGS BASED ON MY PILOT
PROJECTS OVER THE PAST TEN
YEARS WORKING WITH HISTORY
TEACHERS. IT'S A TUNE UP
EXTENDS CURRICULUM IT TO
CHARTER HIGH SCHOOLS IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA HE'S
POBLACHTA ACADEMY I AND LUIS
VALDEZ LEADERSHIP ACADEMY IN
THE SAN JOSE. I CAN ATTEST THAT
STUDENTS WHO ENROLLED IN OUR
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM AT
BOTH SCHOOLS FOR MORE
INTELLECTUALLY ENGAGED MORE
MOTIVATED TO LEARN AND WHICH
WILL AND MUCH MORE COLLEGE
READY THAN THEIR PEERS WHO DID
NOT ENROLL IN THESE COURSES.
AND ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE
REQUIREMENTS IT'S NOT A SILVER
BULLET THIS THE FALL OF TENSE
RELATIONS IN CALIFORNIA. BUT IT
WILL BE AN IMPORTANT FOUNDATION
TO HELP BUILD THE CITIZENRY
THAT HAS GREATER KNOWLEDGE AND
MORE APPRECIATION FOR
ETHNICALLY. AND RACIALLY
DIVERSE SOCIETY. AND IT'S ONE
OF THE FOR IS OF AMERICAN
STUDIES A LOT BEING STUDIES. IT
GIVES ME GREAT PRIDE TO SEE THE
OUR STATE CAL. IS ON THE THREAT
OF. IN A THE CURRICULUM NOT
JUST FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR
BECAUSE THIS IS THE- IT IS FOR
ALL OF OUR STUDENTS THIS FOR
ALL OF OUR- FUTURE ADULT
CITIZENS. THANK YOU AGAIN
THOUGH TO THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY
COMMENTS WITH YOU THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU DOCTOR NOW TO ALVIN
LEE. HOW CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY PERFECT-
HI ALL MY NAME IS ULTIMATELY
THIS CALL NOW THAT I'M A
CURRENT SENIOR ATTENDING A
PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL IN THE BAY
AREA ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY
FIVE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR GENERAL.
AND THE THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ONE I THINK
STUDIES. CALIFORNIA HAD SIX
POINT THREE MILLION HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS WITH THEIR OWN
EXPERIENCES TO TELL THEIR OWN
STORIES TO SHARE. I LEARNED
FROM ELECTED IN WATERTOWN
HISTORY COULD BUT WAS VERY
CENTER CONTENT MANY. HERE HEY
DIDN'T LEARN ABOUT MANY ASIAN
LIVE MEETING. BLACK LEADERS
THAT HELPED SHAPE. WHAT WHAT.
OVER THE SUMMER GET UP TO DATE
RESEARCH NEAR PROUD TO BE DID
YOU TRY ON TOP THE EIGHTY THREE
THREE ONE. BUT IT IN THE SPAN
OF COKE A WEEK OUR- URGING THE
FED TO PASS AB FIFTY ONE. MORE
THAN TWENTY THOUSAND SIGNATURE.
FROM STUDENTS EDUCATE AND
PARENTS ACROSS. WE ALSO COULD
DO THAT. BY FOR A YOU CAN ONE
THE HOW MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
PLUS BROWN GOERS IMPEACH VERY
OWN STATE. OF PUBLIC AND TO
THERE. IT'S CLEAR FROM THIS
THAT. STUDENTS WANT AT THE
STUDIES AND WE WANT IT NOW NOW
WITH THE- BETTER UNDER. OUR
PEERS. HERITAGE AND HISTORY IF
YOU COULD START DISMANTLE
STEREOTYPES IN WHAT THE ****
THREE BY THE- OF THEM SO MORTON
COULD AGREED TO. REPRESENTS ALL
THE COMMUNITY OF COLOR THAT
WOULD WORK TO AMERICANS INTO
WHAT IT TODAY COMPARED. CAL FOR
EDUCATE SYSTEM CAN DO BETTER
FOR THEIR STUDENTS AND WE MUST
CALIFORNIA HAS THE UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET DIAGRAM FOR
AND SHOW THE COUNTRY WHAT
CREATING A MORE INCLUSIVE
FUTURE. EDUCATION CAN LOOK LIKE
NOW'S THE TIME TO ACT AND WE
NEED TO ACT WITHOUT IGNORANCE
AND MEET WITH COURAGE NINETY
FIRST INCLUSIVE AND POSITIVE
VISION FOR THE FUTURE. AND THAT
IS WHY THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
I'M STRONGLY URGING THE MEMBERS
OF THE FAMILY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO VOTE AYE ON EIGHTY
ONE OF ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE GO TO THE OP. WITNESS
ARE OFF WAS IT WITNESS TEN
ROSSUM AND- FROM THE A M. H. A.
N. S. A TAMMY YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN READY. MATURITY NOT HE
TAMMY ON THE PHONE LINE. OKAY
SO WHAT WE GO WILK YOU SEE OF
TAMMY DOES COME ON. WHY DON'T
WE GO TO DOCTOR OR WHEN YOU ON
WHO I BELIEVE I SAID THAT
CORRECTLY. THE CALIFORNIA ALL
RIGHTS FOUNDATION HERE. YES I'M
HERE OKAY YOU MAY PROCEED GOOD.
OKAY GOOD MORNING HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE THANK YOU
FOR GIVING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK MY NAME IS DR WILLIAM-
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR EQUAL RIGHTS
FOUNDATION A NONPARTISAN AND
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO PROMOTING
OUTSTANDING PRINCIPLES OF EQUAL
RIGHTS AND MARRIAGE. I AM HERE
TO TESTIFY AGAINST AB ONE ONE
FOR THREE MAIN REASONS FIRST
AND FOREMOST IT IS SIMPLY
IMPROVEMENTS FOR THE STATE
LEGISLATURE TO PASS A TAXPAYER
FUNDED STATE MANDATE ON ETHNIC
STUDIES WHEN TENSIONS
CONTROVERSIES AND DISCONNECT
THIS AGREEMENT ABOUND REGARDING
THE MODEL CURRICULUM. THE FINAL
MODEL CURRICULUM IF YOU WROTE
IT DOWN CHANGED IDEOLOGY CALL
FRAMEWORK OF CRITICAL ETHNIC
STUDIES AND CRITICAL PEDAGOGY
THIS IS THE SINGLE MOST CRAFTED
THE PEDAGOGY TO IMPOSE A BELIEF
SYSTEM THAT DIVIDES OUR
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS ON THE
CREW THE BASIS OF SKIN COLOR
ALRIGHT IT IS SIMPLY WRONG IN
THE STATE SHOULD NOT BOB THAT
IS WITH PUBLIC DOLLARS. SECOND
TEACHING ETHNIC STUDIES IN A
CONTEXT THAT IS PREDICATED ON
RACIAL DIVISIONS AND ACRYLICS
THAT CAUGHT IN THE EPIC
COMEBACK THE PRACTICE
FUNDAMENTALLY VIOLATES THE
FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT TO THE US
CONSTITUTION CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTIONAL GUARANTEE OF
EQUAL TREATMENT AND APRAXIA OF
ANTI DISCRIMINATION LAWS AT
FEDERAL AND STATE LEVELS
INCLUDING ARTICLES THREE AND
FOUR AT THE EDUCATION CALLED.
THIRD WITH WIDENING ACHIEVEMENT
GAPS AND LEARNING OUTCOME
DISPARITIES CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
KEY TO TWELVE EDUCATION IS
FACING AN OPPONENT IN EQUITY
CRISIS AB ONE ONE WHICH USUALLY
RESULT IN A HEFTY PRICE TAG BUT
IT IT IT'S EFFECTIVENESS IN
IMPROVING QUALITY OF PUBLIC
EDUCATION IT'S AT BEST ON TEST.
I URGE ALL MEMBERS OF THIS
ASSEMBLY EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO
REJECT AB ONE ONE AND AT THE
VOTE YOUR PRECIOUS POLITICAL
CAPITAL TO DEVICE COSTING ABOUT
COLLUSION TO ADDRESS EXISTING
DISPARITIES AND INEQUALITIES.
THANK YOU FOR HEARING MY CALL
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU DOCTOR
LET'S GO TO IT- MODERATOR TO WE
HAVE TO ROSS IN ON THE HOME. I
DO NOT SEE HER DIAL IN AT A IF
SHE IS DIALED IN AS A PER. MAY
PRESS ON STAR ZERO AND UP CAN
OPEN HER LINE. I DO NOT SEE HER
Q. AND UP OKAY- ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU I FOR SOME REASON SHE DOES.
POP UP COULD YOU LET ME KNOW.
CONSIDERABLY WE DID WANT TO
GIVE HER AN OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE OPINIONS- WITH THAT-
WE'VE HEARD FROM- THIS IS
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES-
AND WE WILL COME BRING IT BACK
TO THE CLINIC. THE COMMITTEE
HAVE ANY COMMENTS. SENA CONCERT
VENUE EMOTION SAM LICCARDO
MOVES IT. ESTERLY SECONDS
MISTER HOW DID YOU HAVE SOME
HOMES I SURE DO. YEAH I JUST
WANTED TO TALK TO THE AUTHOR
HERE I KNOW THIS HAS BEEN YOUR
PASSION FOR MANY YEARS AND- I
KNOW YOU HAVE A LOT OF BILLS
YOU CARE ABOUT THAT AT THE END
OF THE- PROFESSOR MEDINA TEN
YEAR THIS WILL BE THE ONE THAT
I THINK YOU. PROBABLY REMEMBER
THE MOUSE AND SO. THIS IS THE
YEAR WE'RE GOING TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN WE'RE GONNA. WORK ON
THIS BILL TODAY AND MAKE IT A
REALITY PREVENTIVE WORK TO PUT
MONEY. IN THE BUDGET FOR
DISTRICTS TO BE EARLY ADOPTERS
THEN I KNOW YOU'VE ASKED ME
BEFORE MY KIDS ARE IN SIXTH
GRADE AND HOPEFULLY THEY'RE
DISTRICT DOESN'T VOLUNTARY LIKE
THEY DO IN YOUR- NEIGHBORHOOD
AND YOU KNOW TWENTY TWENTY
NINES A LONG TIME- WE LIKE TO
SEE IT SOONER BUT I THINK THAT.
THIS IS A COMPROMISE YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING ON WITH THE- THE
TO THE SCHOOL COMMUNITY ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. I WILL SAY THAT IN
THIS ERA OF LOOKING AT
RECONCILIATION OF RACIAL
JUSTICE AND- THE DIVERSITY OF
OUR STUDENTS THIS IS IMPORTANT
SO THEY KNOW WHO WHO WHAT THEIR
FAMILIES LOOK LIKE IN. THEIR
FAMILY HISTORY MAKE SURE THAT
ALL HISTORY IS TAUGHT BUT ALSO.
ON THIS EXTREME DIVISION THAT
WE'RE FACING AND THE- AND THE
HATE. AND THE NOTION. MORE
RACIAL UNDERSTANDING AND
TOLERANCE ACT I CAN'T HELP TO
THINK THAT MORE. UNDERSTANDING
OF. CULTURE AND DIVERSEY AND
COMMUTERS OF COLOR BY YOUNG
HIGH SCHOOL KIDS. IS ONLY GOING
TO HELP THE SITUATION SO. THIS
IS CERTAINLY VERY VERY TIMELY
AND AGAIN YOU HAVE OUR
COMMITMENT. TO WORK IN THE
BUDGET PROCESS TO PUT SOME
RESOURCES FOR. EARLY
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS THANK
YOU MR MEDINA. FUTURE GREAT
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM ANY
OF THE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES MISTER BENNETT YEAH UP-
SHAKY AUTHORS- EFFORTS ON THIS
YOU KNOW THE STRENGTH OF
AMERICA'S OUR DIVERSITY BUT
THAT DIVERSITY HAS PRESENTED US
WITH MANY CHALLENGES- THAT ARE
STILL UNRESOLVED. THAT WE HAVE
TO WORK ON AND THIS IS ONE OF A
NUMBER OF STEPS THAT WE HAVE TO
TAKE AND SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
THIS EFFORT IF WE WAIT UNTIL
ALL OF THE CONTROVERSY IS OVER
WE WILL NEVER MOVE FORWARD WITH
THIS STEP AND THAT'S OF.
FUNDAMENTAL OF GOOD FAITH
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE AND I'M
SURE THAT THERE WILL BE
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE ESSEX DAY
CURRICULUM AS WE GO FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GREAT
THANK YOU BUT THIS WORKS ALL.
WITH AS THE AUTHOR KNOWS
EDUCATION IS REALLY THE MOST
POWERFUL TOOL WE HAVE TO
CREATE- OPEN MINDS TO CREATE-
EDUCATION WITH FACTS TO USE
CURRICULUM THAT IS NON BIASED I
KNOW THAT- THE INSTRUCTIONAL.
CORRECT OF. CURRICULUM
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN WORKING VERY
HARD ON THIS SO I LOOK FORWARD.
TO THE TIME WHEN WE PRESENT
INFORMATION. WHETHER IT'S
UPDATED INFORMATION AS WE KNOW
EVEN AS TEACHERS OR TEXTBOOKS
OVER THE YEARS HAVE CHANGED IN
THE VAULT AS WE GET NEW
INFORMATION AND HISTORY IS AN
IMPORTANT PART OF EDUCATION. SO
I'D REALLY NOT ONLY SUPPORT
THIS BUT I. ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
BE OPEN ABOUT THIS EDUCATION IS
SIMPLY ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
LEARN INFORMATION AND THEN
THOSE PEOPLE THAT LEARN IT CAN
STILL HAVE THEIR OWN OPINIONS
ABOUT HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT THE
INFORMATION THAT'S PRESENTED TO
THEM. SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS I KNOW YOU'VE WORKED ON IT
TIRELESSLY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- MR KILEY. I YEAH YOU KNOW
I DON'T DOUBT THAT THERE IS-
GREAT VALUE IN IN MANY OF THE
THINGS THAT ARE BEING TAUGHT IN
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA RIGHT
NOW- IN ELECTIVES- THAT GO BY
THE NAME OF EXPECTING STUDIES
OR- OR RELATED TOPICS AND- TO
THE AUTHOR I DON'T HAVE ANY
DOUBT THAT YOUR GOAL. IS TO.
REMOTE HEALING AND
UNDERSTANDING AND EMPOWERMENT-
BUT- MY CONCERN IS THAT. THIS
CURRICULUM AS- IT'S BEEN
DEVELOPED AS IT'S BEEN ADOPTED
IS NOW WE WOULD. UPPER PORTER
REQUIRE IT. DOES THE OPPOSITE
AND- THE REASON WE KNOW THAT IS
BECAUSE THROUGHOUT THE COURSE
OF THE PROCESS. YOU HAD VARIOUS
GROUPS WHO HAVE COME FORWARD.
AND SAID WE FEEL TARGETED BY
THIS. WE FEEL LIKE THIS
CURRICULUM IS CASTING US IN OUR
HISTORY. AND OUR CULTURE. AND
OUR BELIEFS AND OUR COMMUNITY.
IN A NEGATIVE LIGHT YOU KNOW
I'LL THE FIRST VERSION OF THIS-
THE- CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS- I THINK THE
DOZEN OR SO LEGISLATORS FROM
THIS- THIS LEGISLATURE. PUT OUT
A LETTER SAYING THAT THIS
ECHOES THE PROPAGANDA OF ****
GERMANY. AND EVEN WITH THE
REVISIONS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE.
YOU STILL HAVE FOLKS IN THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY ASIAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY. AND MANY OTHER
COMMUNITIES WILL COME FORWARD
TO THIS DOESN'T BUILD
UNDERSTANDING THIS DOESN'T
BUILD BRIDGES THIS STOKES
DIVISION AND- AND RESENTMENT.
AND SO I THINK THAT YOU KNOW.
THE PROBLEMS THAT WE SAW. WITH
THE FIRST DRAFT. DID NOT LEND
THEMSELVES TO SORT OF. SERVICE
LEVEL DIVISIONS BUT WERE REALLY
AT THE FOUNDATION OF THE WAY
THIS WHOLE THING. HAS BEEN
CONCEIVED SO I SIMPLY DO NOT
THINK THAT WHEN WE HAVE A
CURRICULUM THAT IS. INSPIRING
THAT KIND OF DIVISION IT'S
APPROPRIATE AT ALL- FOR US TO.
FORCE EVERY STUDENT IN
CALIFORNIA- TED TO TAKE IT AND
THAT LEADS ME TO MY SECOND
POINT THAT EVEN IF. WE DIDN'T
THINK THAT THIS CURRICULUM WAS
READY FOR THE CLASSROOM IN
SCHOOLS ACROSS CALIFORNIA IT IS
AN ENORMOUS LEAP FROM THAT TO
SAY THAT IT SHOULD BE A
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT- THERE
ARE A LOT OF THINGS THAT ARE OF
VALUE- THAT ARE BEING TAUGHT AS
ELECTIVES ACROSS CALIFORNIA C.
T. MANY OTHER. TYPES OF COURSES
AND SO I THINK IT'S A PRETTY
HIGH BURDEN OF PROOF THE NEEDS
TO BE MET THE STATE OF THIS NOW
SUDDENLY I NEED TO BE REQUIRED
ESPECIALLY WHEN AS ONE OF THE
WITNESS NOTED WE HAVE SOME OF
THE WORST EDUCATION OUTCOMES IN
CALIFORNIA OF ANY STATE IN THE
COUNTRY WE HAVE- SOME OF THE
WORST ACHIEVEMENT GAPS OF ANY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY FOR KIDS
IN. UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES-
EVEN BEFORE COBIT NINETEEN WE
RANKED FORTY NINTH OUT OF FIFTY
OF COURSE WE'VE BEEN THE LAST
IN THE COUNTRY IN GETTING KIDS
BACK TO THE CLASSROOM I'VE BEEN
ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR. OVER
FOUR YEARS AND I SEE TIME AFTER
TIME ACTIONS TAKEN THAT WIDEN
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS THAT
DISEMPOWER STUDENTS SO. I
REALLY THINK THAT IF WE WERE
SERIOUS ABOUT EMPOWERING AT
KIDS IN CALIFORNIA OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS WE TAKE A LOOK AT
THE EDUCATION REFORMS THAT HAVE
SUCCEEDED IN OTHER STATES IN
CLOSING ACHIEVEMENT GAPS. AND%
THAT WOULD BE OUR COURSE OF
ACTION- IT WOULDN'T BE TO ADOPT
A CURRICULUM THAT- THERE'S
REALLY NO EVIDENCE IS GOING TO
IMPROVE ACADEMIC OUTCOMES AND-
THERE'S A LOT OF EVIDENCE THAT
IT'LL HAVE AN AS SOME BAD
EFFECTS ON- THE NATURE OF OUR-
COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
TODAY SO I WOULD AT
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO BE VOTING
AGAINST THIS TODAY. THANK YOU.
AND OTHER MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS JUST
TO CLARIFY- YOU DO WANT TO
APPLY TO CHARTER SCHOOLS YES
THEY TOO. SHOULD- NEED ALL. THE
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS I APPRECIATE THAT
WE DO HAVE ON THE PHONE BACK ON
THE PHONE FOR IN OPPOSITION- I
WANNA GIVE HER AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WEIGH IN FOR TWO MINUTES
TAMMI ROSSMAN BENJAMIN. I
BELIEVE- IS ON THE PHONE SO YOU
MAY PROCEED WITH YOUR
OPPOSITION STATEMENT. THANK YOU
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES I CAN'T
LITTLE LOUDER MAYBE. EIGHT OKAY
GOOD MORNING I'M CAN YOU ROTH
CONTINGENT CORRECTOR UP
INITIATIVE AND I TALKED EXPRESS
MY RGANIZATIONS STRONG
OPPOSITION AB ONE DON'T.
DESPITE FOR WITH. HE APPROVED
EPIC STUDY MODEL. LEVINE
STERNLY ROOTED IN CRITICAL AT
STUDIES AND UNIVERSAL
CONCEPTUAL OF THE FIELD. WITH
AND ACTIVISTS. TO WORKING THAT
INVESTS CAMPUS SEMITISM WE HAVE
WITNESSED HOW COURSES BASED
CONCRETE EXTRA CAN TAKE BETWEEN
AND HATRED AMONG. MISSION TO
THE OF CRITICAL STUDIES. IN PER.
ARE JUNE VETERANS WHO PREFER
OPPRESSORS AND THE TIME WHEN IT
JEWISH. BEHIND HAS REACHED ON.
LEVELS IN TALK TO ME STUDENTS
TO VIEW IN THIS WAY HIS
CAMPAIGN TO PUTTING ANYTHING
LAW TARGET ON THE BACKS.
ALARMINGLY EVEN MORE PEOPLE
INTO COULD. PARKING SIX PEDDLED
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL TO. ARE
EDUCATE RESPOND TO FOR THE
CURRICULUMS. REJECTED DRAFT
OVER ANTI SOME CON OUT. THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY STATE. AND THE
COPS. BUT EIGHT PEOPLE NO ONE
WOULD ALLOW COURSES TAUGHT YOU
UNDERSUPPLY FOR HALF TO
PERSONAL THE GRADUATION UPON
YOUR. THE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
JUST. UNIVERSITY SCHOLAR TO
ENACT THE- INCLUDING NOBEL LOW.
FOUND ABSOLUTELY EMPIRICAL
PROOF THAT STUDIES COURSES.
BENEFITS FOR STUDENTS
CONSIDERING THE CATASTROPHIC IF
YOULAW SIX BY OUR- TO PAY.
IANS ATTACHED DOLLARS TO IMPOSE
TO HELP REQUIRING A COURSE. NOT
CONSUME TO IMPROVE STUDENT
ACADEMIC CHIEF IS QUITE LIKE TO
CATCH UP THERE TO. IS THE
RESPONSE AND UNETHICAL THANK
YOU. DEEP DIVISIONS ARE SOCIETY
SOMETIMES UGLY UNCOMFORTABLE DO
SO BUT IT IS IMPORTANT TO SELL
SO I'M HAPPY TO JOIN AS A CO
AUTHOR AT THE NEXT OPPORTUNITY
DO SO AND- I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK AND FIGURING THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. REPUBLICAN OKAY OKAY
BOB WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE PHONE
BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT THERE TO
INDIVIDUALS IN THE ROOM THAT
WISH TO COMMENT SO DO NOW IT
WILL TAKE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WOULD YOU COME FORWARD STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL ONLY MY
NAME IS MICHELLE THIS ERA AND
THE DIRECTOR OF REVIVAL
CHRISTIAN ACADEMY I FLIP THIS
MORNING FOR MENIFEE IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. HI AMMUNITION MAKER
AND I CAME TO STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TODAY. THANK YOU.
WITH THAT WE'RE TO GO TO THE
PHONE FOR TEN MINUTES- AND
AGAIN WHEN YOU'RE ON THE PHONE
WHAT YOU DO WHEN YOU WHEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JUST STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL ONLY MODERATOR IF
THERE'S ANY FURTHER EDITORIAL
PLEASE CUT THEM OFF AND MOVE TO
THE NEXT CALLER- LET'S. TO THE
PHONE PLEASE. IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE SIXTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES HE AND
I'M WITHIN FORMING PARENTS THE
PROTECTING CHILDREN IN THE
MONTEREY COUNTY. SAN BENITO
REGION AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE CRITICAL RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
OF TWO FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH HELLO I TWO FIFTY GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN.
SORRY YES MY NAME IS MICHELLE
GONZALEZ STILL I'M WITH
ALLIANCE TO PROTECT CHILDREN WE
ARE BASED IN ORANGE COUNTY BUT
WE ARE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE
OH ONE. THANK YOU. EDLINE I'D
TO FORTY NINE- LINES OPEN GOOD
MORNING MARC SAID SERRA DOES
THE DíAS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB ONE OH ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BLIND CHIU
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MARY WILLIS
AND I LIVE IN A BIG. YOU CAN
MAKE A VERY SMALL TOWN IN. THE
MOUNTAINS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND WHEN THE GST THANK YOU
THREE TWENTY NINE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU. AND TWO
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO I'M ROMONA SCOTT AND I'M
A VERY CONCERNED PARENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSES DIVISIVE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO GOOD
MORNING TODAY AND YOU'RE
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS TOP TWENTY CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT ABOUT
A LINE OF ONE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN OKAY HI MY NAME IS
HENRY AND I AM A CONCERNED
PARENT I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE
OH ONE. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
OF TWO FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS STOP ME WITHIN FOR
PARENTS THE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF TWO
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SAMANTHA THANK
WITH NEXT IN CALIFORNIA AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU BACK
TO THE LINE OF TWO SEVENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY TWO
SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SO I HAD YOUR LINES OPEN. AND I.
AB. ONE THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
OF TWO EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. JENNIFER CHANDLER
GENERATION UP IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB ONE. THANK YOU. NEXAVAR
LINE OF TWO EIGHTY FOUR YEAR
ONE OR TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU OKAY YEAH
THIS IS ABOUT FROM SACRAMENTO
AND I'M A SUPPORTER OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR EQUAL RIGHTS
FOUNDATION AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE OH ONE. THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE OF TWO SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS A LADY CAGE BURRELL LATE I
AM WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
ORGANIZATION MASSRESISTANCE AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSED AB ONE OH
ONE. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF
ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MEXICO LINE OF
TWO SEVENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS CHRISTY
HEARING TEN EIGHT CONCERNED
GRANDPARENT IN STRONG
OPPOSITION AB ONE ON ONE. THANK
YOU THANKS FOR THE LINE OF ONE
SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO I'M I'M WITH. EQUAL
RIGHTS FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE BY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF TWO EIGHTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. BY TO THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS CATHERINE
SHU I'M A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
IN THE CARE OF OUR UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH ONE.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF TWO
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THEY DROPPED SOME OF THE LINE
OF NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THE COUNTRY GARAGE
WITH THE SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BUT A LINE OF TWO
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS RON CHAU
FROM SAN DIEGO I'M A SUPPORTER
OF CALIFORNIANS FOR EQUAL
RIGHTS FOUNDATION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE OF ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MEXICO
ONE OF TWO THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES LISA PARKWAY
WITH WILL IMPACT AND WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO EIGHTY ONE
OH ONE. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF TWO FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
JEREMY CURRENT SHOW FOR I AM A
DEBT COLLEGE STUDENT AND A
FORMER STUDENT BOARD MEMBER AS
WELL AS A SIGNAL CALLER I. IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE- BILL.
THANK YOU. I LOVE THE LINE OF
TWO FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING BETTER
BENJAMIN I'M A STUDENT IN THE
OPENING BY SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
PART OF GAPS AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB ONE OH ONE. THANK
YOU. AN EXTRA LINE OF NEW FIFTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MORNING
ALL REPRESENTING HUNDREDS OF
CONCERNED PARENTS FROM ONE NOT
SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH A HOST AB
ONE LAST. THANK YOU NEXT LEVEL
ONE OF ONE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CHECK BALK AT
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS ON THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SUPERINTENDENT
OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY IN SUPPORT.
YOU EXTRA BUT A LOT OF TO
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IT
CAN RULE AND THE SHE BOTH
CHRISTIAN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE BOARD MEMBERS ALL OF THE
THAT JUGGLING WITH THE TEACHER
TELEVISION ARE PROMPTED THE
GENTLEMAN FROM THE DISTRICT
FIFTEEN AM VOICING APACHE CORP
AB. ONE OH ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT OF LINE OF FIFTY. YOUR
LINE IS. MY NAME IS LAURIE
CARDOZA MOORE I'M PRESIDENT OF
PROCLAIMING JUSTICE TO THE
NATIONS A NONPROFIT CHRISTIAN
ORGANIZATION AND SPECIAL ENVOY
TO THE UNITED NATIONS BUT THE
WORLD COUNCIL OF INDEPENDENT
CHRISTIAN CHURCHES AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. EIGHTY ONE OH
ONE. THANK YOU. AND NEXT OF OUR
LINE OF ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THAT THIS IS
ABOUT GARCIA ON BEHALF OF THE
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL
AND WE TO RUN UP THE FIRST
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. THANK
YOU. NEXT OF A LINE OF ONE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BACKGROUND ANDERSON A STATUS
THEN IN LOS ANGELES I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE OTHER ONE. THANK
YOU. NEXAVAR LINE OF ONE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FIND ONE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT TO A LINE OF A ONE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN I DON'T
KNOW I THINK THERE'S A GUY THAT
WILL TELL ME WHAT LIKE ONE
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YES GO AHEAD- MY NAME IS
MARTIN I BORROWED I AM A
CONCERNED PARENT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE OH ONE. THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE OF TWO FORTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBERS THIS IS ASHLEY
WALKER WITH NOT MEN ON BEHALF
OF THE MONTEREY COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE OH FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. FOUR ONE OH
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
CAN I SPEAK YES YES GO AHEAD
OF. MY NAME IS CHERYL KAPLAN
AND I AM ON A CONCERNED PARENT%
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY
WHEN I WENT. THANK YOU. NEXT TO
THE LINE OF TWO FORTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
MICHELLE ALLEN I AM A STUDENT
OF COLOR IN THE MOUNT DIABLO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AND THE REPRESENTATIVE OF CHEN
OPT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. NEXAVAR LINE
OF ONE SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
SHERRY LARA COME FROM LOS
ANGELES I'M AN ATTORNEY AND
FORMER COLLEGE PROFESSOR I AM
STRONGLY STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB.
ONE OH ONE. THANK YOU. MEXICO
LINE OF. SIXTY SEVEN. BERMAN
WHO GO TO LINE TWO OH FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOUR AVAILABLE
REPRESENTING DISSOCIATION OF
COPPER SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR FOR
ITS AMENDED PETITION STRIKING
THE IMPROVISED LANGUAGE AND
REPLACING IT WITH THE EXISTING
OVERARCHING INSTRUCTIONAL
MATERIAL CONFECTION REPORT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR TALKING OKAY UP. TO THE
MODERATOR WILL TAKE TWO MORE
CALLS PLEASE. OKAY LINES SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS TERRY FILE OUR LANDMARK
I'M A CONTRACTOR AND I AM
AGAINST COMPETITION TO EIGHTY
ONE OH ONE. THANK YOU. CONNECT
OF A LINE OF A TWO FORTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SECRETARY
SHANAHAN CROWNED NO PORT BEACH
I'M A CONCERNED PARENT AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE EIGHTY ONE ON
ONE. THANK YOU MODERATOR EXCUSE
ME MISTER CHAIR I MODERATED BY
MAY HOW MANY JOBS DO WE HAVE ON
THE LINE. THAT WE HAVE FORTY
MORE IN Q. YEAH OKAY DO WE
SHOULD WE HAVE A TIME LIMIT WE
HAVE A TIME LIMIT FOR EACH BILL
OF TEN MINUTES. AND YOU WERE
MADE WELL AWARE THAT MR KILEY
BEFORE YOU EVEN WALKED INTO
THIS ROOM TODAY. SO THERE IT IS
I'M SORRY LET'S GO TO THE
LEGISLATURE. SO I THINK WE
SHOULD JUST LET THE FORTY FOLKS
WANT TO TESTIFY. WHERE YOU CAN
THE AUTHORITIES LEFT DEBATE. MR
KILEY PLEASE. IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN YOU WERE ADVISED THAT
THE NEW ONE WE ASK MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I MISS COOK SO
EVEN WHICH IS A THIRD OF THE
FORTY KILEY. MR KILEY. MR
KILEY. PUT A SHOW ON SOMEWHERE
ELSE TODAY'S NOT THE DAY IF YOU
THINK. OUR MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
GOVERNMENT IS A CHAU KILEY.
FORTY PEOPLE TAKE EARLY MINUTES
THEY SHOULD HAVE A CHANCE TO
TESTIFY. ARE YOU DONE. FORTY
PEOPLE. YOU MAY CLOSE MISS
COMMITTEE I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION TO ALLOW PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TO CONTINUE MOTION IS
OUT OF ORDER MR MEDINA YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I WANT TO FIRST THANK. ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS ON AB ONE
OH ONE. I WANT TO CLOSE BY
SAYING THAT I WAS A TEACHER
THIRTY FOUR YEARS AND HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TEACH ETHNIC
STUDIES AS WELL AS CHICANO
STUDIES AT RIVERSIDE POLY HIGH
SCHOOL. WHEN I TAUGHT THAT
CLASS I SAW THE CHANGE IN MY
STUDENTS WHO WERE ATTENDING MY
CLASS AND WE'RE LEARNING
INFORMATION AND FACTS THAT THEY
HAD NEVER BEEN PRESENTED BEFORE
AND I SAW HOW THAT CHANGE. THEM
AS STUDENTS AND I KNOW THAT
THIS WILL ALSO HAPPEN WITH
OTHER STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN ETHNIC
STUDIES IS IMPLEMENTED. AND I
THANK EVERYONE WHO- WHO
TESTIFIED AND CAME OUT TO BE A
WITNESS- ON THIS BILL. I WANT
TO ECHO THE WORDS OF THE ALVIN
LEE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF CHEN
UP. THAT NOW IS THE TIME IT'S
BEEN OVER FIFTY YEARS IN THE
MAKING OF FOR ETHNIC STUDIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. GREAT THANK YOU THE
MOTION. IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED PREVIOUSLY. AS ONE OF
VERIFY THAT CORRECT BUT I'M
SECRETARY. ASSEMBLY MR LEE WAS
THE SECOND THERE WAS A PERSON
WITH A GOOD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- THANK YOU MR
MEDINA. THE WORK. DOT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL AB ONE OH ONE THE
MOTION IS THE PASSES A MANAGER
APPROPRIATIONS THE DONALD HI
DONALD FIVE KILEYKILEY NOW
SENATE. SENATE I VALLEY. DALLY
PLEASE TIME LEAI MCCARTY
MCCARTY I QUICK SILVA
QUICKSILVER I. THE TWO SORRY
THE TWO OKAY THE BILL HAS FIVE
VOTES IT IS OUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MR MEDINA THIS PROCEED OUR
NEXT BILL THAT IS- AB ONE ZERO
FIVE FIVE FILE ITEM FOURTEEN BY
MISTER RAMOS BY MISTER ROMANS.
WHEN YOU'RE READY MISTER RAMOS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- PRESERVATIVE PRESENT
THIS BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS FOR AB TEN FIFTY
FIVE. THAT'S MY COLLEAGUES HERE
ARE AWARE OUR STATE HAS A
HISTORY OF INEQUITY TO THE
TREATMENT OF CALIFORNIA NATIVE
PEOPLE WE ALMOST WORK TOWARDS
HEALING FROM THE PAST OUR
COLLECTIVE HISTORY INCLUDES
MANY MISGUIDED POLICIES. AIMED
AT TRAVEL CHILDREN ESPECIALLY
IN THE REALM OF EDUCATION ONE
EXAMPLE IS THE HISTORY OF
BOARDING SCHOOLS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TOWARDS THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE ELIMINATING
THEIR LANGUAGE AND THEIR THEIR
CULTURE MOVING FORWARD. NATIVE
YOU FACE SOME OF THE LOWEST
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATION RATES
AND EVEN FEWER ENROLL IN AND
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE. IN SEVEN
STATES WITH THE HIGHEST
POPULATION OF NATIVE AMERICANS
WITH CALIFORNIA BEING THE
NUMBER ONE. ON AVERAGE LESS
THAN 50% OF NATIVE STUDENTS
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
FURTHER WE KNOW THAT FOSTER
YOU. ALSO HAVE FAR WORSE
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES THEN THEIR
SCHOOL PEERS IN GENERAL. AB TEN
FIFTY FIVE HELPS EXPAND A. B.
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO. WHICH
EXTENDED THE DEFINITION OF A
STUDENT IN FOSTER CARE TO
STUDENTS UNDER THE JURISDICTION
OF TRIBAL COURTS WITHOUT
EXTENDING DISASSOCIATED
SERVICES. THIS MEANS NATIVE
AMERICAN FOSTER CARE STUDENTS
ARE NOT AFFORDED THE SUPPORT
SERVICES AND NECESSARY
RESOURCES OF THEIR PEERS. AB
TEN FIFTY FIVE BUILDS ON THE
WOULD MEASURE BILL BY INCLUDING
NATIVE FOSTER YOUTH IN THE
PROTECTION AND SERVICES OFFERED
TO OTHER YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE.
THIS BILL. WOULD RELIEVE ALLEY
AS FROM THE OBLIGATION TO
IDENTIFY STUDENTS UNDER THEIR
JURISDICTION OF TRIBAL COURT
AND INSTEAD ALLOW TRIBES TO
INITIATE NOTICE. MISTER CHAIR.
THERE IS A JUDGE JUDGE
CLAUDETTE WHITE CHIEF JUDGE OF
THE QUICK CHON TRIBAL COURT
THAT BROUGHT THIS LANGUAGE TO
ME IN THIS ISSUE TO ME AND IT'S
SAD TO SAY THAT SHE SUCCUMBED
TO CARBON NINETEEN IN FEBRUARY
AT THE AGE OF FORTY NINE. A
QUICK JOHN MEMBER WHO BECAME
CHIEF JUDGE SEEN THE
DISPARITIES HAPPENING TO OUR
INDIAN KIDS JUDGE WHY IT WAS A
TOWERING FIGURE IN INDIAN LAW
AND TRIBAL COURTS AND
PASSIONATE ADVOCATE FOR NATIVE
AMERICANS. WITH ME TODAY. IS
MICHELLE PERATA ADMINISTRATOR
OF ALL TRIBES AMERICAN INDIAN
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN KIMBERLY
CLOUGH LEGAL DIRECTOR FROM
CALIFORNIA TRIBAL FAMILIES
COALITION. AND THEY WILL BE
OFFERING TESTIMONY THANK YOU WE
WILL NOT GO TO YOUR WITNESS IS
I BELIEVE MISS CLUB IS NOT
GOING TO MAKE IT I BELIEVE SHE
IS A SHE IS GOING TO MAKE IT
OKAY I I'M INCORRECT ON THAT
SOAP. SO TEAR WITNESSES ON THE
PHONE. NUMBER LIKE WHAT. GOOD
MORNING I AM THE LEGAL DIRECTOR
FOR CALIFORNIA TRAVEL FAMILIES
COALITION. HFT IS A TRIBAL
COALITION OF OVER FORTY
CALIFORNIA TRIBES AND TRIBAL
ORGANIZATIONS HFT IS A PROUD
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROB US FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN ADDRESSING
THE SYSTEMIC INEQUITIES. THAT
CALIFORNIA TROUBLED COMMUNITY
STATE. I DON'T THINK THE
COMEDIAN COMMITTEE STAFF AND WE
HAVE GLADLY ACCEPTED THE
REQUESTED AMENDMENTS. AB ONE
FIFTY FIVE WHICH BROUGHT
FORWARD IN ORDER CAN MAKE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A PRIOR BILL
AB NINETEEN SIXTY TWO MORE
SEAMLESS AND THE FACT THAT. AS
IT OFTEN HAPPENS WE HAVE
LEARNED LESSONS SINCE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO WITH PASSED.
IN YOU COMPLICATED FOSTER USE
AN EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM SOMETIMES
WE NEED CLARITY ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION. ESPECIALLY WITH
EDUCATIONAL SUPPORT- TRAVEL
FASTER YOUTH AND ALSO STUDENTS
UNDER VOLUNTARY PLACEMENT AGREE.
THE EDUCATION CODE SUPPORTS IN
EXISTING LAW THAT WE WANT TO
EXPAND AND SECURE FOR FOSTER
YOUTH THEIR COMMON SENSE FOR
EXAMPLE WE WERE COOL FEES SUCH
AS THE TEXTBOOK OR LIBRARY
FEASIBLE FOSTER CHILD WILL NOT
BE PREVENTED IN ROLLING AND
START TO GET INTO SCHOOL AND
THEY HAVE THE MOVE. BECAUSE
THEY HAVE TO MOVE FOSTER CARE
PLACEMENT. PRETTY COMMON. AN
EXEMPLARY CLARIFICATION THAT
THIS BILL MAKES. IS IN RELATION
TO WHEN THE TRIBAL COURTS MAKE
THEIR FINDINGS THE LAW
CURRENTLY REQUIRES TRIBAL
COURTS TO MAKE A FINDING UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW. BUT TRAVEL
COURT JUDGES THEY NEED TO LOOK
TO TRIBAL WHAT. SO THIS I JUST
BUILDING IN NINETEEN SIXTY TWO
THAT WE HAVE AN EIGHTY TEN
FIFTY FIVE WILL ALLOW TRIBAL
COURT JUDGES TO MAKE THE NEED
OF FINDING THE TRIBAL CHILDREN
THAT ARE FOSTER CHILDREN UNDER
THEIR JURISDICTION. CAN STILL
BENEFIT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION CODE BENEFITS. THIS
BILL AMENDS STATE LAW WE HAVE
CLARITY ON THE TRIBAL COURT
FIGHTS IN THE STATE EDUCATIONAL
FIVE ON HOW WE MAKE THE
BENEFITS RUN TO TRAVEL FOSTER
YOU. EITHER COMMONSENSE
SOLUTION WE SUMMARIZE NEED TO
IMPLEMENT THAT. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND YOU RESPECTFULLY
ASK THEIR AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY
TEN FIFTY FIVE THANK YOU TO THE
NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALMOST FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP THE TYPICAL
TIME CALIFORNIA'S WE FACE AN
EQUITIES IN THE PAST AND FORGE
FORWARD. IN YOUR BILL AVOID HER
TRIBE AND OUR PEOPLE IT IS
DEEPLY APPRECIATED. MORNING AND
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MICHELLE PRODUCTS I
MILLION CONTRACT WILL MEMBERS A
FOSTER PARENT ONE OF THE
FOUNDERS OF ALL TRIBES AMERICAN
INDIAN CHARTER SCHOOL. HONORING
QUALITY RESERVATIONS SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. URINE OUR TWENTIETH
YEAR AS A CALIFORNIA CREDIT THE
PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOL. WE ALL
TRIED SCHOOL STIRS PK THROUGH
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS. WE FOUND
OF THE SCHOOL DRESS ISSUES. WE
SAW IN OUR COMMUNITY INCLUDING
LOWER ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE AND
LOW GRADUATION RATES. THIS
SCHOOL YEAR WE HAVE A HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR STUDENTS WHO COME
FROM MORE THAN TWELVE
RESERVATIONS AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA. WE SEE FIRSTHAND
THE IMPACT OUR STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
ISSUES THE STUDENTS FACE COULD
NOT CHANGE WHETHER THEY ARE IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM TO THE
STATE COURT OR TRAVEL COURT.
ORDINATOR STUDENTS LEAD THE
SECTOR SUPPORTS THAT THE
EDUCATION CODE PROVIDES. I'D
LIKE TO TELL YOUR STORY. WE
HAVE A SIBLING GROUP OF FIVE
CHILDREN IN OUR SCHOOL THE
THREE OLDEST CHILDREN PLACED
WITH THEIR GRANDPARENTS.
THROUGH THE TROUBLES WITH THE-
YOUNGEST TO THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA CAR SYSTEM. THREE
OLDER CHILDREN SHE VIRTUALLY
ZERO SUPPORT THE FOSTER YOUTH.
THEY DO NOT GET EXTRA SUPPORT.
IN THEIR SCHOOLS. AND THE
GRANDPARENTS DO NOT GET EXTRA
SUPPORT FINANCIALLY. THE TWO
YOUNGER CHILDREN THAT ARE IN
THE COUNTY FOSTER CARE SYSTEM.
GET EXTRA SUPPORT IN THEIR
EDUCATION AND THEIR
GRANDPARENTS GIVE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR THEM. UNFORTUNATELY
THE TWO YOUNGER ONES HAVING
BEEN THROUGH THE COUNTY FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM- MORE TRAUMATIZED.
STRUGGLE MORE WITH SEVEN SEVEN
MULTIPLE FOSTER HOMES. BEFORE
THEY FINALLY GOT PLACE FOR THE
GRANDPARENTS. THE POINT IS THAT
THE TROUBLED FOSTER CARE
SYSTEMS ARE BETTER CAñADA
CHILDREN BUT WE MUST ENSURE
THAT THESE TRAVEL CHILDREN
DON'T LOSE OUT ON THE BENEFITS.
OF STATE LAW EDUCATIONAL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME ATTENTION TO THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. I HAVE TROUBLE.
THANK YOU I DO BELIEVE WE HAVE
NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHY
DON'T WE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
IT'S BEEN MOVED. AND SECONDED
BY MR MCCARTY- MOVED SECONDED-
IT WITH THAT NO COMMENT BERMAN
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS- LET US
GO TO THE PHONES. FOR SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION TEN MINUTES TO
THE MODERATE. IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. RHUMBLINE ONE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
PLEASE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
CALLER. THANK. ONE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THE
CALIFORNIA TAKING CON ON BEHALF
OF THE VERONA BANDIT MISSION
INDIANS IN SUPPORT. AND THREE
FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS NOW
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THE DEFENSE
ATTORNEY HAVE A CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT. ONE THREE EIGHTY SIX.
RIGHT HI MY NAME IS COURTNEY
MCDANIEL WITH- ADVOCATES FOR
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN AND
ROCKLIN CALIFORNIA I WOULD LIKE
TO SAY SHAME ON THAT- COMMITTEE
CHAIR FOR LIMITING COMMENTS.
THAT'S DISGUSTING. ONE NINE
THREE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WARNING THIS IS DANIELLE
pALLIANCE OF CHILD AND FAMILY
SERVICES IN SUPPORT. ONE ONE
NINETY NINE GO HEAD. ONE ONE
NINETY NINE. HI MY NAME. TO THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE ONE NINETY
NINE A PLEASE OPEN UP AGAIN I'M
SORRY TECHNICAL. HI MY NAME
PLEASE DIRECT AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE EIGHTY ONE OH ONE. AND I
LIKE MY BOY THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND MOVE ON BECAUSE THAT IS NOT
THE BILL WE ARE WE ARE. HAVE
UNDER DISCUSSION AT THIS MOMENT.
ONE THREE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS PRETTY HOT WITH RESOLUTE ON
BEHALF OF THE ABOUT MENTAL
ALMOST AFTER LAKE TRIED IN
SUPPORT OF AB TEN FIFTY FIVE.
THANK YOU. ONE THREE NINETY
FIVE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
METED OUT I AM A CONCERNED
PARENT AND I'M WITH ICAD IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB ONE OH ONE
THANK YOU. ONE THREE SIX SIXTY
SEVEN GO AHEAD. LINE TWO SIXTY
SEVEN GO AHEAD. I I'M SORRY I
DID NOT GET MY STATE NUMBER-
LADY CAGE BORRELLI- CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED A. B.
ONE I'M. ONE ZERO FIVE FIVE.
LINE ONE SIXTY TWO GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS KELLY SING HUSKY AND
I'D LIKE TO ECHO WHAT OTHER
COLORS ARE BAD SHAME ON THE
COMMITTEE CARE CHAIR AND GIVE
HIS MOVE ON THE NEXT CALLER.
PLEASE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
CALLER. NINE THREE THIRTY ONE
GO AHEAD. AND WITH THE WIND
THREE THIRTY ONE WE'RE HAVING
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES. THERE'S
NO OTHERS LEFT AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU BUT BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE OTHERS BEEN A
MOTION AND A SECOND- THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED HUMAN
SERVICES THANK YOU FOR THE BILL
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THIS MUCH
NEEDED- BILL MOVING FORWARD IN
HELPING THE TRIBAL YOUTH IN
THIS PARTICULARLY THOSE IN
FOSTER CARE AYE URGENT AYE VOTE
AND WOULD OPEN UP IN AND
ENTERTAIN ANY CALL AUTHORS I'M
ADDING ON TO THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU MISTER
ROBERTS FOR THE BILL WITH THAT-
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB TEN FIFTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON HUMAN SERVICES
BUT DONALD. HI DONALD HI KILEY.
KILEY I'D BENNETT. SENATE I
VALLEY SALLY I LIED MCCARTY
MCCARTY I QUIT SILVA. BY THE-
THE BILL HAS BY VOTERS AFTER
WHAT WAS WRONG WITH HER THANK
YOU WITH THAT ONE NOW MOVE ON
TO AB FOUR SIX NINE FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN BY MISS REYES. YOU MAY
RECEIVE AN READY. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TODAY I
PRESENT TO YOU AB FOUR SIX NINE
WHICH REQUIRES LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES OR ELLIE
AS TO ENSURE THAT ALL HIGH
SCHOOL SENIORS COMPLETE THE
PHELPS PHONE OR CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT APPLICATION TO FOR
FINANCIAL AID BEFORE GRADUATING
THIS BILL IS ALIGNED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL AND
IS A LATINO CAUCUS PRIORITY
BILL. IT IS SUPPORTED BY GROUPS
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE LOTUS
WHAT THE FOUNDATION AND OUR
SPONSOR EDUCATION TRUST WEST.
CUPBOARD NINETEEN EXACERBATED
AT THE UNESCO THE STUDENTS FACE
WHEN APPLYING FOR COLLEGE.
INCLUDING COMPLETING FINANCIAL
AID FORMS. IN THE PAST YEAR OUR
STATE SAW 5%DECREASE IN PHELPS
WERE APPLICATIONS AND A
THIRTEEN DECREASE IN CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT APPLICATIONS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LARGEST
IMPACTS ARE FELT BY LOW INCOME
STUDENTS WHO PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE QUALIFIED. MANY ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS DO NOT COMPLETE A
FINANCIAL AID FORM BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THEY ARE INELIGIBLE
HAVE LITTLE INFORMATION ON HOW
TO APPLY OR LACKS SUPPORT IN
THE APPLICATION PROCESS. IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS ALONE NEARLY
HALF A MILLION. HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS IN CALIFORNIA DID NOT
COMPLETE THE PHELPS WERE OR THE
DREAM ACT. APPLICATION LEAVING
AN ESTIMATED FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
AND FEDERAL FINANCIAL AID ON
THE TABLE. AB FOUR SIX NINE
INSURERS ALL STUDENTS GET THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO SUPPORT
CRITICAL FORMS FOR FINANCIAL
AID. CALIFORNIA TYPICALLY LEADS
THE NATION A PROGRESSIVE POLICY
MAKING BUT IN TERMS OF PHELPS
FOR COMPLETION OUR STATE IS
FALLING BEHIND OTHER STATES
SUCH AS LOUISIANA TENNESSEE AND
TEXAS HAVE ALREADY IMPLEMENTED
SIMILAR STATEWIDE POLICIES. AND
THEIR STUDENTS HAVE REAPED THE
BENEFITS IT IS TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO JOIN THE EFFORT.
THIS BILL RECOGNIZES THE NEED
TO HAVE PROTECTIONS ALSO FOR
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS BY
EXPLICITLY REFERENCING STATE
AND FEDERAL PRIVACY LAWS. IT
ALSO EQUIPS ELEAZAR WITH THE
GUIDANCE THEY NEED TO
IMPLEMENTED THIS REQUIREMENT BY
OUTLINING THE RESOURCES TO
WHICH THEY CAN DIRECT STUDENTS
FOR SUPPORT. HERE TO TESTIFY.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL ARE
COMPELLING ENOUGH TO POINT THIS
CHAIR THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
AID COMMISSION AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS. AT THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AS
WELL AS MIKE MCCORMICK
SUPERINTENDENT OF ALBERDI UNION
SCHOOL DISTRICT. TO THE-
WITNESSES. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR COMING A MEMBER YES I
MY NAME IS TIMOTHY CUENTA
UNLIKE RICHARD EARLIER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR COLLEGE AND
CAREER READINESS AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AT A
LOCAL FORTUNATE TO BE THE CHAIR
OF THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND HIS
OFFERING DIGITAL CAMPFIRE ARE
CONCERNED AFTER ANY QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS ABOUT-WHAT COULD
HAPPEN OF THIS BILL WHAT IT
WOULD AFFECT OUR STUDENTS.
CONSIDERING CHIU OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY
WITH THE FIRST IN THE STATE TO
ENACT THE GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT- FOR THEIR STUDENTS
WELL FIRST I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS IN TERMS
OF DATA SECURITY AND PRIVACY
FROM THE CALIFORNIA SENATE
COMMISSION- CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW
WITH YOU IN A MINUTE-
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT OUR FAX
APPLICATION WE DO NOT IDENTIFY
THEDIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TWO
I AM BECAUSE OF MICHAEL COUNTY
OFFICE I HAVE ONE OF THE
LARGEST ACCOUNT. ACCESS TO THE
STUDENT LEVEL DATA OF THE
COMMISSION BEEN VERY MAC
COMMISSION BUT IN ANY AND ALL
OF MY RECORDS I CANNOT TELL THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE FACT
THAT ARE CALIFORNIA DREAM
MATCH- ARE COMPLETED SO FOR
EXAMPLE QUITE CONCERNED CANNOT
AS A TEACHER HAS ACTED TO A
LIVE WILL BE DEALT THE ANSWER
IS NO THE ANSWER IS THAT- WE DO
NOT KNOW THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THE TWO OUR JOB IS TO JUST
ENCOURAGE AND SUPPORT ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS HAVE BEEN MET-
ALSO A CONDITIONAL CONCERNS
HAVE COME UP IN REGARDS YOU.
ARE DOCUMENTED STUDENTS AND HOW
WE SUPPORT THEM ENCOURAGE THE
COMMISSION OF WORKING ON
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AND
TRAINING WE DO THE WORK NOW
WITH ARE UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES
AND THE GOAL IS TO NOT CONTINUE
TO ALLOW THEM TO MAKE DECISIONS
IN THE DARK AND THAT'S WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN OUR STATE OUR
DOCUMENTS FAMILIES DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE PROCESS MORE
THAN 65% OF OUR STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE FIRST GENERATION
AND SO THEY NEED HELP THEY NEED
SUPPORT FOR THEIR MAKING AN
UNEDUCATED DECISION NOT. A
MINUTE BECAUSE THEY JUST DON'T
KNOW ANY BETTER SO THE
COMMISSION IS COMMITTED IN THE
FEEDBACK TEAM COMMITTED. TO IF
PATH TO EXPAND YOU. TRAINING TO
ENSURE THEY HAVE. IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT LEN PERFECT. IT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE DATA AND OF. IN
WE'RE- MILLIONS OF OLLARS
FEDERAL DOLLARS IN CAN BRING TO
OUR STATE OUR COMMUNITY. IF WE
JUST HAVE A FEW. THE MESROP OF.
AND LIKE I SURE THE DON'T KNOW
WHEN THE GOAL. TO SYSTEMIC
APPROACH FOR STUDENTS ARE IN
THE- DEPENDS. THE HEALTH. MY
THANFIFTY FIVE COULD OF THE
AND MIKE. 65% A FAMILY GLAZER
COUNTY SEVENTY ONE. OVER ARE.
WOULD BE WANT. THEY DON'T HAVE
PARENTS THAT THEY CAN GO HOME
LIKE OUR- NEW. AND NEPHEWS AND-
TAKING TO ONE. WE'VE GONE TO
CALL. THEY'RE DEPENDENT ON THE
FOR DEPENDING ON THE EXTENT.
AND WE MUST BUILD FISCALLY
SUMMARIZING THE FULL DAY
SUPPORTS THEM. SO WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE THAT WE'RE
PREPARED TO SUPPORT THE BILL-
AND BIG AFTER. AND THANK YOU
YOUR NEXT WITNESS. TO OUR NEXT
WITNESS THANK YOU. MY NAME IS
MY MCCOURT AND I'M THE PER
SUPPORT. OF READY TO FIGHT
SCHOOL. WE SERVE VERY DIVERSE
COMMUNITY JUST OVER TWO
THOUSAND. LOCATED RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. SOME OF OUR MAJOR
DEMOCRATIC INCLUDES 75% LATIN
ACTS 13% AFRICAN AMERICAN. THE
FIFTH OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
LEARNING ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE IN APPROXIMATELY 84%
OF OUR STUDENTS PARTICIPATE IN
THE NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAM. ACCORDING TO THE
LUMINA FOUNDATION REPORT A
STRONGER NATION APPROXIMATELY
29% OF RESIDENTS IN OUR
METROPOLITAN REGION. HAVE
OBTAINED A POST SECONDARY
DEGREE AS COMPARED TO THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE OF FIFTY ONE
POINT NINE PERCENT. THIS
COUPLED WITH THE FACT THAT
NEARLY A HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE IS LEFT ON
THE TABLE AND UNCLAIMED
FINANCIAL AID FOR GRADUATING
SENIORS. SERVIDOR Y. TO MAKE
FAST WHEN CAPTAIN POLLUTION
REQUIREMENTS FOR OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT. WE KNOW THAT MANY OF
OUR SCHOLARS WILL BE FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE GOING
GRADUATES AND WE ALSO KNEW THAT
WE NEEDED TO SYSTEMATICALLY
REMOVE THE NUMBER ONE BARRIER.
TO COLLEGE ACCESS AFFORDABILITY
WE BLAZED A NEW TRAIL IN BALBOA
READY NOT FOR FAME OR ATTENTION
BUT BECAUSE WE KNEW THE
MAJORITY OF OUR STUDENTS WILL
BE ABLE TO ACCESS. GRANTS FREE
MONEY FOR COLLEGE IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE BOARD VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY. YOUR SUPPORT DROPS
WHEN KATIC CONCLUSION. PRETTY A
COLLEGE GOING CULTURE SUPPORTED
BY ALL LEVELS OF THE
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN KEY TO
OUR SUCCESS. THE WHOLE SYSTEM
FOCUS HAS PRODUCED SOME AMAZING
RESULTS OVERALL HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION RATES OF NINETY SIX
PERCENT. LARGEST INCREASE IN A
FEW KEY REASON RIVERSIDE COUNTY
TO SIXTY TWO POINT SEVEN
PERCENT. AND A COLLEGE GOING
RATE NOW 67% WITH THE NUMBER OF
CAL GRANT. SKYROCKETING
REPORTING ARE UNDOCUMENTED AND
MIXED STATUS FAMILIES HAS BEEN
A PASSION OF OURS WE PARTNER
WITH KODAK. THE GRASSROOTS
IMMIGRATION RIGHTS ORGANIZATION
TWO ARCHER ARE FAMILIES HAVE
TRUSTED INFORMATION. REGARDING
CHAPLAIN CAPTAIN POLLUTION
FINALLY. IT'S IMPORTANT NOTE
THIS ENTIRE EFFORT HAS BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED WITHIN OUR
EXISTING BUDGETS COSTING ZERO
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS. I'D INVITE
YOU TO JOIN THIS MOVEMENT WE'VE
INVESTED THIRTEEN YEARS OF
EDUCATION. TO OUR STUDENTS AND
CAL. IT HAS SET ASIDE MY
TRIMMING THE NUMBER BARRIER
HIRING. WHY DON'T WE GIVE OUR
ANOTHER FIVE MINUTES TO
COMPLETE THEIR CROPS BY TWO.
EIGHT FOUR SIXTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO UP THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WHILE WE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. FIRST OF ALL MISS
REYES I'D LIKE TO SAY I
APPRECIATE YOUR BILL APPRECIATE
THE MISSION OF YOUR BILL. WHICH
IS TO OFFER A HIGHER EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITIES TO ALL CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS I ALSO APPRECIATE. THE
COMMENTS HERE TODAY MOST OF THE
SPEAKERS THAT RECOGNIZE SOME OF
THE COMMENTS I MADE THE PAST.
AS A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER THAT'S
HOW TO IMPLEMENT A POLICY LIKE
THIS A PRACTICE LIKE THIS- IN
THE PAST. I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT AND- THE
COMMENTS BY THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND ALSO OUR EFFORT
REALLY WHICH IS. WILL
COMPLEMENT THE SEVEN I THINK IS
STREAMLINING THE WHOLE
FINANCIAL AID SEEKING PROCESS
VERY NECESSARY SO CONFUSING.
HAS BEEN CONFUSING FOR YEARS I
KNOW MR MCCARTY IS LET THAT ON
THAT EFFORT TO. AND I KNOW
YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT TOO
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON AS WELL WITH THAT
ANY OF THE OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WISH TO COMMENT MISTER
KILEY. I JUST WANT EXPRESSED MY
SUPPORT I THINK IT'S A- VERY
GOOD BILL WE HAVE THAT AS YOU
MENTIONED- YOU KNOW- TO LOWER
THE PERCENTAGE OF. STUDENTS WHO
GO THROUGH THIS AND MISS OUT ON
ON POTENTIAL OPPORTUNITIES SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I WAS
MCCARTY. YEAH I THINK YOU- YOU
KNOW WE DISCUSS THIS AS YOU
KNOW- MISTER CHAIR A LOT AND
BUDGET COMMITTEE AS WELL THIS
IS A CONCURRENT. BILL I JUST
SAY ONE OF THE- ONE OF THE MOST
DISTRESSING THINGS THAT I DO AS
CHAIR THE BUDGET FOR LAST SEVEN
YEARS AS EVERY YEAR WE GET A
DOLLAR AMOUNT OF HOW MUCH
MONEY. GOES BACK TO THE GENERAL
FUND WHICH WAS ALLOCATED FOR
CAL GRANT AND IS NOT GIVEN OUT
TO STUDENTS WHO ARE WORTHY AND
SHOULD GO BECAUSE THEY DON'T.
FILL OUT THE APPLICATION. AND
TOO MANY HIGH SCHOOL COUNSELORS
ARE DEALING WITH JUST LIFE
THEY'RE DEALING WITH. CRISIS IN
HOUSE KIDS THAT ARE HOMELESS
AND POVERTY AND EVERYTHING ELSE
I DON'T ALWAYS HAVE TIME TO BE
THAT TRADITIONAL ACADEMIC
COUNSELORS AND THE COUNSELOR
RATIOS ARE. ARE ARE REALLY WILL
FALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA. SO THIS
IS DEFINITELY NEEDED. WE HAVE
AN ENTITLEMENT THAT CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS
NOW IN CALIFORNIA THAT IF YOU
HAVE A- TWO POINT NOW AND
YOU'RE A SENIOR IN HIGH SCHOOL.
YOU APPLY YOU GET A CALTRAIN
GUARANTEED THE STATE MONEY FOR
YOU BUT IF YOU APPLY THE NEXT
YEAR. OR TWO THIRDS TWO YEARS
LATER YOUR ODDS OF GETTING IT
ARE LIKE ONE IN FIVE. SO IT'S A
NO BRAINER TO HELP STUDENTS AND
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE BEAN COUNTERS
THERE DON'T WANT THIS THEY WANT
TO USE THIS MONEY FOR ELSEWHERE
IN THE BUDGET BUT WE HAVE THIS
VISION TWENTY YEARS AGO- ARE
FIRED FORMER CENTER JABBER TCI
THINK WHO YOU KNOW VERY WELL.
AUTHORED THIS LANDMARK BILL AND
WE'RE NOT THE FILLING THE
POTENTIAL. FOR COLLEGE FOR
EVERYBODY AND NOT IT WAS GOING
TO GO TO COLLEGE BUT THEY
SHOULD AT LEAST HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SAY. NO KNOWING
THAT THEY HAVE MONEY TO PAY FOR
TUITION. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
WE NEED THE STUDENTS TO SUCCEED
NOT JUST FOR THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AND THEIR UPWARD
MOBILITY BUT FOR ECONOMY YOU
KNOW WE NEED MANY MORE COLLEGE
GRADUATES TO FILL THE JOBS OF
TODAY AND TOMORROW SO THIS IS
DESPERATE NEED FOR OUR ECONOMY.
AND SO THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING
TO PUSH US FOR THE PAST FEW
YEARS THANKS. THANK MISS CLARK
SILVA. THANK ECHO MY COLLEAGUES
ON AND- THIS DOCUMENT WITH THIS
PRESENTED TO US FROM OUR OWN.
PRETTY SHOCKING I THINK ALL OF
THIS. A LOT OF PAIN RIGHT. I AM
SEEING THAT ONE OF MY VERY HIGH
ACHIEVING- HIGH SCHOOL- THAT
STUDENTS DO EXCEPTIONALLY WELL
WHAT WE HAVE- SOMEWHERE 21%
YEAH THE APPLICATIONS ARE
NINETY PERCENT. THAT HAVE
FUNDING AND ANOTHER- ONE THAT
WAS. ENOUGH FOR MORE TO OF
COLOR SIXTY SEVEN PER STUDENTS
OF COLOR AND YET THAT. THAT
SIXTY THREE SO MORE EXPERIENCE
AND PENA- SEE THOSE
APPLICATIONS AND THAT CERTAINLY
IS ABOUT NOW- THE EDUCATION BUT
IT'S ABOUT THE WHERE. ACCESS I
WOULD BE. LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR YEAH YOU WOULD DO
THAT AND- HI. DEF SUPPORT THIS
BILL. WELL OKAY THANK YOU I'D
LOVE TO HAVE YOU AS A AUTHOR.
THANK YOU JOINT ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SAY NO OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS DID
I DON'T BELIEVE WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THIS YET. SECOND IT
COULD MOVED AND SECONDED- WILL
NOW GO TO THE PHONES FOR THOSE
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION TEN
MINUTES. TO THE MODERATOR TO
THE PHONES. IF SUPPORT
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO NOW THE WIND NUMBER FOUR
OH FOUR GO AHEAD. AND I'M SORRY
THAT ONE IS NOT ACTIVE. LINE
THREE OH THREE GO AHEAD. BLIND
THREE OH THREE. GOING TO THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ONE ONE
SIXTY SEVEN GO AHEAD. THE
DANGER CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB FOUR SIX
NINE THANK YOU SO MUCH. NINE
FOUR SEVEN GO AHEAD. MARCOS ERA
GOES THE DS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR SIX NINE THANK YOU. WINE
FOR SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SAMANTHA SANG WITH
ACTING CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT. WINE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE FORTY
SEVEN. NOW GOING TO LINE ONE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING DAVID NEVIN ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. NOW GOING TO LINE FOR
SEVENTEEN GO HEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RON RAPP-
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE FOUR
OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS BILLY AND I'M
ACTING ON BEHALF OF WHEN YOU GO
TO THE WEST COULD IT BE KNOWN
AS THE NATIONAL CONSOLE. IN
STRONG SUPPORT. ONE NINE FOUR
TWELVE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN.
FOR TWELVE. GOING ON TO LINE
FOUR OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING LOOK AT THE TOPIC
WITH THE PARENT INSTITUTE FOR
QUALITY EDUCATION OR TO GET
INSTRUCTABLE THANK YOU. NINE TO
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE TWO SIX SEVEN. GOING NOW
TO LINE FOR TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. STARLINE FOUR TUNES
NOT OPEN GOING NOW TO LINE.
THREE SIXTY FOUR. ONE THREE SIX
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. LEADING
THAT LINE GOING NEXT TO LINE
THREE FIFTY NINE GO AHEAD.
DURING THE SENATE THE
TRANSCATHETER NOW IN SUPPORT.
NOW GOING TO LINE THREE OH
THREE GO AHEAD. HI WITH THE
BUDGET CONTRACT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SEARCH ENGINE
KHALKHAL. FROM REAPING THE
BENEFITS OF FASTER THROUGH THE
GREAT BILL AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT. NINE ONE SIXTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. KLEIN WELL
READY ONE CLIENT BURKE RIDLEY
CREEK CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WINE FORTY SEVEN. GO AHEAD.
JOHNSON WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR SIXTY NINE. AND LINE
ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR ADDRESS BLESSED IN SUPPORT.
NO FRONT OF FURTHER LINES AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU WILL BRING
IT BACK- WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS THIS
RANGE YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
AND I AS REQUESTED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHARON QUIRK SILVA AND
INSTANT CARDING I WILL BE
JOINING YOU AS IT IS ADDING YOU
AS JOINT AUTHORS PER YOUR
REQUEST. THE EVIDENCE IS CLEAR
OF WHEN OUR STUDENTS FILL OUT
THE FACTS FOR DREAM ACT
APPLICATION THEY ARE 63% MORE
LIKELY TO GO TO COLLEGE AND IF
THIS IS ONE OF THE BEST
INDICATORS THAT WE CAN HAVE THE
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE THEM FILL
THAT FILL OUT THE FORM AND HAVE
IT BE A REQUIREMENT PROVIDING
THE TREATMENT THE TIME
NECESSARY- FOR THEM TO FILL IT
OUT SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR
YOUR IPHONE. GREAT US SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
AB FOUR SIX NINE THE MOTION IS
THE PASTOR APPROPRIATIONS THE
DONALD HI DONALD FIVE KILEY.
KILEY I'VE BENNETT. SENATE I
DALLI. DALLI I'D LEAVE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I WORK SILVA. RICK
SILVA I. THE BILL HAS EXPLODED
AS A TRAIN WORKING FIRST I
WOULD THAT WILL MOVE ON TO AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE IS FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN ONE SIX. BY MISS
RIVAS. YOU MAY PERCEIVE ALREADY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS I WANT TO START
BY THANKING YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF- TANYA FOR HER WERE
WORKING WITH MY OFFICE ON THIS
BILL- I ALSO WANT TO ACCEPT THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS OUTLINED
pTHE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS OF AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE IS A
WOMEN'S CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL
THIS BILL WOULD DEVELOP A
STANDARD PROCESS FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS TO IDENTIFY
THE DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS THAT
THEY IN ROLAND SERVE. THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE PROVIDERS TO
REPORT KEY INFORMATION ABOUT
DUAL LANGUAGE LEARNERS TO THE
STATE IN ORDER TO FOR FUTURE
POLICY AND PROGRAM DECISIONS TO
BE MADE. THIS BILL THE PORTENT
BECAUSE 60% OF CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA FROM BIRTH TO AGE
FIVE LIVE IN HOUSEHOLDS IN
WHICH A LANGUAGE OTHER THAN
ENGLISH IS SPOKEN. HOWEVER
THERE'S NO CONSISTENT MANNER OF
IDENTIFYING DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS IN CALIFORNIA'S EARLY
LEARNING SYSTEM. RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT ACHIEVING FLUENCY IN
MULTIPLE LANGUAGES BENEFITS
CHILDREN BY BROADENING THEIR
COGNITIVE FLEXIBILITY ENHANCING
THEIR ABILITY TO LEARN AND
GIVING STUDENTS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BECOME. BI OR MULTILINGUAL
SO THAT THEY ARE COMPETITIVE IN
THE GLOBAL WORK FORCE THE
RESEARCH ALSO TELLS US THAT.
THE CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF
UNDERSTANDING THE LEARNING AND
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT OF THE L.
L. CHILDREN TO NURTURE THE RICH
LINGUISTIC ASSETS AND TO ENSURE
SUCCESS IN SCHOOL AND IN LIFE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO IDENTIFY AND
PROVIDE INTENTIONAL SUPPORT
DESIGN FOR THE SUCCESS OF DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS WHEN THEY
ENTER PRESCHOOL- IN DECEMBER
THE GOVERNOR RELEASED THE
MASTER PLAN FOR EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE. A TEN YEAR ROAD MAP
FOR IMPROVING AND TRANSFORMING
THE STATE'S EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE SYSTEM. THE MASTER PLAN
PROVIDES A ROADMAP TO ADDRESS
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC INEQUITIES
AND CALLS FOR LEGISLATION TO
REQUIRE THE IDENTIFICATION OF
THE L. L.'S DEVELOPMENTAL
ASSESSMENTS BOTH IN ENGLISH AND
IN THE CHILDREN'S HOME
LANGUAGES AMONG OTHER THINGS.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE TAKES
THE FIRST CRITICAL STEP IN
IMPLEMENTING THE MASTER PLAN
FOR EARLY LEARNING AND CARE-
RECOMMENDATIONS SUPPORTING OUR
CHILDREN WHO ARE DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS BY FIRST IDENTIFYING
THEM. TO DATE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT I HAVE CAROLINE CROWELL
HELLO. DIRECTOR OF DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNER PROGRAMS AND
JESSICA GOOD THE ADDRESS C. S.
P. P. TEACHER. TO THE PHONES
MODERATOR GOT TWO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. WINE FOR TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING. NINE GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS CAROLYN COLLIDE AND I'M
THE DIRECTOR OF TWO A LANGUAGE
LEARNER PROGRAMS EARLY EDGE
CALIFORNIA WHERE STATEWIDE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION FOCUSED
ON IMPROVING ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING PROGRAMS
FOR CHILDREN BIRTH TO AGE EIGHT
IN CALIFORNIA. SUPPORTING OUR
TO A LANGUAGE LEARNERS THAT
SOMETHING WE CHAMPION FOR THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS BECAUSE WE
THOUGHT THIS IS A GREAT NEED
GIVEN A LARGE AND GROWING
POPULATION OF BE ALLOWED IN THE
STATE. WE WERE EXCITED TO SEE
SUCH A STRONG EMPHASIS ON
SUPPORTING GALLOP IN THE MASTER
PLAN FOR EARLY LEARNING ND
CARE. INCLUDING THE NEED TO
IDENTIFY DEVELOP ACROSS ALL
EARLY LEARNING CARE PROGRAM. WE
BELIEVE THAT BY BRINGING THE
POLITICS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE CAN BE A LEADER
IN THE NATION IN SUPPORTING AND
UPLIFTING THE ASPECTS OF OUR
DOOR LANGUAGE LEARNERS. FISHER
MORE ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF THE
POLICY ON PROVIDERS FEATURED
FAMILIES AND CHILDREN I'M GOING
TO DEFER THE REST OF MY TIME.
TO OUR OTHER WITNESS THAT'S
GOOD WITH THE ADDED. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU TOWARD
NATURAL AND- THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JESSICA
COULD GET IT I SAID I'M AN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR WITH
THE FRESNO UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE THE VOICE
OF AN EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR
IT'S REALLY A GREAT HONOR TO
JOIN YOU ALL. AND I'D LIKE TO
SHARE A LITTLE ABOUT MY WILL
HAVE AN EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATOR WHAT WILL PROVIDE
INSIGHT INTO THE PERSPECTIVE
FROM WHICH I'LL BE SPEAKING.
I'M CURRENTLY WORKING IN FRESNO
UNIFIED STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS AND FOR THE PAST SIX
YEARS I'VE BEEN A PARTICIPANT
IN THE LANGUAGE LEARNING
PROJECT WHICH SEEKS TO IMPROVE
THE PRACTICE OF THE EASY WORK
FORCE TO SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
BILL LANGUAGE LEARNERS. OUR
PROGRAM IS RECOGNIZED AS A
PROMISING NOT ONLY WITH THE
FUNDING FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AS AN EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATOR IN
CALIFORNIA I HAVE THE GREAT
FORTUNE TO THE DIVERSE GROUP OF
CHILDREN FAMILIES WHO SPEAK
MANY LANGUAGES I'MONE OF THE
MOST VALUABLE EXPERIENCES FROM
MY PARTICIPATION IN THE
LANGUAGE LEARNING PROJECT HAS
BEEN LEARNING A PROCESS WHICH
TO IDENTIFY THE BUILDING WOULD
LEARN IN MY CLASSROOM. THE
PROFIT BY USING VERY SIMILAR TO
THAT IDENTIFIED IN AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY THREE ABOUT POINT SO
GRATEFUL THAT THE BILL BEING
HEARD BY YOU ALL TODAY I USE A
TOOL CALLED THE FAMILY LANGUAGE
IS AN INTERESTING OF YOU TO
GUIDE MY CONVERSATIONS WITH
FAMILIES ABOUT THE CULTURE
LANGUAGE THAT IDENTIFIES. THE
CAR OUT OF THE DOOR LANGUAGE
LEARNER. YOU THE PLAN IF YOU'RE
TO IDENTIFY THE L. L. BECOME.
INVOLVED PART OF MY TEACHING
FOR. THE COMMERCE. ABOUT A FAIR.
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY FOR ME TO
GATHER DATA THEN IMPLEMENT
STRUCTURE. AND REALLY GUIDES
LEARNING EXPERIENCES IN MY
CLASSROOM. THE DATA GATHERED
NOT ONLY FOR MY TEACHING
PRACTICE IN THE CLASSROOM. BUT
IT ALSO INFORMS PROGRAM
DECISIONS IN ALLOCATING
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT CHILDREN
AND FAMILY. MEMBERS SO MANY
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS THAT WE AS
EDUCATORS MUST CONSIDER TO
ENSURE THAT WERE BACK. IN THE
NEEDS OF THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WE SERVE. PROPER
THOUGHT A PROCESS FOR
IDENTIFYING THE LANGUAGE
LEARNERS MAY SEEM LIKE A
BURDENSOME TASK. THAT'S BEING
ADDED TO AN ALREADY LONG LIST
OF PRIORITIES. AND HONESTLY I
HAD SIMILAR THINKING WHEN I
FIRST LEARNED ABOUT IT
AFFECTING UNIFIED. HOWEVER
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO EASILY
INTEGRATE THAT CONVERSATION AND
HARD TO THINK STRUCTURE OF
ENGAGING AND MEETING WITH
FAMILIES. I CANNOT EMPHASIZE
ENOUGH HOW INVALUABLE THE
PROCESS OF BECOMING MY TEACHING
PRACTICE. AS EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATORS WE HAVE THE GREAT
HONOR AND RESPONSIBILITY OF
SERVING OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS.
BUT HOW CAN WE ENSURE THAT
WE'RE MEETING THE NEEDS IF WE
CAN IDENTIFY WHAT THOSE NEEDS.
ARE DEALING WOODLAND
IDENTIFICATION IS A CRITICAL
STEP IN PLANNING LEARNING
EXPERIENCES AND INSTRUCTION AND
THOUGHT THAT THE EXTRA ITEMS.
BUT HE JUST HAD TO OUR TO DO
LIST. BUT THEN IN A ROW PLEASE
SUMMARIZE FAMILIES. BELIEVE OF
THE CHILDREN WE SERVE. AN
DINNER TO DEATH A DEEPER.
INTENTIONALITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THE WE HAVE ONE MORE
WITNESS NOT ONE WITNESS HAVE.
NOW THAT THAT IS BOTH KIND OF
TO OKAY I APOLOGIZE. BOB WITH
THAT OF AND I WE NO OFF. WILL
WILL IT BACK COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS MANY THE CAN MEMBERS.
AFTER ONE AS A- VERY YEARS IN-
IN AN AREA WHERE OF WHERE
THERE'S A LOT OF ENGLISH
LEARNERS- SOMETHING LIKE THIS
IS VERY IMPORTANT TO HELP
IDENTIFY KIDS AND SUPPORT THEM.
IN BECOMING DUAL LANGUAGE.
LEARNERS GOING FORWARD SO WITH
THAT THANK YOU- THAT'S BEEN
MOVED ALL. OF I'M SORRY IF I IF
I COULD I'D JUST LIKE TO POINT
OUT WITH- WITH DUAL LANGUAGE
LEARNERS IN OUR HOUSE- STARTED
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO I SAW LOTS OF
CONFUSION- AS THEY WORK THEIR
WAY THROUGH THE PROCESS WAS
WHETHER THEY WERE. DUAL
LANGUAGE LEARNERS ARE NOT AND
SO I THINK IT'S REALLY VALUABLE
TO HAVE THIS PROGRAM THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WOULD HAVE MOVED TO
RECOMMENDED ACTION. THE MOVE BY
MR BENNETT. SECOND I MISS SILVA.
SINGLE COMMENT FURTHER COMMENT
FROM THE COMMITTEE- WE WILL- GO
TO THE PHONES. SPORT
OPPOSITION'S TEN MINUTES. THANK
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR ANY SUPPORT THEIR
OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO TO A
LINE OF ONE OH ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SEIU- ON BEHALF OF TPP YOUR
COLLABORATION YOU W. IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU EXTRA GOAL
LINE. AFTER SIGNING CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF
THE BILL AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA GOAL LINE OF. THREE FIFTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MORNING
TRANSPORTATION WITH CHILDREN
NOW- IN IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
TEXCOCO LINE OF THE TWO SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
IT'S A GREAT CHANCE FOR LA ONE
INTERNATIONAL MASSRESISTANCE-
APPROACH THAT HAS BEEN A TRAGIC
TO AMERICAN. THANK YOU. THE
NEXT TO GO TO LINE UP. FOUR
THIRTY. FOUR THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN FOR
THIRTY. OKAY NEAR ME YES GO
AHEAD HELLO MY NAME THE MIRACLE
COMPANION FROM VETERAN PARTY
TELEPHONE WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF
THE BILL WE AREN'T STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU WILL BRING IT
BACK- IT'S BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU IRESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. SACRIFICIAL THE ROLE. AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY THREE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL I
DON'T KNOW I. KILEY. KILEY I'D
BENNETT. BENNETT I DALLY. DALLY
I LEAVE MCCARTY. I THINK
MCCARTY I QUICK SILVA. THE
CLERKS OF I. THINK THE BILLS
OUT THANK YOU. WELL NOW MOVED
AB TWENTY TWO OH THIS IS THE
SUPER FOR MISTER MCCARTY PAIRS
THE HOLY GRAIL. EARLY EDUCATION-
IT'S AB TWENTY TWO MR MCCARTY
THAT'S BY LAW I MISS MCCARTY
THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBERS TO
SEVEN. YEAH WELL MOST
IMPORTANTLY HOPE IT'S A LOT
FASTER BECAUSE WE WORKED- OF
THE LAST FEW. WEEKS WITH YOUR
STAFF AND YOUR TEAM THAT NO
SHE'S NOT HERE BUT I WANT TO
THANK DEBBIE LUCK YOUR
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT WHO WORKED
ON THIS AND ROAD OUTSTANDING
ANALYSIS OF THE ISSUE. AND OUT
OF THE GATE WE WILL UPSET WE
WILL ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS SOME CLARIFICATIONS
THAT WE WANNA MAKE SURE WE- AT
HERE TOO SO- THIS OF COURSE IS
AB TWENTY TWO. A UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
YOU'LL GIVE EVERY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA ACCESS TO THE FULL.
YEAR OF HIGH QUALITY FULL DAY
PRESCHOOL AT NO COST TO THEIR
FAMILIES BY EXPANDING UNIVERSAL
TEEKAY THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AS WE NOW WE HAVE A TEN YEAR
PILOT PROJECT IN CALIFORNIA
WITH T. K. SO FOR FAMILIES ARE
LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE A CHILD
BORN IN THE FALL. THEY HAVE A
FREE YEAR OF PUBLICLY FUNDED
EARLY EDUCATION BUT AS WE'VE
SEEN THE LAST TEN YEARS PARENTS
AT THE SOCCER FIELD ARE ASKING
AROUND LIKE HOW DID YOU GET
FREE PRE K. WHAT DO YOU MEAN-
HOUSE BUT YOUR BABY WAS BORN
IN. IN OCTOBER OR SEPTEMBER
NOVEMBER SELL AT IT IS THIS
REALLY ADDRESSES THAT INEQUITY
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IT COULD
EXPAND ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY
EARLY AT THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WE KNOW THAT ECP MATTERS- HIGH
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES IMPROVE SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT SCHOOL
READINESS AND A LONG TERM
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT OUR
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT T. K.
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVES
KINDERGARTEN READINESS. PUTTING
CHILDREN AHEAD OF THEIR NON TKT
PIERCED BY UP TO SIX MONTHS IN
SOME ACADEMIC SKILLS MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE THINK WE CAN
HELP HERE IN CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME STUDENTS- DIVERSE
STUDENTS ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS BENEFIT THE MOST FROM
TEEKAY ACCORDING TO RESEARCH
MAKE IT MAKING UNIVERSAL T. K.
A POWERFUL STRATEGY IN
NARROWING. THE OPPORTUNITY AND
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS IN OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM WHICH IS. OUR
LINGERING ISSUE WERE TRYING TO
A DRESS BY THIS BILL OFF IMPLY
THAT'S JUST QUALITY
IMPROVEMENTS INCLUDING.
DEVELOPMENTALLY APPROPRIATE
CURRICULUM AND STAFFING RATIOS
SO THAT EDUCATORS CAN
MEANINGFUL MEANINGFULLY
INTERACT WITH THE CHILD WE'LL
MAKE SURE WE HAVE RATIOS THAT
ARE APPROPRIATE ME NOW- YOU
KNOW MR DONAHUE TALK A LOT
ABOUT YOUR EXPERIENCE AS A
TEACHER AND HAVING A T. K.
TEACHER WITH TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
KIDS THAT DOESN'T QUITE WORK.
AS IT WILL BE A DISASTER FOR
THE TEACHER AND THE KIDS SO IN
HERE WE HAVE APPROPRIATE
RATIOS. MORE IMPORTANTLY WE
KNOW THAT BY JUST MOVING ALL
FOUR YEAR OLDS IN THE T. K.
WITHOUT ANYTHING ELSE WOULD BE
A DISASTER FOR THE PROGRAM
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE'VE
HEARD THEM LOUD AND CLEAR.
WE'RE GONNA THERE'S NO OFFICIAL
OPPOSITION BUT THERE'S PEOPLE
THAT ARE CONCERNED WE'RE GONNA
HEAR FROM THEM I'M SURE
WITNESSES LATER. OTHERS A
COMPANION BILL IN THE SENATE
AUTHORED BY CENTRALLY MON WHICH
WOULD STATE THAT OF THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
FUNDING THAT CURRENTLY GOES TO
SERVE FOUR YEAR OLDS IN THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM. WE
WOULD USE THOSE MONIES TO SERVE
MARK ZERO THREE THREE YEAR OLDS
SO- THOSE PROGRAMS COULD SERVE
MORE INFANTS AND TODDLERS
WHAT'S YOURS THERE GREATER
NEED. AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
THINK ABOUT THE KIDS WHO WHO
NEED EARLY EDUCATION NOW THESE
LOW INCOME KIDS WOULD HAVE ONE
YEAR. OF FREE PRE K. THROUGH
THE TICKET PROGRAM AND THEY CAN
OTHER YEAR OF STATE PRESCHOOL
IN THE THREE SO TWO YEARS OF
QUALITY EASY EATING. WILL
REALLY ADDRESS ARE CHEAP AN
OPPORTUNITY. GAP ISSUES- K.
NEEDS THIS WE NEED THE SHOT IN
THE ARM TO MAKE SURE WE PREPARE
OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS- AB
TWENTY TWO ISN'T THE ENTIRE
SOLUTION BT IMPORTANT PIECE OF
THE PUZZLE- THE GOVERNOR HAS
EMBRACE THIS BY PUTTING ONE
TIME IN THE BUDGET. TO
JUMPSTART IMPLEMENTATION OF
TEEKAY THIS WOULD FURTHER THIS
EFFORT. AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE TODAY WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING FROM- EDUCATOR'S SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND COMMUNITY GROUPS
I ONE LAST THING TO WE KNOW WE
HAVE TO CLIMBING ENROLLMENTS.
ACROSS CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS SO
THIS WOULD HELP SOME OF THOSE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH DECLINING
ENROLLMENT TO GET MORE EIGHTY
EIGHT. IN THEIR IN THEIR IN
THEIR- SCHOOL SYSTEM. AND
LASTLY ONE THE BIG PIECES FAR
AS FUNDING THIS WEEK JUST TO
SAY IT OUT RIGHT- THERE WAS
WHEN WE STARTED THIS BILL IT
WOULD HAVE FUNDED T. K. THROUGH
THE EXISTING ALLOTMENT. UNDER
THAT TO THE TEST ONE PROP
NINETY EIGHT. WE THINK THERE IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO BEYOND
THAT AND PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING- FOR EACH ADDITIONAL
STUDENT WHO COMES IN THE T. K.
KIND OF FRAMEWORK HERE- WILL BE
WORKING WITH THAT CAN CURRENTLY
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS. I
WOULD THAT I HAVE TO- SPEAKERS
ON THE PHONE TO SUPPORT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. FIVE THANK
YOU MET MISTER MCCARTY VOTERS
WITNESSES- FIRST IS- THE SHALL
CONSIDER. MICHELLE KESSLER FROM
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION ON THE PHONE TO THE
MODERATOR WE'RE GOING TO THE
PHONES AND SUPPORT WITNESSES
PLACED. THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS MICHELLE KEPLINGER I
AM A MEMBER OF THE CSA BOARD OF
DIRECTORS. AND HAVE BEEN A
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEE FOR
MILPITAS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT FOR TWENTY ONE YEARS.
HE IS A CO SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY
THREE THAT WE BELIEVE IN
UNIVERSAL TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN. THROUGH THE
DIFFERENT THE NEXT YEAR OF
KINDERGARTEN MAKES AN ACADEMIC
SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS. WHAT
ABOUT THIS MY TESTIMONY TODAY
ON ADDRESSING SOME WORKFORCE
CONCERNS WE REPRESENT PRESCHOOL
AND HEAD START TEACHERS AND
EDUCATORS AS WELL AS MEMBERS
AND TAKING KINDERGARTEN. ONE OF
THE CONCERNS WE'VE HEARD IS
THAT UNIVERSAL T. K. WILL CROWD
OUT EXISTING PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS. WE DO NOT BELIEVE
UNIVERSAL HE K. WILL CROWD OUT
EXISTING PROGRAMS OR DISPLAYS
ARE MEMBERS INCREASE ONE HEAD
START THERE'S SO MANY ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN ZERO TO THREE. WHO CAN
BE AND WILL BE THIRD BY
CRIPPLING HEADSTART WHEN FOUR
YEAR OLD ARE BEING SERVED BY T.
K. THERE IS NO SHORTAGE OF
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS. WHICH MEANS
THERE'S PLENTY OF IMPORTANT
WORK FOR OUR MEMBERS TO DO IN
FACT MY DISTRICT HAS A WAITING
LIST FOR PRESCHOOL MISTER AS-
DARK PROGRAM. AB TWENTY TWO IS
GOING TO PROVIDE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR YOUNG
STUDENTS- FOR MEMBERS OF THE
FIFTIETH LOW RATIO WILL BENEFIT
INDIVIDUAL WHO NEEDS. AND
REQUIRE THE ASSISTANCE OF CARE
EDUCATORS COMMITTEE K.
CLASSROOMS. THIS WILL ADD
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
EXPERIENCED EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATORS TO MOVING FIFTY KA
CLASSROOMS IF THEY CHOOSE. OR
THEY CAN CHOOSE THE SAME
FREEFORM HAS START PROGRAM.
EXPANDING TO GAVE ONLY GOING TO
BE AN OPPORTUNITY. WE NOT ONLY
SUPPORTER MEMBERS IN THEIR JOBS
BUT WE ALSO SUPPORT STUDENTS
OPPORTUNITIES AND STAFF
ADVANCEMENT OPPORTUNITIES THAT
IMPROVE THE LIVELIHOODS OF OUR
MEMBERS. AS MENTIONED I HAVE
WORKED IN PUBLIC EDUCATION FOR
MANY YEARS AND THE TEACHER
SHORTAGES WILL PREPARE EDUCATOR
SHORTAGE IS REAL BUT THE WORK
IS STILL HERE. AND THERE I AM
VERY IMPORTANT THIS IMPORTANT
WORK STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE OUR
MEMBERS. ARE THERE TO FOSTER
AND SUPPORT AS YOUR- UNDER
ACADEMIC. WITH THE K. UP.
COMPONENT IN THE EARLY. I
ASPECTS DOT. SUPPORT BY IN
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU OUR NEXT WITNESS MORE FROM
KATANGA. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MY NAME IS SCOTT
MORE ORGANIZED CUTTING DOWN ONE
OF. BAR CHILD AND PRESCHOOL.
AND BECAUSE OF AB TWO.
UNIVERSAL AND POWER BECKLEY BY
INCOME CHILDREN CAL ARE WITH
LIKE TO ATTACK CRITICAL ONLY
ONE IN OF CAN TO KEEP. OKAY ALL
YEAR OLD IS THE KEY STEP TOWARD
BACK. BUT IT'S NOT ENOUGH A TEN
ONE YOU'RE PICKING NOT GONNA UP
FOR YOUR OF INACTION HELLO
GETTING DOWN TO FACTOR SHOWED
AT THE- CAPTIVES BEFORE
CHILDREN WALK THROUGH THAT
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOM DOOR.
AND ONCE CHILDREN START SCHOOL
A BIG TO STIR OF THE PROBLEMS
AND THE MOST OF. SO BOTH HAPPEN
BEFORE STARTS CLEARLY COULD
KEEP. WE'VE GOT TO DO MORE
EARLIER. THAT COULD BE OF AB
TWENTY TWO. IT WILL ALSO BE.
THE MORE INCOME BABIES AND
THREE YEAR OLD TO GETTING THE
PRESCHOOL CHILD THEY NEED AND
DESERVE HERE'S HOW. ABOUT HALF
OF LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR OLD
EARTH SERVED IN EITHER STATE
PRESCHOOL OR HEAD START. IF
THOSE CHILDREN'S PARENTS TO
DEFEND IN THE KEY PAD IN AB
TWENTY TO PROTECT PARENTS
SHOWING. UP AT THE POT FOR A
THREE YEAR OLD AN INFANT OR
TODDLER. PRINTED TICKET BANGO
BOB HALF THE CHILDREN WE SERVE
OUR FOUR YEARS OLD. THE OTHER
HALF ARE YOUNGER SO WHAT WE DO
ARE FORTUNATE PK. WE WILL
SIMPLY SERVE THEM A YEAR
EARLIER WE WILL SERVE THEM AT
THREE YEAR- ORANGE LINE PARK
PARK. BOB SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU I BELIEVE WE
HAVE NO WITNESSES AN OP. WHO
OPPOSE RAMOS MCCARTY- ANY
COMMENTS OR THE COMMITTEE
OTHERS ONE. I THANK YOU FOR THE
THANK YOU WORKING MY CAN- IN.
THE GREATER CAN MAKE SURE THAT
YOU IS FOR. SOME OF THEM.
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
JUST DON'T ADD STUDENTS TO AN
EXISTING BUCKET OF MONEY BUT
THAT WE ACTUALLY ADD MONEY. AS
WELL AS STUDENTS TO THAT BUCKET
WITH THAT- MISTER MISTER
BENNETT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
BUT OBVIOUSLY I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE PATIENCE THE
THAT THE AUTHOR HAS HAS SHOWN
FOR THIS AND THE TENACITY TO
STAY WITH US FOR SO MANY YEARS-
YOU. HAVE ASK ME EARLIER TO ADD
ON AS A AS A- CO AUTHOR AND-
I'D LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT- THIS
AND- MAKE THE MOTION TO-
HOWEVER WE'VE ALREADY MADE A
MOTION I BELIEVE TWO. OF THE
BILL THANK. GREAT THANK YOU.
DID WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
THAT NO WE DID NOT SO THAT IS A
MOTION BOTH MISS CORK CIVIL
SECOND- DID YOU WISH TO
COMMENT. OCCASION NO COMMENTS
SPELLING. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HARD WORK ON THIS BILL AND AS A
PARENT OF A CHILD BORN IN
OCTOBER. WE DID HAVE- THE TIKI
EXPERIENCE WHICH WAS INCREDIBLE
SO I'D ALSO LIKE TO CO AUTHOR
IF YOU. ACCEPT ME. I SEE NO
FURTHER COMMENT FROM THE
COMMITTEE- WE WILL GO TO THE
PHONES IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TEN MINUTES. THE
MODERATOR NOW TO THE PHONES. IF
YOU ARE A PART OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
WE'LL GO TO LINE FOR FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS
DAVE THAT'S BEEN WITH
CALIFORNIANS FOR QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING SUPPORTING ELEVEN
THOUSAND CHILD CARES WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE POTENTIAL BILL.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONE IS
SIX FEET SEVEN. YEAH BUT WHAT
GROUP CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL CONVENTION WORKERS
COMP FOR CAPITA INFRASTRUCTURE
QUARTER AB TWENTY TWO THANK YOU
THE OFFICE. THIS IS. A. ONE
MOMENT- NEXT OPPONENT OR NINETY
THREE LINE IS- OPEN. HELLO THE
CONTENT GARAGE WITH THE BEING A
UNIFIED SCHOOL A CO AN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXA VA THREE
ALL THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS A CONTRACT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA'S BUDGET YOU MISTER
COUNCIL THE PROUD SUPPORTER- OF
THIS BILL AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION EXPANDING ACCESS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO ONE
OF FOUR FIFTY INE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JENNIFER
CRAPPIE WITH PARENT VOICES
CALIFORNIA AND WE REPRESENT
THOUSANDS OF PARENTS ACROSS THE
STATE AND WE UNFORTUNATELY HAVE
TO OPPOSE THEIR SPELL AFTER
SPEAKING TO THE- THANK YOU
EXADATA LINE OF FOUR FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
IT'S CARE NUMBERS CHRISTY FROM
BACK IT HAPPENS TO
PARTICIPATION WITH THE SUPPORT
AND THEN THE GOVERNOR'S BEEN
COMMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. Q. OVER
THE NEXT LOCAL LINE UP OF FOUR
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS COURTNEY MCKENNA
WITH INFORM PARENTS OF POTTER
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THAT COMMITTEE CHAIRED BY ONE
THING THAT. YOU WERE GOING
EXCEPT FOR SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- HI DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS THAT HAD
THAT CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
TWO THOUSAND PROGRAM SITE
SERVING ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. AND THAT
WERE LINE ABOUT FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
PUTTING HER ON BEHALF OF THE
EARLY EDGE CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB TWENTY
TWO IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE UP FOR SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HARPER
JONES IN A MESSAGE SACRAMENTO
CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
REPRESENTATIVE OF ATOMIC
COLLECTED STRONG SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU NEXT TO
THE LINE OF FOUR THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING JESSICA GOT
OUT WITH THE CHILD CARE
ALLIANCE OF LOS ANGELES- IN
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED TO
REMOTE SECTION SIX SUBDIVISION
J. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NEXAVAR LINE OF FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER TURNER'S
PAMELA AGAINST REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. AB TWENTY TWO WILL
SEVERELY IMPACT HAS SPARKED A
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM A FUNDING
INCLUDING FEDERAL FUNDING AND
THE VIABILITY OF THE PROGRAM
SERVING FOUR YEAR OLD WE WISH
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND THE
COMMITTEE ON THE ISSUE THANK
YOU. SPECTACLE LINE OF- NINE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
MY NAME IS DOOR TO DOOR I AM
WITH OLD BIOLOGICAL LIFE BY
THAT PROGRAM AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO AB TWENTY
TWO CURRENTLY WRITTEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THREE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
KARINA RIGHT AWAY THE CHILD
CARE LAWCENTER IT WILL REDUCE
THE BACK EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATORS PROVIDING PARENTS AND
WE OPPOSE AB TWENTY YEAH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU IN MEXICO LINE
OF FIFTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS BETSY NAKHTMIN
AFFILIATED WITH THE EAST BAY
DIRECTORS GROUP I'M A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT PRESCHOOL DIRECTOR
WHO CLOSED MY SIXTY FIVE YEAR
OLD SCHOOL LARGELY BECAUSE OF
THE DEARTH OF SUPPORT HEARING
THAT ARE YOU ARE YOU. POSITION
JUST MOVE ON MODERATOR. ONE
SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS LEFT HENDERSON- I
WAS A CHILD CARE PROVIDER ON
THE DIRECTOR ABOUT POINT
WESLEYAN PRESCHOOL IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY- AS AN ADVOCATE I'M
CURRENTLY SITTING ON A MEMBER
OF THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY CHILD
CARE AND DEVELOPMENT PLANNING
COUNCIL AND AS AN EDUCATOR I TO
POSSESS AN ACTIVE CALIFORNIA
MULTIPLE SUBJECT TEACHING
CREDENTIAL. AND I OPPOSE AB
TWENTY TWO UNLESS THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE OF. ONE FORTY TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU JEFF BARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE UP ONE
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MEDINA BORN REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA DIVISION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF A TO TEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS VALERIE DINERO REPRESENTING
EVERY TELL CALIFORNIA WE
CURRENTLY. AB TRUMPCARE WE-
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE A TWO SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE TWO SIX
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS WHERE THE KIDS WERE
ELEMENT THAT YOU HAVE TO
REGISTER AND- I WOULD POST. IT
BACK. THANK YOU CONNECT WITH A
LINE OF FOUR THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI CAROL CARTER-
ADJUNCT FACULTY AT LOTS OF
DONALD COLLEGE AND DIRECTOR OF
JOYFUL BEGINNING TO RECALL I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO A
THREATEN. THANK YOU AND MEXICO
LINE OF FOUR FOUR TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHAT GOOD MORNING THIS
IS OVER THE FINAL WITH LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
WE ARE OF SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND NEXT TO LOCAL LINE OF FOUR
FOUR FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TOMARON FOR THE CALIFORNIA WILL
TURN. OKAY ONE MOMENT I'LL GET
YOU BACK. SO FAR ACCORDING FIVE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING JASON
FROM AROUND THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE AB TWENTY
TWO ON THE BILL AS AMENDED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE ED
MEXICO TO ALIGN FOR FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS ANGELA FACT I'M A
MOTHER IN MEMBER ANNA AREA AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB. TWENTY
TWO. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
OF FOUR FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS APRIL
MACKLIN OF TINY SCHOLARS
ACADEMY A COOPERATING I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU NEXT TO THE LINE UP
FOR FIFTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS STACY HEMINGWAY A C.
S. P. P. TEACHER AT ALCOTT
ELEMENTARY CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
NEXT RECALL LINE OF. FOUR SIXTY
THREE. THREE NINE FOUR SIX
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE UP FOR
SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
CHINA BILLS REPRESENTINGTHE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS WITH NO
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT AGREE
WITH THE SPIRIT OF THE BILL ON
THE FLOOR TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH DOCTORS OFFICES CONTACT
THANK YOU. THANK IN OCTOBER
LINE OF FOUR SIXTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CREDENTIAL
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER DANIEL
MACKINNON WHO IS IN FACT
TEACHING KINDERGARTNERS RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU AN EXTRA LINE OF
FOUR SIXTY NINE. THIS IS SOO
BRESSAN AT STEP ONE SCHOOL IN
BERKELEY- FORTY YEAR PROVIDER
AND GRANDMOTHER OF A FIVE YEAR
OLD I AM STRONGLY- IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL UNLESS
AMENDED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AN ACT OF A LINE OF FOUR
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THIS IS AT SMITH. HEAD OF
SCHOOL AT DIABLO VALLEY
MONTESSORI SCHOOL IN LAFAYETTE
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY
TWO. THANK YOU ANEXO GOAL LINE
UP FOR SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS MELINDA
FOR THE L. I AM THE OWNER AND
DIRECTOR OF ADVENTURES IN
LEARNING CHILD CARE CENTERS IN
ORANGE COUNTY AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE UP FOR EIGHTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MICHELLE WHAT HELL MOTHER OF
THAT G. K. FOUR STUDENT AT
VALENCIA PARK ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
IN SAN DIEGO AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. EXTRA LINE OF FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS LINDA HARA NUMBER
EIGHTY YOU KNOW COUNTY MOTHER
AND SMALL BUSINESS OWNER AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB TWENTY TWO.
THANK YOU AN EXTRA GOAL LINE OF
FOUR EIGHTY EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JAMES BOND
YOUR DIRECTOR OF A PRIVATE
NONPROFIT PRESCHOOL IN BUSINESS
FOR THIRTY YEARS AND I OPPOSE.
AB TWENTY TWO UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU MODERATOR ONE MORE
CALL THANK. THANK YOU WE HAVE
LINE FOR EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FOUR EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THANK YOU
HER OVER THAT- CHAIR OF THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD STUDIES
DEPARTMENT AT CAL POLY POMONA
AND KALITA PETE'S AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE MAXIMUM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE- THERE HAS BEEN A
MOTION THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS MR
MCCARTY MAKE CLOSE. I WANTED TO
ASK REAL QUICK QUESTION.
CONSCIOUS OF IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS THE- OPPOSITION BECAUSE-
IT WAS QUITE A BIT CAN I JUST
SHARE ONE THING. THERE I HEARD
OPPOSITION BUT I'VE NEVER HEARD
Y. YES THAT FIFTH. NO NO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION YET
PEOPLE CAME ON AND SAID THEY
WERE OPPOSED A LOT DO THAT
QUOTE YES YEAH BUT I DON'T
THINK THERE WAS NO REASON SO I
DON'T KNOW THE MISTER MCCARTY
SHOULD BE MAKING THEM UP AT
ALL. I LET HIM YEAH I THOUGHT I
WILL ALL ALL ADDRESS WE DID
RECEIVE A LETTER OF CONCERN
LAST NIGHT WHICH TURNED INTO A
LETTER O OPPOSITION TODAY AND
IT SUB OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING TO DO THE CHANGE I JUST
WANNA DRESS KIND OF THE BIG
ISSUE. IS THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA DO
TREMENDOUS JOB SERVING FOUR
YEAR OLDS AND CHANGE OF HEART I
THINK PEOPLE ARE SCARED WHAT
WHAT HAPPENED AND IF WE DID
THIS BILL BY ITSELF WITHOUT THE
LIMóN COMPANION BILL IT WOULD
BE A PROBLEM BUT AS ART WITNESS
SAID EARLIER FROM CONTANGO.
HALF ITS POPULATION IS SERVING
FOUR YEAR OLDS AND OF THIS BILL
WENT THROUGH WHAT HE WOULD DO
BY DEFINITION THERE ARE JUST AS
MANY THREE YEAR OLDS AS THERE
ARE FOR GIRLS AND THERE ARE.
THAT YOU KNOW TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR OLD WHO
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO STATE
PRESCHOOL RIGHT NOW SO WHAT
THAT GOAL HERE BECAUSE WE WOULD
SERVE MORE THREE YEAR OLDS AND
EVEN MORE WE'D GO DOWN AND
SERVE LOWER FOR ZERO. THREE
THREE SO SOME OF THESE
PROVIDERS THEY WANT US TO NOT-
TELL THEM BUT SHOW THEM AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH THAT WORKED
WORK THREATENING STRENGTHENING
THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL AND
OUR COMPANION BILL- YOU KNOW WE
THINK THAT THE OTHER ISSUE TOO
IS THAT HEAD START PROGRAMS-
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SECOND
PRESENT VEITNER TALKING ABOUT
SERVING MORE KIDS THREE ZERO
THREE THREE IN HEAD START. SO
YOU KNOW THERE'S THAT THERE'S A
MAGIC SWEET SPOTS ON THESE
PROGRAMS THINK THAT FOUR YEAR
OLDS REALLY ARE THAT ECONOMIC
TOOL THAT MAKES THEM
FINANCIALLY VIABLE. BUT WHAT
ARE WE DOING THIS. FOR THE
PROGRAMS- FOR CAN. I WOULD
ARGUE WERE DOING THIS FOR QUE
AND FAMILIES AND- WE'RE MAKE%
SURE THEY WE HAVE FOR THE WRAP
OF THE- DEVELOPMENT APPROPRIATE
CURRICULUM. AND THERE ARE SOME
PRIVATE- PROGRAMS THAT DON'T
GET ANY STATE SUBSIDIES THAT
WORRY THAT STUDENTS. LIKE YOU
KNOW THE DOLLY FAMILY TWENTY
YEARS AGO WILL TAKE THE FREE.
PUBLICLY FUNDED SCHOOL AND NOT
PAY. FOR A. T. K. WELL IT'S
STILL VOLUNTARY IT'S NOT WE'RE
NOT FORCING FAMILIES TO GO TO
T. K. IF THEY STILL WANT TO
PAY. TO GO TO A PRIVATE
PROGRAM. THAT'S THEIR CHOICE
THAT STILL AVAILABLE BUT WE'RE
TRYING TO LOOK WHAT'S IN THE
BEST INTEREST. AT KIDS AND
FAMILIES AND AGAIN FOR OUR FOR
OUR PROGRAMS THAT HAD STATE
SUBSIDIES IT SIR FOUR YEAR
OLDS. WE HEAR YOU WERE WORKING
WITH YOU AND WILL CONTINUE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE- HAVE YOU BE
ABLE TO THRIVE AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY HELP KIDS AND
FAMILIES THRIVE BY GETTING. A
YEAR OF PUBLICLY FUNDED TEEKAY
AND- HELP YOU SERVE MORE ZERO
THREE THREE YEAR OLDS- THANK
YOU FAMILY MEMBER FOR THE
QUESTION. I THANK YOU SO
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND A
SECOND. ARE YOU MAY CLOSE MAYBE
THAT WAS YOUR CLOTHES I DON'T
KNOW MUCH MCCARTY BUT YEAH I
JUST WANTED TO ADDRESS THA
ISSUE AND WE'RE WORKING WITH
THAT SOME OTHER CONCERNS I KNOW
SOME LABOR GROUPS HAVE ASKED
HOW THIS DEALS WITH. THE WORK
FORCE AND WE FEEL THAT THERE
ARE AS OUR SPEAKER SAID EARLIER
THERE IS A PATH THAT CURRENT
WORKERS IN PRE K. THEY HAVE
THREE CHOICES THEY COULD STAY
AND SERVE MORE THREE YEAR OLDS-
ZERO THREE THREE YEAR OLDS.
THEY CAN BECOME A PART
PROFESSIONAL AT A PUBLIC SCHOOL
SITE AND FRANKLY GET A INCREASE
IN COMPENSATION OR THEY CAN
STEP IT UP WITH THE MONEY WE'RE
PUTTING IN THE BUDGET. AND GET
A CREDENTIAL AND BECOME A T. K.
TEACHER BECOME OCCUR LICENSE
CREDENTIAL TEACHERS SO THERE
ARE THREE PASSED FOR EDUCATORS
I JUST THE BIG PICTURE IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES OF THE DAY THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
CALIFORNIA. THE EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITY AND SHIPMENT GAP-
INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY AND
FRANKLY CREEK CRIME ISSUES IN
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE
EVERY ECONOMIST NOBLE LAUREATES
INSTEAD OF IS ONE THING THAT
YOU CAN DO. TO ADDRESS THESE
BIG ISSUES OF TE DAY IT'S MORE
EARLY EDUCATION AND A ROBUST
YOU SEE OP SYSTEM OUT SO WE'RE
DOING WITH AB TWENTY TWO ALONG
WITH OTHER MEASURES AND OUR
BUDGET APPROPRIATION SO WITH
THAT. ASKEY RIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CARTER JUST
PIGGYBACK ON YOUR STATEMENT
THERE AS ONE OF TAUGHT MIDDLE
SCHOOL AND I WENT TO A K. EIGHT
SCHOOL WHERE I TAUGHT MIDDLE
SCHOOL- I WOULD HEAR THE
KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS. RIGHT
ESPECIALLY THE BEGINNING HERE
THEY COULD REALLY TELL- THROUGH
A GOOD FOR OF THE- OF NOT THE
ENTIRE WHO INVENTED EARLY
EDUCATION. IN THE KINDERGARTEN
CLASS AND WHO HADN'T. AS WHAT
YOU'RE DOING HERE IS CREATING
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN. SO I APPRECIATE THAT I
THINK CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE WILL
APPRECIATE THAT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB TWENTY TWO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS O'DONNELL. HI
DONNA HI KYLIE. KILEY AYE
BENNETT AYE BENNETT AYE DALY.
DALY I'D LI. LI I MCCARTY BY
MCCARTY AYE CORK SILVA.
QUICKSILVER I SEVEN BOTH THE
BILL CERVANTES OUT THANK YOU
GRADUATION HAS MCCARTY WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO- AB SEVENTY FIVE BY
O'DONNELL. FINAL TURNOVER
MISTER KILEY. AND- I DON'T KNOW
ARE YOU. HELLO GRANTED TRAVELER
THIS IS. OKAY. THANK YOU. I
WILL NOT BE A PROBLEM LIKE.
THIS IS AB SEVENTY FIVE DONALD
HE MAY PROCEED ON READY. THANK
YOU A THANK YOU I AM I CORRECT
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
AB SEVENTY FIVE PLACES A
KINDERGARTEN COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SCHOOL FACILITIES BOND ON THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO BALLOT. THE
SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAM IS A
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM THAT
IS BASED ON A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE STATE. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND DEVELOPERS. STATE
BOND FUNDS HAVE BEEN MATCHED BY
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN LOCAL
BONDS AND DEVELOPER FEES.
TOGETHER THESE FUNDS TO BUILD
NEW SCHOOLS MODERNIZE AGING
FACILITIES TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE SAFE AND UPDATED. AND
SUPPORTED VOCATIONAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS. THESE FUNDS ALSO HELP
THE ECONOMY BY GENERATING TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS. THE FUNDS
FOR THE LAST BOND APPROVED BY
VOTERS. OPPOSITION FIFTY ONE
FROM TWENTY SIXTEEN ARE ALREADY
DEPLETED ON THE K. TWELVE SIDE
ABOUT TWO BILLION APPLICATIONS
HAVE BEEN SUBMITTED BEYOND
AVAILABLE FUNDING THE NEED IS
GREAT IN FACT THE AVERAGE AGE
OF A SCHOOL FACILITY IN
CALIFORNIA. I BELIEVE IS AROUND
SIXTY FIVE YEARS OLD. WE ALL
KNOW FACILITIES MATTER IN
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AND STUDENT
MOTIVATION I THINK SCHOOL
FACILITIES SET THE TONE FOR THE
SCHOOL DAY. WHEN A STUDENT
WALKS ONTO A CLEAN AND
APPROPRIATE SCHOOL FACILITY
AGAIN IT SETS THE TONE FOR THE
SCHOOL DAY. IN ADDITION TO THE
BASIC PROGRAMS NEW CONSTRUCTION
MODERNIZATION CT AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS THIS BILL ADDRESSES
MORE RECENT NEEDS INCLUDING
DISASTER ASSISTANCE. TESTING
AND REMEDIATION OF LEAD IN
WATER REPLACEMENT OF SEVENTY
FIVE YEAR OLD BUILDINGS AND-
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ASSISTANCE. THE BILL ALSO
EXPANDS THE USE OF BOND FUNDS
TO INCLUDE TECHNOLOGY REQUIRED
TO ENSURE ACCESS TO BROADBAND
INTERNET AND OTHER FACILITIES A
SCHOOL SUCH AS LIBRARIES
PRESCHOOLS IN KITCHENS. THIS
BILL ADDRESSES EQUITY BY
PROVIDING MORE FUNDS TO
DISTRICTS THAT MAY HAVE A
HARDER TIME RAISING LOCAL FUNDS
AND ENROLL A GREATER NUMBER OF
LOW INCOME FOSTER CARE. AN
ENGLISH LEARNER STUDENTS. AS
YOU ALL PROBABLY KNOW THE LAST
ONE REPLACED ON THE BALLOT
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN WAS NOT
APPROVED BY THE VOTERS. THIS
BILL IS NOT IDENTICAL TO
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN. I BELIEVE
WE NEED TO MODIFY THE PROPOSAL
TO GET VOTER SUPPORT WE HEARD
THEM WE HEAR THEM- TESTIFYING
BY BY PHONE ARE- FLOOR PRESTON
WITH A CALIFORNIA AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS. AND TIM
TAYLOR WITH A SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION BEFORE I
GO TO THE WITNESSES MR CHURCH
WANT TO CLARIFY THIS IS
DIFFERENT THAN THE LAST ONE. WE
PUT ON THE BALLOT HOW WILL IT
BE DIFFERENT WILL FIRST OF ALL
IT WILL NOT BE CALLED
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN. OKAY I
WILL NOT MAKE THAT MISTAKE
AGAIN IS THAT CREATED A
SIGNIFICANT. AMOUNT OF VOTER
CONFUSION I HAD MY NEIGHBORS
COMING TO ME SAYING OH DONALD
HE WANT REVERSE PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN. THAT WAS NOT THE CASE
THIS IS A SCHOOL BOND. THEY
JUST HAPPEN TO FALL IN LINE
WITH THE PROPOSITION THIRTEEN
SO IF YOU HEARD ABOUT FIFTEEN
YEARS MIGHT WELL MAYBE FORTY
YEARS YOU MIGHT HAVE THAT SAME
PROBLEM. THE WATCH WORD ABOUT
HAPPEN AGAIN. OF THE DOLLAR
AMOUNT AYE AYE I SUSPECT WILL
BE MUCH LOWER MUCH LOWER- THE
DEVELOPER. THE ASSESSMENT
CHARGES WHERE WE'RE NOT MESSING
WITH THOSE OF BUT THE GUARD THE
PROPERTY VALUATION BASIS- WE'RE
NOT GOING TO CHANGE THE BINDING
CAPACITIES OF LOCAL DISTRICTS
THAT CREATED SOME CONCERN. LAST
TIME WE DON'T WANNA DO THAT
THIS TIME AROUND- HI RICH. IS
NOT IN THIS BAR WELL. WELL WE
FIND THAT THROUGH RESEARCH THAT
NOT AS MANY VOTERS QUITE
FRANKLY SUPPORT. BONDS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION DAY BUT THERE
WAS AN AGREEMENT MADE IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN. THAT TO ADDRESS THE
FACILITY NEEDS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION MEANING. US THE CSU
AND UC. THEM BECAUSE OUR IN
THIS BOND EVER. BUT I WHAT WE
DO WHAT WE HAVE DONE SINCE
TWENTY THIRTEEN IS COMMIT TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS EVERY
YEAR. TO EACH HIGHER- TO EACH
OF THE HIGHER. EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS CSU AND UC TO
UNDER MILLION DOLLARS FOR THEIR
FACILITY NEEDS. AND ALLOW THEM
TO SELF ON. SO THEY REALLY
DON'T. NEED THIS MONTH AND I
DON'T WANT TO BREAK THAT
AGREEMENT WE WOULDN'T WANT TO
TAKE THAT AWAY FROM THEM BY
PUTTING THAT PERSON INTO THIS
BOND- SO I BELIEVE THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN MADE HALL THAT'S
WHY THEY- ARE NOT. IN THIS BOND
GOODNESS BOND DIFFERENT THERE'S
NOT A DOLLAR AMOUNT TODAY. BUT
I SUSPECT WE'LL COME UP WITH
THE DOLLAR AMOUNT SHORTLY AND
IT WILL NOT BE AS HIGH AS THE
LAST BOND I'M VERY CONFIDENT OF
THAT. A WITH THAT WE DO HAVE
THE WITNESSES ON THE PHONE-
MISTER CHAIR. WHAT THIS IS IN
SUPPORT. BEGINNING IN THE THIRD
OF CALIFORNIA. I'M SORRY I HAD
OUR FIRST WITNESSES LAURA
PRESTON WITH THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS. THANK YOU. FOR
PRESIDENT I'M AT ONLY SUPPORTS
EIGHTY SEVENTY FIVE AND RAIL
REALIZES THAT. ADDITIONAL NEED
TO BE INVESTED IN OUR SCHOOL
FACILITIES TO ENSURE THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF OUR STUDENTS AND
EMPLOYEES MANY OF THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY ISSUES A COPY ON THE
CONTROL OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BUT SUCH AS CIRCUMSTANCES- THAT
PROBABLY MOVE ALL OF FLAG IN
OUR WATER PIPES AMERICAN P.
HOUSING FOR EVERY IMPACTED BY
NATURAL DISASTERS AND OUTSPOKEN
NINETEEN NUMBER NEED FOCUS TO
ENSURE H. FACT SYSTEMS ARE
INSTALLED AT THE PLACE TO JERRY
TRANSMISSION OF THAT THE-
IMPACT PUBLIC INPUT THE THOUGHT
LIGHT ON AREAS LACKING IN OUR
CURRENT. GOAL TO SELL THE- AB
SEVENTY FIVE IT. IMPROVEMENTS
TO ACHIEVE EQUITY IN A LONG.
FISCAL FROM. THROUGH THOSE
THANK YOU FELT. MODEL EDITOR
NAME YOU CAN PRIORITIES FOR AND-
US SUCH A BROAD. AND IT WAS
JUST ABOUT. APART THAT YOU CAN
BACKING. AND NOW WITH THE HOPE
OF AN ASK INFRASTRUCTURE. YOU
THANK HELP BY. AND EXPAND THE
USE OF FIVE. FOR THESE REASONS
AND MORE AT ISN'T STRONG
SUPPORTER AB. SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS IS TIM
TAYLOR WITH THE SMALLEST.
DISTRICTS GOOD MORNING AND I AT
CAMPAIGN EXECUTIVE AND- WE
REPRESENT FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
DISTRICTS 458% OF THE DISTRICTS
IN CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT AB SEVENTY
FIVE. WHICH WILL MAKE NECESSARY
INVESTMENTS IN DRAMATIC
IMPROVEMENTS TO SCHOOL FACILITY
PROGRAM. SMALL WORLD SCHOOL
STRUCK CALIFORNIA HAVE DEALT
WITH THE FEARS OF DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES POWER OUTAGES
EARTHQUAKES FLOOD AND
MUDSLIDES. THEIR PERSONALITIES
ARE FIFTY TO EIGHTY YEARS OLD.
AND THEY ARE TIRED IT'S TIME TO
ASSIST THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
BUILD OR MODERNIZE THEIR
FACILITIES LIKE THE REST OF THE
STATE. I WORK IN OAK GROVE
DISTRICT WE BOTH FORTY PLUS
SCHOOLS IN TWELVE YEARS. WE
HAVE A FULLY STAFFED FACILITY
DEPARTMENT TO OBTAIN STATE
FUNDING IN. A SMALL RURAL
DISTRICT HAS A SUPERINTENDENT
PRINCIPAL WHO'S ALSO THE
FACILITY DIRECTOR SPECIALIZED
DIRECTOR EL CAP AND EVERYTHING
ELSE. WHO COMPETES TO OBTAIN
THE SAME FUNDING IT IS NOT. A
FAIR COMPETITION. AND THIS BILL
WILL HELP HELP THAT ISSUE FOR
SMALL RURAL DISTRICTS BY
ESTABLISHING A PROCESS FOR
SMALL DISTRICTS TO SECURE
PRELIMINARY FUNDING FOR FIVE
YEARS THAT'S HUGE FOR US.
YOU'RE GONNA SLIDING SCALE FOR
THE STATE'S SHARE UPON BASED ON
BONDING CAPACITY. AN
UNDUPLICATED PUPIL PERCENTAGE
THAT PROVIDES RELIEF ON THAT
LOCAL MAX ASSEMBLY. MEMBER
RICARDO DONNIE TALK ABOUT.
THESE ARE. THAT LEVELS THE
FIELD IT HAD DE HAS BEEN. THE
IN THE STATE THAT SMALL WORLD.
HAVE TO DO WITH DIVIDE EVERY
DAY. IT'S ALL IT HAS CLEARLY
SHOWED A HUGE EQUITY GAP FOR
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IT IS NOW
TIME TO CLOSE THE FACILITY
PROVIDED BY SUPPORTING AB.
SEVENTY FIVE. STUDENTS AND
TEACHERS HAVE SAFE AND MODERN
SCHOOLS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND DEEPLY APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF ALL OF
DONALD LEADERSHIP TO CLOSE THE
FACILITY GAP IN ALL SCHOOLS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THERE ARE
NO DESIGNATED OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FOR THIS BILL SO AT
THIS TIME WE'RE GOING BACK TO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE ARE MODERATED CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES.
WELL DONE YES THANK YOU. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO LINE UP THREE EIGHTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
COMMENT IS FOR A DIFFERENT BILL
SORRY. THANK YOU NEXT TOOK
ONLINE OF FOUR TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU SO-
MARK MCDONALD MGI ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF ABOUT BOOKS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS KERN SAN
FRANCISCO ABOUT SANDERS SINGLE
PERALTA SAMPOERNA DNO YUBA- IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LIVE IN FIVE OR SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHARE ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THE NEXT OF
A LINE OF FIVE OH SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THE
MANAGER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF FIVE ELEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. JENNIFER BAKER ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITY. IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
FIVE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MEGAN BURKE ON BEHALF OF THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
BOILERMAKERS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ANEXO PHOTO LINE UP FOR
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING DEREK BLANKS ON
BEHALF THE CALHOUN COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF WHAT
ONE SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE ONE SIX ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ROBERT WHICH WE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. IT
YEAH NEXT THE COURT THE LINE OF
THREE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI KATIE HARTMAN AT THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE COURT. THANK YOU
EXTRALITE OF ONE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
CHARLIE DOWN HAVE TO
CALIFORNIA'S CORPORATE
SITUATION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THAT'S BECAUSE THE LIGHT OF
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO BRIAN ALLAIN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AT THE BOTTOM
LINE OF ONE TWENTY TWO YOU'RE
WIDE OPEN. DAVID NEVIN ON
BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU EXTRALITE OF
FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ACCEPTABLE
LINE UP FOR FORTY THROUGH YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY SANDALWOOD
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SUPPORT. IT'S AN
EXTRA GO TO LINE OF FIVE OH
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AT THE
START OF THE SPIN OFF ON BEHALF
OF THE COALITION FOR ADEQUATE
SCHOOL HOUSING AND THE SCHOOL
ENERGY COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AN EXTRA CLOSE THE
LINE OF ONE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU JEFF BARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS AND THE TWENTY THREE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS REPRESENT
COUNTY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
EXTRA BORDERLINE OF FIVE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS RICHARD MARX
AND ON BEHALF OF THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU X.
ABOUT A LOT OF ONE FIFTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PICKED UP
OVER LINE FIVE OH EIGHT YOUR
MIND IS OPEN. RICHARD LIED ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE HOME
BUILDERS CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY WE THANK MR O'DONNELL
FIRST LEADERSHIP WITH A LETTER
ON FILE WORK PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THE B. SEVENTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
EXTROVERT A LINE OF FIVE TWENTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN THANK YOU
ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF THE
LONG BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
EDUCATION COALITION. AND THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SUBURBAN SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
OF TWO SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. EDUCATES CORRAL A
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE SOUTH
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES- OPPOSED
BLACK RIVER BENEFIT. THANK YOU
AT THE BOTTOM LINE OF FIVE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FIVE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU NEXT ACROSS THE LINE
OF FIVE TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MICHELLE UNDERWOOD ON BEHALF OF
THE TORRANCE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MEXICO LINE OF FORCE SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIXTY
EIGHT YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANKS IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
AB SEVENTY FIVE POINTS
TRANSPOSITION TO THE- WE LOOK.
THANK YOU THAT'S ABOUT A LINE
OF FIVE TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I IN FACT LOOK THAT IS
YOU BUT I THINK THIS IS BRANDY
LEE ABOUT RIVER- REVIVAL
CHRISTIAN ACADEMY I OPPOSE. I'M
AT WORK. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. I WE DO NOT HAVE ONE
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC EYE HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO- PARTICIPATE IN
PUBLIC COMMENT. MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISTER O'DONNELL YOU MAY
NOT CLOSE LAST FOR AN AYE VOTE.
LET'S SEE I BELIEVE WE NEED A
MOTION SOME OF. SECOND MOTION
IS DUE PASSED- TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
SEVENTY FIVE THE MOTION IS BE
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION THE DONALD HI
DONNA HI KILEY. KILEY AYE
BENNETT. THE DAILY. DELHI NOT
VOTING LEAD HI WE AYE MCCARTY
AYE MCCARTY AYE CORP SILVA.
QUICKSILVER I. VERY HIGHLY OF
THE CHANGE I TO NOT VOTING.
KILEY NOT VOTING. FOR THE LAST
FOUR VOTES THE BILLS OUT.
LIVING ON TO ANOTHER BILL FROM
MISTER O'DONNELL AB FIVE EIGHTY
SIX. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR BOB.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED PERCENT EIGHTY FIVE
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO STUDENTS. I
AM ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS WHICH
WILL BE TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY
HEALTH COMMITTEE. EVEN PRIOR TO
THE PANDEMIC THAT INCIDENTS OF%
YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES WAS
INCREASING AT ALARMING RATES.
AND THE PANDEMIC WAS ONLY EXACT
AS ONLY EXACERBATED THESE
CONDITIONS. THE SCHOOLS ARE
WELL POSITIONED TO MEET THEM
HEALTH AND MENTAL NAY NEEDS OF
STUDENTS BUT THEY LACK THE
RESOURCES TO DO SO EFFECTIVELY.
FOR TOO LONG SCHOOLS OF LACK
THE GUIDANCE AND SUPPORT
NECESSARY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO MEET
STUDENTS NEEDS. WE ARE LEAVING
FEDERAL MONEY ON THE TABLE
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED ONLY TWENTY
NINE DOLLARS PER MEDI CAL
ELIGIBLE CHILD AND
REIMBURSEMENTS FOR SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH SERVICES. WHILE OTHER
STATES RECEIVE UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS. THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A TWO YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM FOR CD TO CHOOSE EXPERT
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TEAMS WHO
PROVIDE INTENSIVE SUPPORT AND
GUIDANCE TO ALIA'S. THE TEAMS
WILL ASSIST THE L. A. IS WITH
THE EXCEPTION FEDERAL FUNDING
THROUGH EXISTING PROGRAMS LIKE
THE L. A. BILLING OPTION
PROGRAM. THEY WILL ALSO ASSIST
THE ALIAS WITH ESTABLISHING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COUNTY HEALTH
AGENCIES. COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDERS AND HEALTH PLANS TO
MAXIMIZE THE SERVICES AND
REVENUES AVAILABLE FOR SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH SERVICES. AT THE
CONCLUSION OF THE TWO YEAR OLD
PROFILER PROGRAM THE
PARTICIPATING ELEAZAR WILL
DEVELOP A SUSTAINABLE MODEL.
WITH RELIABLE ON GOING FUNDING
FROM MULTIPLE SOURCES TO MEET
STUDENTS NEEDS. THE CITY ABLE
E. CD WILL USE LESSONS LEARNT
TO DEVELOP RESOURCES AND
SUPPORTS TO SCALE UP THESE
EFFORTS ACROSS OUR STATE. THIS
BILL SPONSORED BY THE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND AND
IS CURRENTLY SUPPORTED BY OVER
FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL AS
DOZENS OF INDIVIDUALS. SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE EIGHT SIX
TODAY ARE ALEX BRISCOE THAT
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S TRUST AND
RUBEN REST SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE ROEBLING ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT. FIRST WHAT IS IN
SUPPORT IS MISTER BRISKET YOU
MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU- OUR I
NEED A COLLEGE PRINCIPAL AND
THE PRINCIPAL OF THE CALIFORNIA
TREE TRUNKS. A COALITION
SUPPORTIVE INITIATIVE OVER FOUR
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS TO HELP
REIMAGINE OUR STATE'S APPROACH
TO SUPPORTING THE SOCIAL AND
EMOTIOAL HEALTH OF CHILDREN. I
WILL ADD THAT I COME TO THIS
WORK HAVE YOU BEEN AFFECTED
SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC SCHOOLS AT
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL RESEARCH
CENTER OPENED. AND FOR TWELVE
YEARS IN LEADERSHIP STYLE TO
HELP DIRECTOR ALAMEDA COUNTY.
WHERE WE DECIDED DELIVERED OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY SCHOOL
BASED PROGRAMS FUNDED BY
MEDICAID- I DID MY PRIVILEGE TO
SUPPORT THEMSELVES FIRST AND
FOREMOST I THINK THERE'S A
UNIVERSAL CONSENSUS NOW THAT
SOMETHING'S GOING ON THE LIVES
OF CHILDREN WE HAVE SEEN A
11004% INCREASE IN INPATIENT
ADMISSIONS FOR PERSONAL HEALTH
AND A 50% INTEREST INCREASE IN
PEDIATRIC. BACKGROUND THAT IS
BEFORE THE OF IT. EVERYTHING WE-
IT TO PASS. WE CAN DATA SHOWS A
31% INCREASE AND EATING
UTILIZATION. FOR TEENS THAT
BUTTON. AND MARK CAL OUR STATE
MEDICAID COULD TO STRUGGLE TO
MEET THAT NEED. SCHOOLS ARE
ESSENTIAL TO ANY SOLUTION AT
SCALE SO THE CHALLENGES FACING
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE. AT WHAT
MUST PARTNER WITH MEDI CAL
CALIFORNIA'S VERSION OF
MEDICAID AND DOING CREATIVE
WORK IS. UNFORTUNATELY OUR
PROGRAM CALIFORNIA'S WITH A
PROGRAM OF BLOCK MEDICAID
PROGRAM THE LARGEST IN THE
NATION. IS AMONG THE NATION'S
WORST. SCHOOLS ARE ESSENTIAL
NOT JUST BECAUSE SCHOOLS ARE
GROUND ZERO FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS. BUT THAT CENTRAL
BECAUSE CHILDREN EIGHT EIGHTEEN
AT THE LOWEST RATE OF PRIMARY
CARE UTILIZATION OF ANY
DEMOGRAPHIC GROUP. SO THIS BILL
IS ABOUT DEFINING THE NEXT OF
HEALTH EDUCATION. IN THE WEEKS
THAT ARE SCALABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE ADDRESSING THE
CHALLENGES OF OUR STATE
MEDICAID PROGRAM AND LEVERAGING
HE UNIQUE ROLE THAT SCHOOL CAN
AND SHOULD PLAY IN SUPPORTING
THE SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL HEALTH
CHILDREN. THE COUPLE FINAL
PIECE OF DATA THAT NAME THE
CHALLENGE LESS THAN 5% OF THE
SIX MILLION CHILDREN IN
MEDICAID IT'S ABOUT FIVE POINT
FIVE MILLION NOW BUT WE
ANTICIPATE ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND CHILDREN. COMING INTO
MEDICAID WONDERFUL IMPACT OF
THE PANDEMIC IS REALIZED. SIX
OUT OF TEN CHILDREN IN THE
STATE ARE ELIGIBLE OR ENROLLED
IN MEDI CAL LESS THAN 5% FACT
THAT ANY SUPPORT AT ALL FOR
THAT SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
DEVELOPMENT. WE MUST. MAKE THAT
THE BEST WAY TO TEACH SCHOOLS.
YES THAT'S APP AND I'LL GET
LIVER SYSTEM. AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING SOCIAL AND EMOTIONAL
HEALTH CHILDREN'S THEY CAN SEE.
IN SCHOOL LIFE. NEXT YOU'LL
HEAR SUPERINTENDENT REYES OF
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT THOSE ARE
PLEASURE THE TOP ON OTHER'S TRY.
TO ALLOW COUPLE YEARS COURT
SUPPORT OAKLAND HIS TEAM. TO
HELP UNDER. THE COMPLEX
LANDSCAPE OF MEDIC CAL THERE
ARE AT LEAST SEVEN DIFFERENT
PLAYERS. SCHOOLS MUST LEARN TO
NEGOTIATE THREE ECHO CANNOT
HELP THAT SOME. MANAGED CARE
PLANS AND THEIR OWN BILLING
OPPORTUNITIES ON THE BILL
ACTION PROGRAM. TO PRETEND
REYES COMPLETED THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THEY FACE THE
DISTRICT AND IT WAS A MODEL FOR
HOW WE INTENDED FOR DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE. AND ACCESSING
FEDERAL DOLLARS THAT CHILDREN.
AREN'T SEXY. THANK YOU. NEXT
WITH US PROCEED. HELLO GOOD I
REGRET THAT I MISSED IT BUT OF
THE SCHOOLS IN TOMORROW WELL
LET A SMALL SCHOOL THAT SERVING
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND TWO STUDENTS
IN PRESCHOOL GRADE. OUR THE
CITY IS CHARACTERIZED BY HIGH
POVERTY RATE. I THANK THE TEACH
HERE TO HELP THAT BECAUSE
NINETY AND 95% OF OUR STUDENTS
LEVEL THE POVERTY LINE. IT ALSO
HELPED THAT BUTTON FORTUNATELY
QUARTERBACK. ARE HOME. THREE
THIRTY PM PACIFIC FROM
CHALLENGE THEM ALIVE GARCIA.
GALLAGHER CREATE A NUMBER OP
THE FROM WHAT IMPORTANT TO ME
RESPONSE. OF A PUBLIC DISTRICTS
SUCH AS ROBOT WE LEARNED LONG
AGO THAT WE NOT A GREAT DEAL OF
ATTENTION TO THE MENTAL HEALTH
THE MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF OUR
STUDENTS. OF ALL THE IN. HAT
THE PAST YEAR DURING THE COVER.
NINETEEN WE HAVE SEEN A GREAT
DEAL OF EVIDENCE THAT EVEN THE
YOUNG WE SERVER WITH AND-
DEPRESSION AND A BLOCK MANY OF
THE SOCIAL TO BUILD DURING THE
MONTHS OF ISOLATION. WE HAVE
LONG YOURSELF TO GET THAT BOND
SUPPORTER. BUT WE CAN TRAFFIC
RESOURCES ONLY SO FAR. AT THE
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICT WE
CONTINUE TO SEARCH OUT FUNDING
FOR INCLUDING REIMBURSEMENT
FIFTY PART I. WORK IN THIS
AREA. THE MANAGED CARE SYSTEM.
IT VERY. AND NAVIGATING THE
SYSTEM IN ORDER TO ACCESS THE
FUNDING- AT THE CURRENTLY EXIST
IT'S DIFFICULT TO SAY THE LEAST.
REPUBLICANS TRIED TO WORK WITH
COMMUNITY PARTNERS TO PROVIDE
MENTAL HEALTH THE PARK IS
GETTING. EXAMPLE WE ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION AND THE RESULT OF
AN ADDITIONAL CONNECTION AT ONE
OF OUR GOALS. BUT WE STILL FALL
FAR SHORT OF THE MEETING THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS. WILL
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO PROVIDE
NEEDED GUIDANCE AND TECHNICAL
SUPPORT SO. WHAT THAT CAN
ACCEPT THE KIND OF FUNDING THAT
WE NEED FOR THE PRODUCTS
SERVICE THE FIRST YEAR. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU THERE ARE NO
DESIGNATED WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU FOR
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF ONE FIFTY
NINE. SORRY THAT JUST DROPPED
OVER A LINE OF OP FIVE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS CURRENTLY CHIANG WITH
CALIFORNIA'S SUGGESTED. WE
STRONG SUPPORTER IF YOU COPY
PIC THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
TWO FIVE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI BECAUSE AND
ENVIRONMENT AND- CONTROLLER
PARENTS AND I'LL AB ONE ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXAVAR
LINE OF FIVE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING
THIS IS DANIELLE LLOYD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LINE JOB FAMILY
SERVICES REPRESENTING COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS BY DEFAULT
EVERYTHING'S IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE FIVE FIVE
TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO ERIN ANTI WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
FIVE EIGHTY SIX. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE UP FOR SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I'M
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
CHAIR PATRICK O'DONNELL WHO WAS
AN ARROGANT BE LET. THANK YOU
THURMOND BACKTALK ORDER LINE OF.
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT. BYE BYE
JOHNNY HOWARD. GO AHEAD
SONNABEND HOWARD ON BEHALF OF
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND
SPONSORED THE BILL STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF FIVE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MONICA
COATES IS A BIT DIFFERENT KIND
ENOUGH TO HIM A COUNTY FELL
BACK STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO CAROLINA FIVE THIRTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS NEKRON THEY'LL BE
HAPPY WOULD BE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PRIVATE SPECIAL
EDUCATION SCHOOLS AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
BOTH IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU THE
NEXT TO GO LINE UP TO SIXTY
SEVEN YOU KNOW I DON'T OPEN. I
WELL A PASS AND GO OUT THERE
LOOK AT THE CAN'T. UPLOAD THANK
YOU WE HAVE NO FURTHER HIS
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER DONALD JUDD
CLOSE AS FOR KNIFE OF THE
FUTURE. ATTITUDE WILL MOTION.
SOME OF. WE ARE MOTION AND A
SECOND THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
A HEALTH WITH AMENDMENTS- TO BE
PROCESSED IN THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB FIVE
EIGHTY SIXTY PASSED TO
COMMITTEE ON HEALTH WITH
AMENDMENTS TO BE TAKEN AND
HEALTH. THE DONALD HI DONALD HI
KILEY. KILEY HYPHEN HI THEN I.
MCCARTY I QUIT SILVA.
QUIKSILVER I FIX THAT. SIX
VOTES ARE THE BILL IS OUT IT'S
ALSO COME TO MY ATTENTION THAT
WE HAVE YET TO TAKE UP THE
CONSENT AGENDA US WILL DO SO AT
THIS TIME WITH A MOTION ON
CONSENT. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM ONE AB
ELEVEN TWELVE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED YOUR PREPARATIONS.
FILE ITEM TO AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PRIVACY AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION. FILE ITEM
TWELVE AB FOUR FOUR NINETY
EIGHT. DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN AB AT NINE FORTY FIVE
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. FILE
ITEM SEVENTEEN A. C. R. FIFTY
THREE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. DONALD FIVE
O'DONNELL I KILEY. KILEY AYE
BENNETT AYE FINANCE AYE DALY E.
LEAI MCCARTY THIRTY AYE CORK
SILVA QUIKSILVER I'D SIX OF SIX
VOTES THOSE BILLS ROUTES AND
WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR FINAL ITEM
ON THE AGENDA A. B. EIGHT
THIRTY NINE ALSO AUTHORED BY MR
O'DONNELL THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS AB EIGHT THIRTY
NINE WILL PROVIDE AN ADDITIONAL
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT K. TWELVE C.
T. PROGRAM'S. HIGH QUALITY CTE
PROGRAMS IN OUR SCHOOLS ARE
CRITICAL TO ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS GAIN THE SKILLS THEY
NEED TO ENTER THE WORKFORCE
FROM BARK ONS POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND TRAINING THE
STRENGTH OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY DEPENDS ON A SKILLED
WORKFORCE IN CTE PROGRAMS ARE
AN ESSENTIAL PART OF BUILDING
THAT WORK FORCE. K. TWELVE CT
IS CURRENTLY FUNDED AT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS PER
YEAR ONE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
FOR THE C. T. INCENTIVE GRANT
PROGRAM ADMINISTERED AT THE CD
AND ANOTHER ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION PER FOR PER PER YEAR
FROM THE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAM THROUGH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS LESS THAN 50% OF QUALITY
FOR QUALIFIED APPLICANTS
FUNDING REQUEST FOR THESE TWO
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN FILLED AS
THE DEMAND HAS BEEN WELL OVER
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
EACH YEAR. CLEARLY THERE IS A
NEED FOR ADDITIONAL ON GOING
FUNDING TO SUPPORT HIGH QUALITY
CTE PROGRAMS. THIS BILL WOULD
INCREASE THE OVERALL FUNDING
FOR K. TWELVE C. T. TWO FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN THE
SEA TECH PROGRAM AND ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN THE
STRONG WORK FORCE PROGRAM. BUT
I JUST FROM PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE. C. T. WHATEVER YOU
CALL THEM VOCATIONAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS ARE PROGRAMS THAT HELP
STUDENTS. AND HELP OUR ECONOMY-
MANY STUDENTS- WHO ARE INVOLVED
IN C. T. PROGRAMS GO TO SCHOOL
QUITE FRANKLY JUST FOR THE C.
T. PROGRAM. IT IS WHAT ENGAGES
THEM SO THERE'S A VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE
THEIR STUDENTS SUCCEED. BUT
ALSO OUR ECONOMY SUCCEEDS
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
THIRTY NINE OR PAUL GOT HOLD
SUPERINTEND OF THE SAN DIEGO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. AND
LINDA GRAINGER. GRAINGER CENTER
INTENT OF THE EDEN AREA R. O.
P. THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS AND
SUPPORT A PROCEED. THANK YOU
GERMAN AGO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
PROJECT SETTING COUNTY OPS THAT
TESTIFIED ON BEHALF OF THE CTP
COALITION WAS REPORTED TO
DISTRICTS AND A HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE CHARTER SCHOOLS. ACCORDING
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT. ACT 30%
OF SAN DIEGANS. WHAT FIVE AND
OVER LACK HOST SECONDARY GRANT
ARE CALLED COURSE REQUIRED FILL
JOB- OPENINGS IN OUR REGIONAL
WHILE. IT OCCURS OFFER A LIVING
WAGE WOULD. THE NEED TO OUT
SOURCE FOR SKILLED LABOR OUT OF
STATE OR OUT OF COUNTRY. WE
ALSO KNOW THAT NOT EVERY CHILD
IS AN APPLE. IS GREATLY
TRADITIONALISTS GRANT PARK
COULDN'T. KEEP PROGRAMS UP WITH
MUCH NEEDED CONNECTION PERSON
WHO. MAKE AN ARK MOMENT BECAUSE
PATIENTS E. G. PATHWAYS OPEN
INCREASING ACADEMIC OUTCOMES
AND GRADUATION RATES.
PARTICULARLY FOR HISTORICALLY
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES FOR
EXAMPLE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
TO ALLOW PUBLIC COMPLETION
WOULD BE SEVENTEEN PERCENT.
TWENTY FOUR PERCENT. IN OUR
COUNTRY. L. G. IT'S PROBLEMS
AND MAKING TRAVEL COMMUNITIES
USING THE SAME METRICS. PATHWAY
COMPLETION FOR AMERICAN INDIANS
INCREASED 122401% OF THE COURSE
THIS CURRENT. REGULATION RIGHT
SHOOTING OVER 80% OVER 15%
INCREASE. CHALLENGES IN
STARTING ENHANCE YOUR BILL P.
ETT PROGRAMS ALIGNED WITH THE
DEMAND FOR SKILLED LABOR NOW
PROJECTED INTO THE NEXT TEN
YEARS REQUIRES ONGOING SUPPORT
RESOURCE. FOR EXAMPLE ONE OF
THE SECTORS EXPERIENCING A
SIGNIFICANT SHORTAGE OF SKILLED
LABOR. IS CYBER SECURITY
HARDWARE AND SOFTWARE REQUIRED
STATE ALONG WITH THE INDUSTRY
HAS DRASTICALLY CHANGED WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO. FINALLY LIKE
TO SHARE WAS PROBABLY MOST
POWERFUL TESTIMONY IN THOSE
WITH MORE OF OUR STUDENTS
RECENT GRADS SHARED WITH U.
YOUR EXPERIENCE IN COMPUTER
ENGINEERING WHAT IF YOU HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY COLLEGE COURSES
WHILE IN HIGH SCHOOL. AS WELL
AS AN ONLINE CERTIFICATION
COURSE FOR MAJOR SOFTWARE
COMPANY. ARE GRADUATION HE
PROUDLY DISPLAYED A JOB OFFER.
SIGNIFICANT STARTING SALAS IN
THIS PARTICULAR COMPANY THANK
SCHOOL OFFICIALS TEACHERS. AND
THE PROGRAM BECAUSE YOU WOULD
BE MAKING MORE MONEY. THAN BOTH
OF HIS PARENTS COMBINED IN THAT
WE GET HELP THEM. WE BELIEVE
THAT EVERY STUDENT SHOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO SPEAK IN A ROBUST
INDUSTRY EXPERIENCE OUR
SCHOOLS. CAN'T THANK YOU ENOUGH
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOT
WITNESS. MY IS ONE GRANGER AND
I AM THE SUPER OF THE AREA R.
O. P. SERVING APPROXIMATELY
FIVE HUNDRED IN THE CATHOLIC
ABOUT A WORD FAMILY ANDRO AND
SAMARINDA DISTRICT WE STUDENTS
FOR AND HER AND- OVER A HUNDRED
FIFTY CLASSES AND THIRTEEN IN
SECTORS. THE STATE OF BIRTH THE
ROLE THAT HE PRO BY OUR SCHOOLS
WITH A COMMITMENT TO ME SEATED
FUNDING MINUTE AND THE TO THE
EIGHT NINETEEN STATE BUDGET ACT
AT A HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY WELL WE
APPRECIATE THAT THERE IS A
DEDICATED LINE ITEM IN THE
ANNUAL STATE BUDGET FOR C. T.
THE CURRENT AMOUNT IS
INSUFFICIENT THE DEMAND FOR
THIRTY TWO DOLLARS CONSISTENTLY
OUTSTRIPS THE SUPPLY BY MORE
THAN DOUBLE EACH YEAR. AB EIGHT
THIRTY NINE WOULD INCREASE THE
TAKE AMOUNT TO THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING MORE
EFFECTIVELY MEETING THE CURRENT
DEMAND FOR THE GREATLY NEEDED
GRANT PROGRAM AS A PROVIDER OF
P. T. E. R. R. O. P.
SIGNIFICANTLY RELIES ON THE
STATE'S COMPETITIVE GRANT
AWARDS TO MAINTAIN OUR HIGH
QUALITY INNOVATIVE PROGRAM
BECAUSE WE DID NOT RECEIVE
DIRECT FUNDING FROM THE STATE.
AN INCREASE IN SEATED FUNDING
WOULD GO A LONG WAY TO ENSURE
THAT OUR PROGRAMS REMAIN
EXCEPTIONAL AND RESPONSIVE TO
THE NEEDS OF THE LABOR MARKET
THAT WE CONTINUE TO PROVIDE OUR
STUDENTS WITH THE SKILLS AND
EDUCATION THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY ECONOMY SPECIFICALLY WE
HAVE YOU SEE TO DOLLARS THAT WE
RECEIVE FROM THE STATE TO
MAINTAIN THE DELIVERY OF HIGH
QUALITY CTP AND THIRTEEN
INDUSTRY SECTORS FOR EXAMPLE WE
HAVE EXPANDED OUR MEDICAL
PROGRAM AND HIRED AN ADDITIONAL
TEACHER. TO MEET THAT DEMAND
AND WE HAVE ADDED A
CYBERSECURITY PATHWAY WITHOUT
EATING FUNDING I DON'T KNOW HOW
WE WOULD HAVE ADDED THESE
PROGRAM ROBUST HIGH QUALITY
ACCOUNTABLE P. T. PROGRAMS MAKE
A SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTION TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY BY
PROVIDING THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
WITH THE TRAINING AND SKILLS
NECESSARY TO BE PRODUCTIVE
INCOME EARNING TAX PAIN SAID AT
THE- INVESTING IN THE STUDENT
NOW WILL HELP CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY THRIVE FOR THESE
REASONS. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
EIGHT THIRTY NINE NINE AND-
URGE THE COMMITTEE MEMBER TO
VOTE I ON THE- THANK YOU WE
HAVE NO DOES WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION SO WE'LL TAKE IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS YES
ASSEMBLYWOMAN QUIRK SILVA- I
REALLY APPRECIATE THIS BILL AS
I HAVE SEEN THESE PROGRAMS WORK
FIRST HAND. IN MY DISTRICT AND
IN THE SCHOOLS HAT I
REPRESENT- EVERYTHING FROM OUR
POINT PARK HIGH SCHOOL WHICH I
BELIEVE HE WENT OUT TO SEE
WHERE THEY HAVE AN AUTOMOTIVE
PROGRAM FEEDING DIRECTLY INTO
YES BOTH OF YOU- INTO CYPRESS
COLLEGE WHERE THEY'RE WORKING
DIRECTLY WITH- TOYOTA AND THESE
A YOUNG. STUDENTS ARE COMING
OUT OF ALREADY BEING HIRED
BEFORE THEY EVEN FINISH THE
PROGRAM- SOMETIMES AT WELL OVER
MINIMUM WAGE SO I REALLY THINK
IT'S AN EXCELLENT PATHWAY AND
I'D LIKE TO BE. ASK YOU TO BE A
JOINT HEALTH AUTHOR. AND I MOVE
THE BILL SECOND. MISTER BENNETT.
THIS COUNTRY AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE GOING TO FACE A
SEVERE CRISIS IN TERMS OF
SKILLED OF TRAINED WELL TRAINED
LABOR AND- I APPRECIATE THIS
BILL- AND I CERTAINLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL IN THE LONG RUN WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO REALLY RE VAMP
BUT AND DO MUCH BETTER I SHOULD
SAY WE SHOULD REALLY EXPAND THE
EFFORTS IN TERMS OF THIS CAREER
TRAINING. FOR THAT POPULATION
OF STUDENTS THAT ARE NOT GOING
TO GO THROUGH A TRADITIONAL
ACADEMIC BACKGROUND BUT ALSO
BECAUSE OF HOW FAST THE
TECHNOLOGY IS CHANGING HOW WE
HAVE TO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT SO I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THIS- THIS EVERTON
WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL. I
SEE NO OTHER- I SEE NO OTHER
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- SOAP MODERATED CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. THANK YOU FOR
ANY SUPPORTER OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YEAH BUT- MY NAME
IS RUSS CALL CRAYON YOUNG A
FORMER BOILED SCHOOL BOARD
PRESIDENT IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. ANEXO
BORDERLINE OF FOUR FOUR THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRISTINA MARCELLUS
ON BEHALF OF THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO
CAROLINA OF FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HELLO AGAINST
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION WITH
THREE SUPPORT THE BILL. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF FIVE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON FRED JONES PART
OF THE GET REAL COALITION
GRATEFUL FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL'S LEADERSHIP ON C. T.
IN THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND NEXT OF OUR LINE OF
FIVE FIVE FORTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KYLE
HYLAND ON BEHALF OF THE CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION TO EMPOWER
TO THIRTY COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF FIVE FORTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHRIS WALKER ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
SHEETMETAL CONDITIONING
CONTRACTORS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL AND THANK YOU TO
THE OFFICE. THANK YOU NEXT TO
THE LINE OF FOUR SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL CUTTING OFF
CALIFORNIANS VOICES IS TOTALLY
WRONG AND HE IS NOT FIT TO BE
CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE RECALL.
THANK YOU AMBLECOTE HELLO LINE
FIVE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YET LORD YEAH NOT BE UP
CALIFORNIA MAY PRACTICAL
TECHNOLOGY SO SHE'S IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK. THANK YOU. AND
ACCESSIBLE LINE OF SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON AMANDA CALDERON
WITH TRIPLE LAY IN SUPPORT
THANK. THANK YOU. AN EXTRA GOAL
LINE OF FIVE BUT TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON ANDREA BALL ON THE
HALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THE
CENTRAL VALLEY EDUCATION
COALITION THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF FIVE FORTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI DEFEATED
BY A CHAP ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TELLING BURKE
TIGHTENING AND A SPONSOR OF
EIGHTY EIGHT. EIGHT THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF
FIVE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KING ONE
YOUNG ON BEHALF OF THE PROJECT
LEAD THE WAY IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
NEW REENTER. CAILLAT
NEGOTIATION OF CAREER AND
COLLEGE READINESS ORGANIZATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND GREAT
CONFLICT ABOUT. THANK YOU
NEXAVAR LINE OF FIVE FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I FORTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU HAVE IS
A MUTE. OKAY THANK YOU WILL GO
ONLINE OF FIVE FIFTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS MATT
PATTON FROM THE CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURAL TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE NEXT
RECORD A LINE OF ONE THIRTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE THIRTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON SURELY GAS ON BEHALF
TO HELP BRIDGE OVER SITUATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE ONE MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
EYE HERE- IN THE HEARING ROOM
AS WELL. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARE
MIKE WEST ON BEHALF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- AS THIS IS OUR LAST BILL
THE DAY I JUST WANNA TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WHO TOOK THE TIME.
TO PARTICIPATE IN OUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS TODAY I AND
I WANT TO APOLOGIZE TO THOSE
WHO HAD THAT RIGHT ARBITRARILY
VIOLATED THAT IS NOT CORRECT
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON. I WANT TO
SAY THAT SOMETHING THAT SHOULD
NEVER HAPPEN IN THIS CHAMBER IS
SOMETHING I'VE NEVER SEEN
HAPPEN BEFORE. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT IS ALL TOO
TYPICAL OF WHAT THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS BECOME. SO AT
THAT TIME AT THIS TIME I WOULD
LIKE TO- OPEN THIS FOR. A FINAL
VOTE THE MOTION IS TO PASS. A
TO APPROPRIATIONS TO HAVE
EMOTIONAL SECOND. I THINK WE
DO. NOT A SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE
THE MOTION IS THE PAST YEAR
PREPARATIONS O'DONNELL. BUT ON
ALL AYE KILEY. AYE KILEY AYE
BENNETT. I DALLI DALLI I'D LI.
WE AYE MCCARTY HI MCCARTY AYE
CORK SILVA. RICK SILVA I. SEVEN
YES SEVEN THAT'S THE BILL IS
OUT. THE WHOLE BURKE I DON'T
KNOW A JOURNEY HEARING LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ADAMS.
MEMBERS OF YOU WISH TO ADD ON
IT ANY BILL PLEASE STAY SEATED
WITH YOUR MICROPHONES ON WELL
COMMITTEE SECRETARY ALSO ROLE
ON EACH ITEM. SURE CAN I JUST
ASK ONE QUESTION I'VE IDEA.
BEING NEW THERE WAS AN
INVITATION BY MISTER RAMOS TO
CO AUTHOR HIS BILL CAN I ADD TO
CO AUTHORSHIP REQUEST ALSO AT
THIS TIME GREAT THANK YOU.
STARTING WITH CONSENT. DALY HI
SALLY I. SEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
THREE AB NINE SIXTY SEVEN SALLY.
HI SALLY I THIRTY HI MCCARTY I.
FILE ITEM FOR AB FIVE TWENTY.
THE CHAIR VOTING I DALY AYE
DALY AYE. FILE ITEM FIVE AB
EIGHT NINETY NINE THE CHAIR
VOTING I DALY HI SALLY I. FILE
ITEM SIX AB FIVE NINETY NINE
THE CHAIR VOTING I DALY HI
SALLY I'VE- FILE ITEM NINE AB
SEVENTY FIVE THE CHURCH
BUILDING HI BENNETT. FIVE
MINUTES HI OF. FILE ITEM TEN AB
FIVE EIGHTY SIX THE CHAIR
VOTING I DALY HI SALLY I'VE-
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB TEN FIFTY
FIVE. THE CHAIR VOTING I
BELIEVE. HI LEAI CORK SILVA
WORKS OF I'D- FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
AB FOUR SIXTY NINE THE CHAIR
VOTING I BELIEVE HI LEAI. FILE
ITEM SIXTEEN AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE THE CHAIR VOTING I LIED
HI LEE I. THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU.